[Musique]
la séance est reprise
je crois que Madame Goulet voudrait
faire un rappel au règlement
se passe sur l'article 29 bis de notre
règlement voici bientôt deux mois
monsieur le Président et vous le savez
le 16 septembre dernier Macha Amini une
jeune iranienne a été assassiné par la
police du régime des mollats depuis lors
des centaines de morts et des blessés
plus de 15000 jeunes gens sont
aujourd'hui emprisonnés avec des procès
sans avocat et des peines de mort
ils sont incarcérés aujourd'hui les
premières condamnations à mort sont
tombées et aujourd'hui monsieur le
Président l'Iran pleure Kyan pire Falak
10 ans 10 ans monsieur le Président mort
d'une balle dans la tête
en rentrant de l'école l'Iran assassine
sa jeunesse sous nos yeux c'est la
raison pour laquelle monsieur le
Président je souhaitais que notre Haute
Assemblée puisse d'abord évidemment
manifester son soutien avec les
Iraniennes et les Iraniens qui luttent
aujourd'hui pour leur liberté et
organiser aussitôt possible après la
session budgétaire un débat sur cette
question qui me semble extrêmement
importante je vous remercie monsieur le
président
ma chère collègue nous ressentons votre
émotion nous avons eu un débat le 5
octobre
sur la situation en Iran et nous notons
votre désir que nous partagerons aussi
avec la Commission à ce que une fois la
session budgétaire tous les cas je peux
vous dire que personnellement je suis
avec beaucoup d'attention la situation
en Iran et la situation qui avait aux
hommes et aux femmes
je vous donne donc acte de votre rappel
au règlement
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi de finance considérée
comme adopté par l'Assemblée nationale
et en application de l'article 49 alinéa
3 de la Constitution pour 2023 dans la
discussion générale j'avais donné la
parole à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'Économie des Finances
c'est de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique
la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapport en général monsieur le président
de la commission des finances monsieur
le ministre Gabriel Attal je suis très
heureux de vous retrouver pour vous
présenter ce projet de loi de finance je
reviens tout juste ce matin du G20 qui
s'est tenu à Bali avec le président de
la République
à un moment où les nuages s'accumulent
sur l'économie mondiale
le risque principal est identifié
un conflit qui dure en Ukraine
et qui crée de l'incertitude pour tous
les acteurs économiques sans exception
la traduction de ce risque celle que
nous connaissons depuis maintenant
plusieurs mois qui pénalise le
compatriotes qui pénalise nos
entreprises qui inquiète profondément la
société française
c'est une inflation élevée
une inflation qui a d'abord touché les
prix du gaz et de l'électricité qui ont
été multipliés par 5 par 6 par 7
et qui sait maintenant transmise au prix
alimentaire c'est-à-dire à la vie la
plus quotidienne de nos compatriotes
s'il y avait un seul chiffre à retenir
qui résulte de cette guerre en Ukraine
c'est que le choc énergétique
représente désormais plus de 3% de la
richesse européenne
3% de la richesse européenne qui sont
allés du continent européen vers les
pays producteurs de pétrole et de gaz
soit 1000 euros par citoyen européen
dont l'Europe a été privée au profit des
producteurs de pétrole et de gaz
il y a donc
urgence à maintenir une politique qui
nous permettra de ramener en 2023
l'inflation à des niveaux plus
raisonnables
dans ce contexte économique difficile
l'économie française résiste
elle résiste avec une croissance qui est
restée positive au troisième trimestre
elle résiste avec un investissement des
entrepreneurs qui restent dynamiques
elle résiste avec un chômage qu'elle
continuait de baisser encore le mois
dernier elle résiste avec une
attractivité qui est maintenue par ce
que nous avons maintenu avec constance
les mêmes lignes de politique économique
qui aurait imaginé il y a seulement
quelques années que la capitalisation
boursière de la place de Paris serait
plus importante que la capitalisation
boursière de la place de Londres ces
choses faites et c'est le résultat de la
constance de la politique économique et
fiscale que nous avons conduite depuis
plus de 5 ans avec le président de la
République
dans ce contexte de forte inflation
la priorité de gouvernement français
celle qui se lit dans le projet de loi
de finances que nous vous présentons
avec le ministre des comptes publics
Gabriel Attal c'est de protéger les
ménages et de protéger les entreprises
contre les conséquences de l'inflation
nous maintenons un bouclier énergétique
pour l'année 2023 qui va permettre
d'éviter au ménage de payer une facture
de 180 ou 200 euros en plus par mois
nous allons maintenir une aide pour les
entreprises et développer de nouvelles
aides sur lesquelles je reviendrai nous
avons mis en place un chèque énergie
nous proposons une aide de
complémentaire pour ceux qui se
chauffent au fioul en plus de toutes les
mesures que nous avons prises
d'indexation des pensions de retraite
d'extation du salaire minimal qui je le
rappelle a augmenté de plus de 8% depuis
maintenant plus d'un an ou de
l'indexation des imminats sociaux sur
l'augmentation des prix
mais je veux être clair avec vous
en 2023 nous passerons à des aides plus
ciblées en 2023 le ciblage des aides
pour les ménages comme pour les
entreprises devraient être la règle
pourquoi
d'abord parce que c'est une question de
justice
cibler les aides ce n'est plus aider
tout le monde de manière indifférencier
c'est aider ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin
c'est d'aider les ménages qu'on les
revenus les plus faibles céder les
familles qui sont le plus en difficulté
céder les entreprises qui ne peuvent pas
répercuter l'augmentation de leur coût
énergétique sur leur niveau de vente ou
leur niveau de prix
c'est une question de justice la
deuxième raison du ciblage c'est que
nous devons tous prendre conscience
que le choc énergétique n'est pas
transitoire
il est structuré
et que par conséquent nous devons nous
adapter à ce nouvel environnement
énergétique lié au choc de la guerre en
Ukraine et à la transition climatique il
faudra donc à un moment donné que les
prix du gaz et les prix de l'électricité
en France retrouve les prix de marché et
pour le faire nous préférons le faire de
manière progressive
en fixant le cap très clairement
vis-à-vis de nos compatriotes plutôt que
de le faire de manière brutale
mon intervention est donc l'occasion de
dire avec beaucoup de clarté que nous
commencerons à partir de début 2023 a
ciblé mieux les aides pour faire face un
choc énergétique qui est structuré et
permettre au prix en France de retrouver
les prix de marché c'est ce qui nous
amènera à augmenter les prix du gaz et
de l'électricité de 15% au début de
l'année 2023
c'est ce qui nous amènera à mettre fin à
la remise de 30 centimes d'euros sur les
carburants ça n'exclut pas au contraire
d'aider ce que n'ont le plus besoin d'où
soutenir ceux qui ont impérativement
besoin de leur véhicule pour aller
travailler pour se rendre sur le lieu de
travail mais c'est l'exemple je crois
caractéristique du passage d'une aide
massive qui concerne tout le monde et
qui par conséquent n'est pas
nécessairement ni la plus juste ni la
plus efficace à une aide plus sublimée
vers les ménages qui ont réellement
besoin vers ceux qui vont travailler va
les apprentis faire les aides-soignantes
faire les commerçants vers les artisans
artisans du bâtiment des travaux publics
qui sillonnent les routes de France et
qui n'ont pas d'autre choix que
d'utiliser leur véhicule le ciblage doit
donc être la règle pour que les prix de
l'électricité et du gaz en France et les
prix d'énergie de manière générale
retrouve les prix de marché pour
accompagner la sortie de crise en 2023
nous aiderons également je l'ai indiqué
les entreprises
et je veux dire à quel point nous
entendons avec l'ensemble du
gouvernement les inquiétudes de toutes
les entreprises petites ou grandes qui
voient exploser le coût de leur facture
de l'électricité ou leur facture de gaz
je veux leur dire avec beaucoup de
gravité que nous les avons toujours
soutenus pendant la crise du covid et
pendant les difficultés conjoncturelles
dans les bons jours comme dans les
mauvais jours nous continuerons à
soutenir notre tissu industriel notre
tissu économique nos PME nos TPE et nos
entreprises industrielles nous le ferons
d'abord de manière structurelle en vous
proposant la suppression
définitive la CVAE et une nouvelle
baisse des impôts de production que nous
vous proposons de faire en deux fois 4
milliards en 2023 4 milliards en 2024
pour soutenir la compétitivité nos
entreprises industrielles et j'entends
tous ceux qui nous disent mais les
Allemands font davantage pour
entreprises les Américains protègent
plus leur secteur industriel dans ce cas
soutenez une baisse des impôts de
production qui va permettre au PME
industriel de gagner en compétitivité et
de retrouver le niveau d'excellence qui
doit être le leur nous le ferons aussi
de manière conjoncturelle face à
l'augmentation des prix de l'électricité
et du gaz et l'explosion des factures de
certaines entreprises nous protégerons
d'abord les plus petits conformément à
cette exigence de justice que je viens
de vous indiquer les TPE les très
petites entreprises qui bénéficieront du
même bouclier que les ménages
nous protégerons ensuite les PME qui
auront accès d'abord un guichet pour
2022 pour réduire le coût de leur
facture certaines ont eu des factures
extrêmement élevées sont inquiète elles
ont accès dans les tous prochains jours
un guichet qui leur permettra d'alléger
leurs factures puis en 2023 les PME
auront droit à une remise directe sur
leur facture pour amortir le choc
énergétique les PME bénéficieront donc
d'une protection globale qui représente
3 milliards d'euros au minimum d'aide
publique et qui fera baisser de 20% en
moyenne la facture d'une PM
nous protégerons également les
entreprises de taille intermédiaires et
les entreprises énergo intensives c'est
là où le ciblage est le plus nécessaire
c'est là que nous devons tout faire pour
apporter des aides qui ronront jusqu'à
150 millions d'euros pour éviter les
délocalisations éviter les
ralentissements de production éviter les
fermetures d'usine que beaucoup d'entre
vous redoutent nous avons conscience de
la difficulté je me suis battu pour
obtenir une simplification des aides
nous l'avons obtenu je me suis battu
pour que le montant maximum d'aide passe
de 100 à 150 millions d'euros nous
l'avons également obtenu nous laisserons
tomber aucun site industriel français
car il en va de la reconquête
industrielle que nous avons engagé avec
le président de la République et le
gouvernement depuis plus de 5 ans qui
donne des résultats et qui nous permet
enfin de recréer des emplois industriels
dans notre pays quand est-ce que ces
aides seront disponibles dans les
prochains jours comment est-ce qu'elles
seront versées sous forme de guichets ou
des directs pour la facture des PME en
2023 certains me disent est-ce que c'est
suffisant par rapport à l'Allemagne
je comprends parfaitement cette question
qui était soulevée notamment par les
représentants des chefs d'entreprise
j'aurais l'occasion de m'entretenir des
le début de la semaine prochaine avec le
ministre de l'économie allemande Robert
abbec mais une chose est claire nous
sommes dans un marché unique toutes les
entreprises sont donc soumises au même
règle et au même obligations je veux
donc le dire avec beaucoup de force face
à la crise énergétique les entreprises
françaises seront aussi bien défendus
aussi bien protégés que les entreprises
allemandes je rappelle d'ailleurs à ceux
qui l'ont à oublier que pour la moitié
de leur facture les entreprises
françaises continuent de bénéficier
d'une électricité nucléaire à bas coût à
travers la reine qui est un avantage
compétitif significatif
le ciblage enfin répond à une toute
dernière exigence mais qui n'est pas une
exigence négligeable c'est celle que
nous défendons avec Gabriel Attal avec
beaucoup de fermeté et que je tiens à
rappeler le rétablissement des finances
publiques
ciblées c'est aller également vers le
rétablissement des finances publiques je
sais quel je sais que les sénatrices et
les sénateurs sont particulièrement
attachés nous voulons tenir nos
objectifs de réduction des déficits et
de réduction de la dette et nous
tiendrons les objectifs qui ont été
fixés de baisse de la dette à partir de
2026 et de retour chez les Francs de
déficit en 2027 j'ai vu que un certain
nombre de sénateurs avaient dans ce
cadre-là proposé sur la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
d'aligner des objectifs de réduction la
dépense en volume de l'État sur les
objectifs des réductions de dépenses en
volume des collectivités locales pour
que état
collectivités locales soient traitée de
la même manière à
-0,5% de dépenses en volume sur la durée
du quinquennat je veux leur dire que
j'accueille favorablement cette
proposition qui est un signe d'équité et
un signe de la volonté du Sénat de
rétablir dans les meilleures délais
possibles nos finances publiques il
reste à nous entendre sur le montant
précis de dépenses publiques que cela
représente mais je sais que nous aurons
avec Gabriel Attal un débat constructif
avec vous sur le sujet je le souhaite
vous avez réussi à trouver un accord et
sur mon félicite sur le vote du PLF je
souhaite que nous puissions dans cette
voie du compromis trouver également un
accord sur la loi de programmation des
finances publiques pour me permettrez
pour conclure de tirer des leçons plus
globales du G20
auquel j'ai participé avec le président
de la République au cours des quatre
derniers jours j'en tire quatre
conclusions simples
la première c'est que aucun État ne
sortira dans la même situation de la
guerre en Ukraine
certainement pas l'Europe
certainement pas le continent africain
l'Europe parce que elle prend crûment
conscience à l'occasion de cette guerre
que la dépendance énergétique n'est pas
une option et qu'elle doit bâtir son
indépendance énergétique pour garder son
rang économique et pour éviter des
dépenses publiques d'un montant
inacceptable qui bénéficie à des pays
producteurs
le continent africain parce qu'il est le
plus touché par l'explosion des prix
alimentaires par l'inflation et par le
risque de pénurie alimentaire
je rappelle que le G20 sous l'impulsion
du Président de la République a condamné
l'agression russe cette guerre contraire
au droit international a fait dérailler
une reprise économique qui allait dans
la bonne direction elle aura donc je le
redis des conséquences structurelles sur
la répartition des forces économiques
dans le monde de ce point de vue et
c'est la deuxième conclusion que j'en
tire
personne
aucun état
ne fera de cadeaux à l'Europe
ni la Chine
ni même nos alliés américains
nous devons donc nous Européens faire
bloc
faire bloc face à la détermination de la
Chine d'affirmer son leadership
économique faire bloc face à la volonté
économique américaine de défendre ses
intérêts économiques et ses intérêts
industriels notamment à travers
l'inflation Redemption actes l'Europe
doit faire bloc des divisions
européennes dans ce contexte ne serait
pas simplement incompréhensible elle
serait inconsciente chacun désormais
dans le monde défend ses intérêts et les
défends brutalement
notamment c'est des intérêts économiques
l'Europe doit apprendre à les défendre
aussi si nombre brutalement du moins
avec la plus grande fermeté
troisième conclusion que je tire de ce
G20 sur le plan économique personne ne
pourra ralentir la nécessité de la
transition énergétique
la transition énergétique n'est pas le
problème
la transition énergétique et la solution
et la solution d'abord pour les pays en
développement qui doivent passer du
charbon à des énergies renouvelables et
qui doivent pour cela si nous voulons
vraiment atteindre nos objectifs
climatiques bénéficier du soutien
financier technologique des pays
développés et c'est ce que nous avons
fait avec Emmanuel Macron en proposant
qu'un fond accompagne le développement
des énergies renouvelables dans les pays
en développement car c'est la condition
de l'atteinte de nos objectifs
climatiques la transition énergétique
est aussi la solution pour nous pour une
grande puissance industrielle car
accélération la transition énergétique
en France comme la porte et la défend la
première ministre depuis plusieurs mois
c'est plus d'indépendance c'est des
technologies de pointe c'est de la
puissance économique et du rayonnement
c'est de l'efficacité donc nous devons
nous engager avec la plus totale des
terminations et avec le rythme le plus
accéléré possible dans la transition
énergétique
l'énergie sera la grande question
économique du 21e siècle elle doit être
disponible des carboner un coût
raisonnable les États qui l'auront
compris gagneront 21e siècle les États
qui ne l'auront pas compris seront
marginalisés au 21e siècle Enfin une
toute dernière conclusion personne aucun
état
ne peut se détourner du sort les pays
les plus pauvres
en particulier des États africains
pendant la crise du covid j'ai vu
l'occasion cette même tribune de
rappeler que pour compenser
l'effondrement de l'économie dans le
monde l'épée développée avait consacré
jusqu'à 25% de leur richesse nationale
pour soutenir leurs entreprises soutenir
des salariés relancer l'économie
dans les pays en développement c'était
moins de trois pour cent
. et voilà qu'ils prennent un deuxième
choc avec l'augmentation des prix
l'inflation le risque de ne pas disposer
de nourriture suffisamment le risque de
crise alimentaire et derrière on le sait
tous le risque de crise migratoire et de
désordre politique je suis fier que la
France par la voix du président de la
République est porté haut et fort au G20
cette exigence de soutien au pays
africains merci à tous merci
avant d'appeler monsieur le ministre
délégué chers collègues nous sommes très
heureux d'accueillir dans notre tribune
dans le cadre de la Journée européenne
de sensibilisation au handicap qu'on
appelle le duodé et des jeunes en
situation de handicap qui découvrent le
fonctionnement de l'institution auprès
de plusieurs de nos collègues et qui
l'ont fait ce matin à la présidence je
voudrais vous rappeler que nous sommes
pleinement mobilisés pour l'inclusion
des personnes en situation de handicap
dans le monde du travail notamment au
travers de ces journées d'échanges qui
constituent un moment privilégié pour
qu'ensemble nous changeons de regard que
nous dépassions nos préjugés au nom du
Sénat tout entier je voulais leur
souhaiter la plus cordiale bienvenue
ainsi qu'à suivre qui les encadre et qui
les accompagnent merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre délégué chargé des
comptes publics monsieur Attal
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre cher Bruno Le Maire Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général du budget
mesdames sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs à mon tour monsieur le
Président du Sénat je veux saluer cette
initiative duoday qui s'inscrit dans la
semaine pour l'insertion des personnes
en situation de handicap dans l'emploi
nous sommes évidemment tous très
attachés à cette enjeu et vous me
permettrait donc d'avoir un mot
particulier pour deux conseillers
particuliers qui sont au bord du
gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire
les duos de Bruno Le Maire et de
moi-même et donc je vous présente Cali
Ibrahim Hamzaoui qui est un jeune homme
docteur en informatique qui a fait le
tour de France en fauteuil roulant 3000
km avec son fauteuil qui nous accompagne
aujourd'hui ainsi que
[Applaudissements]
ainsi que Arnaud beuglin qui accompagne
Bruno Le Maire Mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs nous étions
réunis ici hier soir pour examiner le
deuxième PLFR de cette année 2022 je
tiens à remercier l'ensemble des
sénateurs présents hier pour la qualité
des échanges que nous avons eu j'ai eu
l'occasion de le rappeler hier Bruno Le
Maire là d'ailleurs dit aussi à
l'instant la situation économique de
notre pays et le climat d'incertitude
dans lequel nous devons évoluer et réel
je n'y reviendrai pas hier soir cette
émission a voté pour donner aux Français
des moyens supplémentaires pour
combattre la vie chère avec l'ouverture
de ces 2 milliards 500 millions d'euros
nous allons aider les Français à se
chauffer à se déplacer nous allons aider
nos étudiants et nos chercheurs à
travailler dans de bonnes conditions
nous allons financer la bataille en
faveur du plein emploi et poursuivre
notre engagement sans faille aux côtés
du peuple
ukrainien et tout cela nous allons le
faire en tenant l'objectif de déficit
que nous avions fixé pour 2022 car il
est hors de question et Bruno Le Maire
l'a rappelé de laisser déraper nos
comptes je sais bien sûr que l'adoption
de cette loi financière néfaste en rien
les clivages qui nous séparent j'ai
conscience que nous aurons durant la
discussion qui s'ouvre un débat
extrêmement nourri sur un certain nombre
de sujets je pense notamment à la
suppression de la CVAE et bien sûr aux
modalités du filet de sécurité que nous
allons mettre en place afin de protéger
les collectivités qui en ont besoin face
à la flambée des prix de l'énergie
l'année qui s'achève a été celle d'un
choix politique et économique
extrêmement clair celui de protéger les
ménages de protéger les entreprises de
protéger les collectivités locales face
à la hausse des prix c'est un choix de
justice mais c'est aussi un choix
d'efficacité cette stratégie est
efficace parce qu'il vaut mieux investir
pour préserver que payer pour réparer le
budget que nous vous présentons pour
l'année prochaine traduit la continuité
de cette stratégie sans jamais perdre de
vue que l'argent public c'est l'argent
des Français et que chaque euro investit
doit être un euro efficace mais protéger
les Français ce n'est pas se satisfaire
d'une politique du chèque ou d'une
vision court termeiste c'est assumé
qu'il faut à la fois répondre aux
urgences du quotidien financer l'action
publique préparer l'avenir et protéger
nos comptes
c'est au tour de ces quatre axes que
s'articule notre action il n'y a pas à
choisir parmi ces objectifs même s'ils
peuvent parfois sembler paradoxaux
contradictoires car la réalité c'est
qu'il faut tous les mener de front le
premier axe de ce projet de loi de
finances c'est donc répondre à l'urgence
de la fin du mois dans un contexte où
l'inflation demeure à un niveau élevé
6,2% en octobre 2022 par rapport à son
niveau d'octobre 2021 répondre à
l'urgence nous le faisons avec le
maintien des boucliers énergétiques
l'année prochaine tout en prévoyant une
hausse contenue à 15%. concrètement si
cette mesure n'était pas votée dès le
début de l'année prochaine un ménage
chauffé à l'électricité paierait en
moyenne 121 euros de plus par mois sur
sa facture d'électricité tandis qu'un
ménage chauffait au gaz Versace alourdir
en moyenne de 185 euros par mois
répondre à l'urgence nous le faisons
aussi avec l'indexation du barème de
l'impôt sur le revenu bien sûr c'est un
ajustement qui se fait chaque année mais
lorsque l'inflation dépasse les 5%
chacun comprendra que la décision n'a
pas la même porté et il y a d'ailleurs
des années où l'indexation n'a pas été
faite le coût de cette mesure témoigne
de sa portée puisque ce sont 6 milliards
200 millions d'euros que nous rendons
aux Français ou pour être plus précis
auquel nous renonçons pour préserver
leur portefeuille oui nous voulons
continuer à redonner du pouvoir d'achat
aux Français je veux d'ailleurs
souligner que parmi les amendements
retenus en première lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale dans le texte
considéré comme adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale figure un certain nombre de
mesures qui vont redonner de l'oxygène
aux Français redonner de l'oxygène à
ceux qui travaillent avec la hausse de
la valeur faciale des tickets
restaurants de 11,84 à 13 euros
redonner de l'oxygène aux parents qui
doivent faire garder leurs enfants avec
la hausse de 50% du crédit d'impôt garde
d'enfant porté donc à 3500 euros
redonner de l'oxygène à nos
entrepreneurs avec la hausse du plafond
permettant de bénéficier du taux réduit
d'impôt sur les sociétés pour les PME
redonner de l'oxygène à nos agriculteurs
avec la prorogation jusqu'à 2025 de la
déduction pour épargne de précaution
ainsi que son indexation à l'inflation
le deuxième axe de ce projet de loi de
finance s'est assuré le réarmement de
nos fonctions régaliennes pour tenir les
engagements pris devant les Français
durant la campagne présidentielle ce PLF
c'est plus de moyens pour la police plus
de moyens pour la justice plus de moyens
pour nos armées dans un contexte
géopolitique à haut risque dans le cadre
de la loi de programmation militaire ce
texte prévoit une hausse de 3 milliards
d'euros pour la mission défense et vous
permettrez de m'arrêter un court instant
sur les lois de programmation militaires
pour donner à voir l'ampleur de
l'engagement budgétaire aujourd'hui pour
nos armées loi de programmation
militaire
2009-2014 182 milliards d'euros sur 6
ans soit 30 milliards d'euros par an en
moyenne
loi de programmation militaire 2014 2019
1991 milliards d'euros sur 6 ans soit 32
milliards d'euros par an c'est 6% de
plus que la précédente loi de
programmation
2019-2025 celle dans laquelle nous
sommes
295 milliards d'euros sur 7 ans soit 42
milliards d'euros par an c'est plus 31%
par rapport à la précédente loi de
programmation militaire
s'agissant des moyens de nos forces de
sécurité c'est un milliard 400 millions
d'euros de crédit supplémentaires que
nous vous proposons de voter c'est plus
de moyens pour les équipements de nos
forces de l'ordre sur les technologies
numériques plus de moyens pour renforcer
la présence de policiers de gendarmes
sur la voie publique conformément à la
trajectoire posée par la loopmie que
vous avez adopté très largement au Sénat
qui prévoit 8500 créations de postes
supplémentaires sur le quinquennat
enfin nous poursuivons le renforcement
des moyens du ministère de la Justice
avec une nouvelle hausse de 8% pour la
troisième année consécutive depuis 2017
le budget du ministère de la justice
aura augmenté de plus de 40% pour
réarmer évidemment aussi cette fonction
régalienne essentielle de notre pays
vous le voyez ce que nous présentons
c'est un projet de réarmement de nos
services publics le troisième axe de ce
texte s'est préparé l'avenir préparer
l'avenir c'est faire le pari de
l'éducation c'est gagner la bataille du
plein emploi c'est accéléré la
transition écologique l'année prochaine
le budget de l'Éducation nationale va
augmenter de 3 milliards 700 millions
d'euros comme nous y étions engagés
pendant la campagne aucun professeur ne
débutera sa carrière sous les 2000 euros
net par mois
préparez l'avenir c'est aussi gagner la
bataille du plein emploi c'est
l'objectif que nous avons fixé à horizon
2027 ce sont ainsi 6 milliards 700
millions d'euros qui seront investis en
crédit supplémentaire dans l'emploi et
l'apprentissage pour atteindre le
million d'apprentis d'ici à 2027 qui est
notre objectif vous le savez mais je le
dis clairement et Bruno Le Maire l'a
d'ailleurs rappelé nous ne gagnerons pas
la bataille du plein emploi avec
davantage de pression fiscale c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons rendu 54
milliards d'euros au ménage et aux
entreprises au cours des cinq dernières
années et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous souhaitons mener à son terme la
suppression de la CVAE même si pour
tenir compte de nos comptes publics nous
proposons de la faire en deux exercices
budgétaires
sur ces sur ce sujet je sais que cette
hémicycle est loin d'être un terrain
conquis en tout cas pour le calendrier
tel qu'il figure dans le projet de loi
initial il y a parfois sur certains
bancs une opposition de principe sur
l'idée même de supprimer des impôts de
production il y a de l'autre une volonté
de différer à l'année prochaine la
suppression de cette impôts de
production pour ma part je crois que
l'amélioration de notre compétitivité
doit rester un objectif central dans un
contexte où la hausse des prix de
l'énergie mène aux entreprises à rue des
preuves les présidents de la CPE et du
Medef l'ont d'ailleurs rappelé encore
ces dernières heures
enfin préparer l'avenir c'est protéger
la planète à cet égard ce projet de loi
de finance prévoit le financement de
politique ambitieuse en faveur des
transitions écologiques énergétiques et
territoriales telles que le fond vert
pour l'investissement des collectivités
telles que le plan en vélo de 150
millions d'euros et une augmentation des
crédits dédiés à ma prime rénove de 500
millions d'euros
concernant la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments je veux souligner un certain
nombre d'avancés durant l'examen des
différents textes financiers le
rétablissement du crédit d'impôt ne
peuvent bénéficier les PME pour leurs
travaux de rénovation c'est un
amendement du groupe LR à l'Assemblée
nationale portée par la députée Émilie
Bonivard que nous avons retenu dans le
projet de loi de finances ou encore la
prolongation d'une année à l'éligibilité
à ma prime rénov sans condition de
ressources également
issues d'un amendement des républicains
portés par Véronique louvagi que nous
avons retenu dans le PLF
le quatrième axe de ce texte c'est le
refus du laisser-aller budgétaire comme
ministre des comptes publics je
continuerai à défendre le passage du
quoi qu'il en coûte ou combien ça coûte
parce que l'argent public ne sera jamais
de l'argent magique oui malgré les aléas
nous poursuivons le rétablissement des
comptes amorcés dès 2021 en stabilisant
le sol de public à 5% cette année comme
en 2023 je veux rappeler déficit public
en 2020
8,9%. déficit public en 2021
6,5%. déficit public l'an prochain 5% et
nous proposons une trajectoire pour
revenir sous les 3% d'ici à 2027 nous y
parviendrons parce que nous pourrons
compter sur des recettes fiscales
importantes encore l'an prochain
notamment de TVA et d'impôt sur les
sociétés liées à la bonne tenue de
l'activité ces derniers mois nous y
parviendrons aussi grâce aux recettes
liées à la contribution sur les rentes
infra marginales qui devrait s'élever
l'estimation a été revu à la Haus à 11
milliards d'euros l'année prochaine ce
projet de loi de finance rend cela
possible puisqu'il intègre les
mécanismes européens qui nous permettent
de faire contribuer les énergéticiens
qui bénéficient d'une rente liée à
l'envolée des prix je sais que nous
aurons à nouveau ce débat sur les super
profits je me souviens que nous l'avons
eu cet été dans le précédent PLFR et que
nous avions alors avec Bruno Le Maire
renvoyer à une discussion au niveau
européen certains à l'époque nous
avaient dit leur envoie une discussion
européenne est une forme de manœuvre
dilatoire pour enjamber ce débat et on
sait bien qu'à la fin il ne se passera
rien et bien depuis il s'est passé
quelque chose il s'est passé quelque
chose de massif il s'est passé un accord
européen pour un mécanisme de taxation
des super profits que nous dans ce
transcrivons dans ce PLF et qui
permettra de capter 11 milliards d'euros
de super profits sur les énergéticiens
l'an prochain et de financer une partie
importante du bouclier tarifaire pour
protéger les Français
cette trajectoire de sérieux nous la
tiendrons en 2023 et pour les années
suivantes afin d'assurer la
stabilisation de la dette et le retour
du déficit sous la barre des 3%. je sais
que la majorité sénatoriale souhaite un
rythme plus soutenu dans la
consolidation des finances publiques je
l'ai dit hier au regard de la situation
économique engagée une baisse trop
brutale de la dépense publique pourrait
avoir des effets dévastateurs pour nos
services publics et plus globalement
pour la cohésion ainsi que sur
l'activité économique mais Bruno Le
Maire vient de le dire dans les
propositions qui sont émises par le
Sénat il a notamment le fait de
rehausser l'effort de maîtrise de
dépenses en volume de l'État pour faire
passer la baisse de -04 à -05 à parité
avec celle des collectivités locales et
nous sommes ouverts comme la dit Bruno
Le Maire sur ce sujet
parvenir à cette trajectoire de maîtrise
des dépenses publiques suppose de
partager un même sentiment de
responsabilité
responsabilité vis-à-vis de notre pays
de sa crédibilité de sa capacité
d'action et de son indépendance
il parvenir suppose aussi de répartir
l'effort entre l'ensemble des
administrations publiques l'État et ses
opérateurs la sécurité sociale et les
collectivités territoriales je sais que
nous aurons à nouveau ce débat dans le
PLF
le débats seront vif mais je ne doute
pas que nous pourrons trouver ensemble
une voie d'équilibre
je crois que chacun a notre place chacun
avec nos convictions nous défendons tous
l'intérêt de notre pays chacun encore
une fois avec ses convictions je crois
que le moment dans lequel nous sommes le
moment que nous traversons les défis
auxquels nous faisons pas face face le
défi géopolitique avec la crise en
Ukraine le défi climatique le défi
démographique nous appelle à
collectivement tracer ensemble
des pistes des décisions des mesures des
axes qui nous permettront d'agir pour
l'intérêt des Français vous me trouverez
toujours à votre compte à vos côtés avec
Bruno Le Maire pour avancer dans cette
direction je vous remercie merci
monsieur le ministre
je vais maintenant donner la parole
à Jean-François Husson rapporteur
général de la commission des finances
paroles monsieur le rapporteur général
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le Président de la
Commission mais chers collègues nous
entamons aujourd'hui au Sénat l'examen
du projet de loi de finance pour 2023
considéré comme adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale après l'usage comme le Prébois
la constitution de la procédure du 49.3
un examen qui intervient peu après et
dans le droit fil du vote d'un projet de
loi de programmation des finances
publiques largement amendée ici au Sénat
et porteur d'une ambition volontariste
pour le rétablissement des comptes
publics nous avions pointé à cette
occasion que le gouvernement faisait
preuve d'un grand optimisme dans le
choix de ces prévisions macroéconomiques
et d'un trop faible volontarisme dans la
maîtrise des comptes publics je
maintiens ces critiques en 2022 et pour
ceux qui nous est permis d'en savoir en
2023 l'économie française a été est
demeurera soumise à de nombreux chocs
exogènes le plus importants d'entre eux
et bien sûr la hausse du prix des
énergies qui a conduit comme nous
l'indiqué le FCE à amputé la croissance
économique d'environ deux points et demi
de PIB entre 2021 et 2023 mais d'autres
chocs doivent être considérés à
commencer par les faits de la remontée
des taux d'intérêts qui ont cumulé
pourrait représenter une perte de
croissance de 1 point de pile la
prévision de croissance du PIB retenue
par le gouvernement pour l'année 2023 et
de mon point de vue optimisme une
hypothèse de plus 1% à ce jour éloigné
du consensus des économistes et surtout
qui ne tient pas compte d'un certain
nombre d'événements conjoncturels
récents qu'il s'agisse du ralentissement
de l'activité économique au troisième
trimestre de la hausse des taux
directeurs de la BCE ou bien de la
prévision de récession en Allemagne et
de stagnation de l'activité en zone euro
nous avons donc devant nous un projet de
loi de finance bâti sur des hypothèses
de croissance assuré votre optimiste
peut-être même obsolète nous avons
concernant l'évolution des prix la
prévision d'évolution de l'inflation
présente encore un caractère
relativement central avec
5,4%, ce qui reste très significatif une
inflation en France qui demeure
d'ailleurs encore majoritairement
importé et elle aussi liée à
l'augmentation des coûts de l'énergie et
les mieux maîtrisée en France que dans
d'autres pays développés mais c'est au
prix d'une forte mobilisation des
finances publiques qui par le même coup
dégrade nos comptes publics en effet
près de 50 milliards d'euros en 2022 est
probablement 56 milliards d'euros en
alors pour nécessaire qu'elle soit ses
dépenses doivent nous appeler à observer
une grande vigilance puisque comme vous
le savez les conditions de financement
de la France ne sont plus les mêmes que
par le passé la remontée des taux
d'intérêts constituent un risque pour la
soutenabilité de la dette française
l'inflation a contribué à une
augmentation rapide des taux nominaux
sur le marché des obligations
souveraines depuis octobre 21
c'est-à-dire il y a à peu près un peu
plus d'un an le taux des Françaises à 10
ans a augmenté de
290 points de base et la perception que
les investisseurs portent sur le risque
des obligations françaises cette
concomitamment détériorée
je dirais le temps de l'argent facile et
gratuit et bien fini et ce n'est pas
faute de vous avoir mis en garde ici au
Sénat sur les risques d'un endettement
trop important et massif en ce qui
concerne la situation de nos finances
publiques les mesures de crise ne
peuvent pas expliquer toute la
dégradation de nos comptes publics et il
est urgent de notre point de vue de
mettre en œuvre une stratégie de
maîtrise des dépenses ordinaires en 2023
le seul de public devrait atteindre 5%
du PIB et l'endettement environ
111%. les recettes publiques devraient
progresser considérablement avec
139 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
entre 2021 et 2023 dans le texte initial
de façon temporaire et conjoncturelle
l'état bénéficiera notamment de recettes
supplémentaires c'est évoqué versée par
les producteurs d'énergie
plusieurs mesures nouvelles viendront
réduire le rendement fiscal à commencer
par la suppression de la contribution à
audiovisuel public la poursuite de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation est
la suppression de la part communale et
intercommunale de la tvae en parallèle
les dépenses vont également progresser
d'environ 110 milliards d'euros en
réalité la hausse est même beaucoup plus
importante car l'état je viens de donner
l'exemple avec le cas des subventions
producteurs d'énergie bénéficient de
moindre dépenses qui sont elles
conjoncturelles
les dépenses primaires retraitées du
coût des mesures de crise progressantes
ainsi d'au moins 137 milliards d'euros
sur les deux années dont quasiment la
moitié en 2023 les mesures de
revalidation des pensions et du
traitement des fonctionnaires
contribueront aussi à augmenter la
dépense d'environ 16 milliards d'euros
le seul de public restera partiellement
dégradé sous l'effet de la situation
financière de l'État exclusivement les
collectivités locales présenteront il
faut bien écouter les collectivités
locales présenteront un excédent tandis
que les administrations sociales quand
vendaient à l'équilibre grâce à
l'amélioration du sol du régime général
et malgré une forte progression des
dépenses sociales raison pour laquelle
messieurs les ministres ont vous demande
de respecter la ligne rouge ne mettez
pas de Carcans ou collectivités locales
c'est aujourd'hui non seulement
inattendable mais inacceptable
j'en viens plus spécifiquement au budget
de l'État qui présente des niveaux de
dépenses et difficiles que le
gouvernement ne parvient plus voir ne
cherche plus à faire redescendre des
sommets atteints depuis 2020 alors que
des mesures d'économie devrait être
engagées dès 2023 les recettes diminuant
légèrement par l'effet de transfert de
fiscalité aux collectivités
territoriales le gouvernement fait en
réalité le choix de ne pas adapter les
dépenses au moyen dont il disposent en
fait il identifie les dépenses qui
doivent augmenter pas les économies qui
devraient les compenser la trajectoire
des dépenses n'annonce ainsi aucune
inflexion pour les années à venir les
dépenses des années suivantes sont
d'ores et déjà contraintes par le niveau
élevé des dépenses des engagées sous
l'effet notamment des lois de
programmation et par l'absence bien
regrettable de volonté de maîtriser les
dépenses de masse salariale
le déficit de l'État supérieur en 2023 à
150 milliards d'euros pour la quatrième
année consécutive je le rappelle ne
redescend plus du pic atteint depuis la
crise sanitaire c'est un budget de
l'État qui est en fait et je le redis
celui de tous les records jamais un
projet de loi de finance n'avait été
présenté avec un tel niveau de déficit
dès le début de la discussion budgétaire
jamais un budget n'avait prévu un tel
niveau d'emprunt nouveau à hauteur de
270 milliards d'euros 2023 jamais non
plus la France n'a dû rembourser autant
d'emprunts arrivés à l'échéance
156,5 milliards d'euros ainsi en 2023 la
France des caissera plus
pour rembourser des emprunts que pour
financer hors pension l'éducation
nationale la recherche et les armées
réunies le gouvernement accumule les
déficits et ils poussent les curseurs de
la dette toujours plus haut arrivé à de
telles altitudes l'emprunt toujours
renouvelé place le pays sous respirateur
artificiel est la facture commence à
être représentée c'est la charge de la
dette qui dès cette année dépasse les 50
milliards d'euros en comptabilité
budgétaire la mission engagement
financier de l'État redevient la seconde
mission du budget général devant même la
mission défense c'est la conséquence de
la reprise de la charge de la dette mais
aussi de l'ouverture de plus de 6
milliards de crédit virtuel sur le
programme d'amortissement de la dette
covid qui pour le coup est un pur
artifice comptable
dans le même temps et c'est bien
regrettable la dette climatique s'ajoute
à la dette budgétaire et les dépenses
défavorables au climat sont multipliées
excusés du peu par deux sous l'effet des
mesures face à la hausse des prix de
l'énergie là encore nous récoltons les
fruits d'une politique énergétique
désastreuse des gouvernements successifs
en particulier s'agissant de l'énergie
et de l'impréparation des choix
politiques devant cette retenue pour
faire face réellement au défi des
risques climatiques
face à ses dépenses je dois le dire la
fiscalité énergétique est reste toujours
aussi inégalitaire elle pèse plus sur
les ménages à revenus modestes elle pèse
plus sur ceux qui vivent dans des
communes rurales ou dans les petits
pôles urbains les moins peuplés il ne
faut guère espérer de recettes des
recettes qu'elles aident l'État à
infléchir la trajectoire de la dette en
2023 puisqu'elle devrait diminuer de
près de 6 milliards d'euros en valeur
les deux principaux phénomènes affectant
l'évolution du recettes fiscal sont la
suppression progressive de la c.de et la
poursuite du bouclier tarifaire
face à la réduction des recettes le
réflexe budgétaire devrait être d'agir
sur les dépenses or on en est loin le
gouvernement choisi celle qui doit
augmenter mais pas les économies qui
devraient les compenser je le redis ils
préparent donc la poursuite de la
dégradation de nos finances publiques je
dirais même il l'a favorise dès le début
du second quinquennat du président de la
République l'heure des choix est renvoyé
quasiment au prochain quinquennat or
dans une vision plus annuelle qui est
d'ailleurs renforcée dans les commandes
dans les documents budgétaires
conformément à la LOLF les perspectives
ne sont guère rassurantes le niveau des
restes à payer
c'est à dire les dépenses qu'il faudra
bien assurer pour couvrir les
engagements déjà pris à augmenter de
plus de 50% depuis 2017 on le constate
sur les dépenses de personnel comme sur
l'ensemble des crédits des politiques
publiques le gouvernement ne fait pas de
choix il favorise certaines politiques
qui en ont assurément besoin mais
n'affiche aucune volonté de décider de
celle qui au contraire devrait voir
leurs moyens réduits ce tableau de 2023
mes chers collègues doit être en fait
replacé dans la perspective plus longue
que trace le projet de loi de
financement de programmation des
finances publiques il nous faut donc une
trajectoire que je qualifierais de
sérieuses et raisonnable d'ailleurs le
ministre Bruno Le Maire avait qualifié
cette trajectoire choisie par le Sénat
ici même de juste et honnête elle est en
toute état de cause plus ambitieuse et
plus juste que c'est du gouvernement en
demandant les mêmes efforts à l'état que
collectivité territoriales tout en
parvenant plus rapidement un niveau de
déficit plus acceptable dans ce projet
de loi de finances nous vous proposerons
de mettre en œuvre ce que nous avons
nous avons invité à faire dans le cas de
la loi de programmation en proposant des
économies sur un certain nombre de
mission indépendamment de celle qu'elle
proposera de rejeter par ailleurs ainsi
je propose moi-même de mettre fin à
l'ouverture de crédit outils du plan de
relance relance dont le temps est
désormais passé et j'estime que de
nouvelles contraintes s'imposent à nous
au regard notamment du contexte de la
crise énergétique à la fois majeure et
inédite la Commission a également
adoptée les amendements de suppression
de crédit sur la mission écologique pour
750 millions d'euros sur la mission
santé s'agissant de l'aide médicale
d'État et sur la mission est publique au
développement pour 200 millions d'euros
d'autres amendements suivront
nos travaux de commission regorgent
aussi de pistes de référence
structurelles qui si elles étaient mises
en oeuvre permettrait de dégager des
économies je pense ici notamment à
l'audiovisuel ou le gouvernement ne
respecte pas son engagement de l'été
dernier
s'agissant des mesures figurants dans le
texte j'aurai l'occasion d'exprimer
évidemment au fur et à mesure de
l'examen de ce PLF mais je conclurai mes
propos en abordant quelques sujets
le bouclier fiscal est budgétaire que
vous maintenez et étendez aux
entreprises nous ne pouvons que soutenir
les mesures d'urgence qui iront dans le
bon sens et permettront de soutenir les
acteurs économiques autant que nos
services publics et les ménages pour
autant je dois l'avouer vos mesures
deviennent-ils lisibles difficile
vraiment de s'y retrouver dans le maquis
des aides et le fait d'inscrire des
milliards d'euros de crédit
supplémentaires sans être capable de
préciser ni les entités éligibles ni le
champ d'intervention n'est pas pour
rassurer au contraire il inquiète et
chacun se demande quelque part s'il le
fera bien partie de ceux qui seront
protégés c'est donc bien une forme
d'impréparation de travail dans
l'urgence et d'une politique énergétique
désastreuse conduite depuis 10 ans
erratique qui nous conduisent à cette
situation il est grand temps de sortir
du flou et d'avoir un cap clair
privilégions les solutions juste et
efficaces nous proposerons pour notre
part en première partie un filet de
sécurité repensé qui vient compléter
l'amortisseur électricité pour les
collectivités territoriales il faut
répondre en effet à l'inquiétude de nos
élus des élus locaux mais de tous les
élus et à travers elle de nos
concitoyens ce qui est en jeu c'est
aussi et bien sûr le maintien de nos
services publics présents actif
performant sur tout le territoire
national avec un message lui aussi
désormais simple clair et juste toutes
collectivité territoriale seule ou en
groupement sans critères d'entrée
bénéficieraient d'une prise en charge
par l'État de la moitié de la hausse de
ses dépenses d'énergie en 2023 après
application de l'amortisseur lorsque
c'était hausse dépasse un montant égal à
40% de la hausse de ces recettes de
fonctionnement enfin
la suppression de la cbae est en soi une
bonne chose car comme j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire les impôts de
production en France restent
particulièrement élevé en comparaison
européenne il faut donc redonner la
compétitivité à nos entreprises mais
pour autant l'enjeu actuellement pour ne
tissu économique c'est aussi de pouvoir
traverser la crise énergétique en étant
suffisamment protégé mise en sécurité
comme je viens de le dire en outre la
réforme du gouvernement est mal préparée
en particulier s'agissant des modalités
de compensation des collectivités
locales et sur ce dernier point il est
encore plus urgent de se laisser de se
donner du temps un temps utile pour une
solution qui soit acceptée de tous en
conclusion
je vous invite à nous faire confiance en
soutenant les amendements proposés par
notre commission des finances je nous
souhaite de bons débats en ayant la
volonté qu'il soit utile et motivé par
l'intérêt de servir les intérêts de la
France une France Forte une France
souveraine une France battante et
désireuse d'ouvrir de nouvelles voies
celle de la réussite une réussite qui
mobilise les efforts de tous et de
chacun à la mesure de ses capacités je
vous remercie merci monsieur le
rapporteur général
[Applaudissements]
je vais maintenant donner la parole à
Monsieur Claude Raynal président de la
commission des finances
paroles monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres monsieur leur rapporteur
général chers collègues cette séance
s'ouvre après plusieurs semaines de
travaux en commission des finances et
dans les commissions pour avis
je remercie notamment l'ensemble des
rapporteurs spéciaux qui ont passé en
revue l'ensemble des crédits et qui ont
bien sûr formulé des propositions
l'utilisation du 49-3 à l'Assemblée
nationale fait que très peu de
dispositions du PLF ont pu être
examinées le Sénat a donc une
responsabilité très particulière de ce
fait dans cette intervention luminaire
je ne balai pas l'ensemble des sujets
que nous aurons tout le temps
d'approfondir d'ici le 6 décembre le
Rapporteur général a fait déjà un point
très exhaustif je voudrais plutôt
partager quelques réflexions avec vous
messieurs les ministres mais je suis
appelé si vous motorisez quelques peu
des chiffres pour essayer de comprendre
le sens de l'exercice de ce PLF 2023
tant il est vrai que sa lecture
interroge
s'agit-il dans un contexte incertain et
par bien des aspects angoissants de
soutenir les Français face à l'inflation
et à la crise énergétique notamment
de maintenir notre outil industriel
de stabiliser notre dette et nos comptes
publics sans doute un peu de tout cela
nous direz-vous et d'ailleurs monsieur
le ministre vous nous avez dit à peu
près ça mais la copie peine à convaincre
en 2017 les choses étaient claires au
bénéfice d'une situation des Comptes
publics rétablie croissance de 2,3% des
fichiers ramenés à 3% du Pipe
application d'une politique néolibérale
on ne peut plus classique baisse des
impôts des entreprises et des
particuliers soutient aux investisseurs
privés baisse de l'impôt sur le
patrimoine
personne encore aujourd'hui ni France
stratégie ni il y a quelques jours
encore le comité d'évaluation des
réformes de la fiscalité du capital ne
se risquait à faire un lien entre ces
mesures et un renforcement par les
bénéficiaires d'une réorientation de
l'épargne vers le financement des
entreprises j'étais opposé à votre
politique monsieur le ministre mais au
moins j'en comprenais les attendus et
les objectifs recherchés
puis vint la pandémie et le casier arrêt
n'est pas entier de l'économie là encore
monsieur le ministre
j'ai compris et pour l'essentiel
approuver votre action
PGE chômage partiel plan divers de
soutien puis plan de relance les
résultats en termes de reprise
économique ont été au rendez-vous et on
peut dire que cela a été une réussite
la crise Russo ukrainienne de cette
année ramenant la guerre en Europe puis
la crise énergétique et l'inflation est
venue mettre fin à ce scénario favorable
la situation est aujourd'hui difficile
nous le reconnaissons tous mais là
surprise
tâtonnement soit malheureux imprécision
se multiplie quelques exemples des aides
aux Français mais vous l'avez évoqué
finalement vous avez évoqué votre
politique passée pour finalement la
dénoncer au bénéfice de votre politique
nouvelle
des aides aux Français non ciblées
mettons sur un pied d'égalité ceux
d'entre nous ayant de bons revenus et
ceux qui ne peuvent plus s'en sortir que
cela soit sur les ristournes ou sur le
prix du gaz et de l'électricité au prix
d'une dépense publique inconsidérée et
aujourd'hui vous l'avez reconnu
complètement
insoutenable un autre exemple la
contribution sur la rente infrar
marginale des producteurs de NR mis à
mal par la dénonciation des contrats par
les 10 producteurs je crois avoir
compris que vous allez nous proposer
très bientôt une taxation directe je
voudrais dire de ces super profits pour
résoudre ce problème comme quoi Monsieur
le Ministre calculé et taxé des super
profits n'est pas finalement si
difficile que cela
et puis au fond et puis au fond ce qui
choque aujourd'hui c'est de ne pas tenir
compte de la situation réelle de nos
finances publiques pour poursuivre dans
votre ligne idéologique de baisse des
impôts alors que notre déficit se
creusera encore de 150 milliards d'euros
cette année
dernière part de taxe d'habitation pour
les 20% les plus aisés suppression de la
redevance TV suppression de la CVAE les
recettes de l'État diminueront de 2,7%
en volume l'an prochain et le mouvement
devrait se poursuivre en 2024
au moment où à court terme vous devez
faire face aux conséquences de la crise
énergétique et également alimentaire
vous l'avez précisé bien sûr pour les
familles les plus en difficulté où vous
devez maintenir des entreprises électro
intensives en grande difficulté comme
par ailleurs beaucoup d'entreprises ou
de collectivités locales vous poursuivez
la même ligne politique qu'en 2017 je
voudrais dire comme si de rien n'était
et si encore vous aviez la
reconnaissance du Medef
vous savez ceux qui ont déclaré après
l'annonce de la répartition de la baisse
de la c.de sur deux ans je cite vu ce
qui est abondamment distribué par
ailleurs nous ne comprenons pas que la
CVAE soit une variable d'ajustement
budgétaire au moment où les entreprises
souffrent fin de citation ou encore les
mêmes qui relevaient je cite encore
votre manque d'ambition en matière de
baisse et dépenses publiques
on avait un certain accord d'ailleurs
entre nous sur ce point le Medef donc a
déjà oublié ça va vite les PGE le
chômage partiel qui a permis aux
entreprises de conserver leur
compétences les plans de soutien à
l'industrie les entreprises souffrent
parent-ils alors beaucoup de petites
Surmont mais franchement pas celle du
CAC 40 en tout cas en 2021
record de dividendes de distribuer
on peine à dire le chiffre
57,5 milliards d'euros
vous savez qu'en France on a une vraie
passion de la distribution de dividendes
sans doute plus en 2022 et je n'oublie
pas les rachats d'actions totalement
insupportable qui consiste à relever
l'action des actionnaires quand on
n'aurait pas assez pour 23 milliards
d'euros
surtout cela l'état or prélèvement
sociaux bien sûr après le v
un peu plus d'un milliard
ne croyez-vous pas que le temps n'est
plus au cas d'offisco mais plutôt un
juste équilibre entre fiscalité du
travail et des dividendes
qu'au lieu de refuser par principe tout
débat sur les super profits il aurait
mieux valu que vous essayez de trouver
avec le Parlement une solution solide
pour cela
alors je le sais Monsieur le Ministre
comme moi vous n'avez pas goûté les
propos du Medef vous l'avez marqué
colère
colère vous leur avez même proposé je
vous cite monsieur le ministre
de faire le ménage dans les crédits
d'impôts donc bénéficie les entreprises
une offre généreuse je suis sûr que
l'organisation patronale a répondu très
favorablement
mais enfin vous nous direz
mais en ce qui me concerne moi voyez je
voudrais vous aider monsieur le ministre
il y a un doute un doute dans la salle
comme vous le savez
l'irès a recensé 2000 mécanismes 2000
mécanismes de soutien aux entreprises
pour remonter à estimer qu'on peut
toujours discuter à la dizaine de
milliards près mais pas plus de 180
milliards d'euros annuels
soit plus de 8% du PIB
niche fiscale
allègement des cotisations sociales
dépensent ce budgétaire alors monsieur
le ministre vous qui aimez tant les
comparaisons internationales notamment
on se souvient des magnifiques
graphiques concernant les impôts de
production
pouvez-vous nous dire en réponse combien
de pays soutiennent annuellement leurs
entreprises à hauteur de plus de 8% du
PIB
je vous le dis parce que c'est fatiguant
c'est fatiguant de regarder les
problèmes en silo les impôts on a baissé
on a traité j'avais voté cette belle
d'impôt à l'époque dans maintenant passé
maintenant un peu de production mais par
contre sur les crédits d'impôts et tout
ce qui est mis en place par l'État en
France qui ne l'est pas ailleurs là il y
a plus de comparaison internationale
alors pour vous aider à répondre
monsieur le ministre je proposerai au
rapporteur général que notre commission
s'intéresse à cette question car il faut
monsieur le ministre vous donner
quelques éléments d'appréciation je ne
doute pas d'ailleurs que cette étude
sera très instructive monsieur le
ministre
il faut savoir prioriser les sujets la
question d'aujourd'hui n'est pas
d'afficher une cohérence de long terme
mais plutôt de répondre aux priorités du
moment je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
nous allons passer mes chers collègues à
la discussion de la motion tendante à
opposer l'exception d'y recevabilité
Monsieur Daniel Breuillet les membres du
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire ont déposé une motion
distribuée sous le numéro 14 19 tendant
opposer l'exception d'y recevabilité
de la parole monsieur vous avez la
parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur
général chers collègues les écologistes
croient et agissent pour une république
plus parlementaire à l'occasion de ce
projet de loi de finances texte le plus
important que nous ayons à voter nous
posons la question de la sincérité du
gouvernement dans ce débat
messieurs les ministres respecterez-vous
le travail du Parlement lors de son
discours de politique générale madame la
Première ministre a tracé un cap et une
méthode mais au-delà des mots quels sont
les faits le travail de l'Assemblée
nationale a été sabordée par un 49.3 le
vote du Sénat n'est pas respecté et je
m'appuie ici sur l'exemple de l'article
23 supprimer en loi de programmation
plurer annuel des finances publiques que
vous réintroduisez dans cette loi de
finances 2023 j'y reviendrai mais cet
exemple justifié à lui seul de vous
poser cette question voulez-vous
sincèrement travailler avec le Parlement
certes nous sommes invités au dialogue
de Bercy certes vous venez présenter vos
projets de loi en commission et nous
exposer le contexte répondre à nos
questions mais quel sens cela a-t-il si
vous n'écoutez pas nous ne sommes pas
les premiers vous avez procédé de même
avec les Françaises et les Français au
moment des grands débats et des cahiers
de doléances à nouveau moment de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat dont
trop peu de propositions ont été
retranscrites dans la loi en réalité
comme certaines entreprises font du
greenwashing pour colorer en vert des
actions qui ne sont pas écologiques vous
faites vous inventer même le
démocratique coaching vous faites croire
que vous nous écoutez mais vous ne nous
entendez pas ma collègue et Vassas
disait dernièrement à juste titre
finalement le gouvernement montre non
seulement son déni du débat
parlementaire mais aussi son absence
d'écoute des problèmes du pays
les Français ont élu une assemblée sans
majorité absolue la première ministre a
estimé que cela invitait je la cite à
des pratiques nouvelles et à la
recherche des compromis en effet ce
choix nous oblige la loi doit être
concertée enrichie de la diversité de
nos convictions républicaines et de nos
assemblées le discours de la politique
générale de la première ministre en
April acte sa pratique législative non
pourtant on a rarement raison seul et
jamais en restant droit dans ses bottes
sans le peuple contre les partenaires
sociaux et le Parlement surtout dans ce
contexte où les fascisme et les
populismes prennent place sur
l'échiquier des décisions de par le
monde en Europe comme en France et où
les dangers grandissent comme vous
l'avez évoqué monsieur le ministre le
maire permettez-moi d'illustrer deux
exemples le dévoiement du dévoiement
démocratique que nous réfutons
aujourd'hui tout d'abord l'usage du 49.3
qui est constitutionnelle et votre tri
des amendements le tri des amendements
est bien plus discutable que l'usage du
49.3 pour qui revendique la conservat la
concertation comme méthode nos collègues
débutaient ont débattu avec conviction
et volonté d'infléchir et d'enrichir le
texte qui leur était présenté ce travail
interrompu prématurément fut sérieux et
exigeant
comme nous nous apprêtons à le faire
durant les trois semaines qui viennent
et les plus de 140 heures programmés de
jours comme de nuit pourtant vous avez
choisi d'éliminer l'essentiel des
amendements votés à l'Assemblée parmi
les amendements écologistes vous avez
choisi de non retirer qu'un de n'en
retenir qu'un sans doute pour montrer
toujours votre démocratique washing que
vous preniez des contributions sur tous
les bancs de l'Assemblée ce fut celui de
mon collègue Julien Bayou permettant
d'utiliser l'huile de friture pour
combustible automobile
c'est un amendement utile qui permet de
réutiliser ce qui était considéré comme
un déchet comme une nouvelle ressource
mais reconnaissons le il ne porte pas
capacité à influer sur la trajectoire
carbone de notre pays
contrairement à celui de ma collègue et
Vassas concernant l'isolation thermique
des logements le logement c'est un quart
des émissions de CO2 et son sujet
c'était 11 millions de foyers en
précarité énergétique 5 millions de
passoires thermiques et bien évidemment
la baisse de nos dépendances au marché
fossile personne ne pourra ralentir la
nécessaire transition énergétique
venez-vous de dire monsieur le ministre
le maire le Parlement a fait des
propositions à dit nous voulons une
inflexion conforme à ce que revendique
toutes les ONG et les organismes
spécialisés vous l'avez rejeté rejeté
aussi l'amendement modem de Jean-Paul
Mattei pourtant voter très
majoritairement je ne parle pas ici de
notre volonté de taxer les super ou de
créer un ISF climatique auquel vous êtes
idéologiquement opposé je parle d'une
taxation temporaire à 35% des bénéfices
exponentiels en période de graves crise
et dans un contexte de guerre en Europe
ce n'était pas avouer le la nuit du 4
roues et l'abolition des privilèges
c'était la traduction par le Parlement
d'une demande profonde de justice
sociale la liste est longue des
amendements qui auraient pu et dû
enrichir ce texte de loi qui nous est
présentée et que vous avez choisi de
classer dans les poubelles
gouvernementales j'en reviens donc à ma
question
respecterez-vous le travail du Sénat où
voulez-vous entraver le pouvoir d'agir
des élus nationaux et locaux et j'en
viens à ce fameux article 23 de la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
qui visent à mettre au pas des
collectivités article inacceptable et
évidemment massivement rejeté
inacceptable car les collectivités
votent des budget à l'équilibre
contraire à l'état inacceptable parce
que ce que vous appelez contrat de
confiance est une remise en cause de
leur autonomie principe consacré par
l'article 72 de la Constitution
inacceptable pour le Sénat chambre des
territoires qui l'a rejeté à une immense
majorité pour l'Assemblée nationale
qu'il avait également rejeté ou encore
pour les associations d'élus qui n'ont
eu de cesse de vous interpeller sur le
sujet alors lorsque le Parlement par ces
deux chambres des associations de maire
de PC vous disent ce texte est
inacceptable que faites-vous dans votre
nouvelle méthode démocratique
revendiquée par la première ministre
vous le retirez et bien non au contraire
sorti par la poste par la porte vous le
ramenez par la fenêtre sous la forme
d'un article additionnel à l'article 40
du projet de loi de finance étrange
conception de la démocratie
parlementaire étrange conception de la
démocratie tout court d'autant quand
vous attaquant aux collectivités
territoriales messieurs les ministres
vous vous attaquez aussi aux dernières
échelon démocratique qui résiste encore
dans l'avancée inquiétante des doutes
qui saisissent notre démocratie et notre
peuple vous devriez nous devrions au
contraire tout faire pour préserver et
soutenir les communes et les élus locaux
chaque crise des gilets jaunes à la
pandémie nous a montré à quel point ils
sont la digue la plus solide en termes
de cohésion sociale leur diversité de
choix de situation est une formidable
opportunité d'évaluer les réponses
politiques les plus efficaces face aux
crises sociales démocratiques et
climatique
il y a ma question voulez-vous
travailler avec le Parlement je vous
réponds que nous nous souhaitons
travailler proposer contribuer car
l'urgence climatique est là et bien là
elle est encore plus redoutable pour les
plus fragiles d'entre nous il est
impossible de rester sans débattre et
sans s'agir pour faire face aux défis
qui sont devant nous la situation exige
une autre gouvernance les solutions
concrètes doivent être travaillées et
mises en oeuvre avec les collectivités
avec le Parlement avec les partenaires
sociaux avec les associations et les ONG
et avec nos concitoyennes et nos
concitoyens la trajectoire écologique
doit être forte équitable immédiate
l'anecdotique ne peut plus suffire ni
les boucliers ponctuels combien divers
mauvais d'été suffocants faudra-t-il
pour que vous entendiez ces propositions
si les débats sénatoriaux sur le projet
de loi de finance 2023 n'ont pour
vocation que de renforcer le
démocratique washing si à l'arrivée vous
refaites le choix du 49.3 et celui de ne
retenir que quelques amendements
gouvernementaux ou d'affichage alors
messieurs les ministres notre débat est
dénué de sens dites le nous
ce cap et ne perdons pas notre temps
mais le péril est grand parce que la
démocratie semble Parlement ce n'est
déjà plus la démocratie messieurs les
ministres pouvaient vous prendre
l'engagement d'un dialogue sincère avec
le Sénat si vous y êtes prêts notre
groupe qui tiendra sa juste place
je n'ai pas reçu de demande de parole de
Raptor contre la motion
quelle est la vie de la commission sur
le rapporteur général
alors la vie de la commission je lis
tout de suite c'est une demande de
retrait je pense que ça ne surprendra
personne je veux donner à ce stade deux
éléments d'appréciation le premier qui
concerne l'exception d'y recevoiralité
c'est à dire au moins sur la forme le
fait que
la démarche ne enfin elle serait
contraire au respect de la Constitution
et de son application je note que dans
cette motion d'ailleurs j'ai bien écouté
l'intervention du brouillé il y a des
désaccords sur les choix politiques du
gouvernement mais il y a absolument au
regard de l'exception d'y recevoir
l'humilité résultant ou pouvant être mis
en oeuvre par le Règlement du Sénat il y
a aucun problème constitutionnel et puis
deuxièmement
je pense qu'il ne faut surtout pas
priver la France d'un débat au Parlement
il y a eu un débat écourté par une
procédure constitutionnelle autorisée
qui a d'ailleurs été utilisé au milieu
des années 80 dans une période politique
qui fut elle aussi difficile notamment
par le Premier ministre de l'époque
Michel Rocard nous sommes aujourd'hui en
2022 il y a une majorité relative à
l'Assemblée nationale le gouvernement a
réduit le temps des débats et un certain
nombre de grandes missions de nos
politiques publiques n'a fait l'objet
d'aucun débat y compris avec des
annonces nouvelles raisons pour laquelle
notre assemblée va avoir une
responsabilité particulière je dirais
même que d'une certaine manière les
projecteurs de l'actualité sont
davantage braqués sur le Sénat
une assemblée constitutive du
bicamérisme français et qui doit nous
donner la possibilité d'être un écho sur
un débat du débat serein animés et qui
mettent à la fois le sérieux et le
regard tourné vers l'avenir pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens et pour
nos débats sur toutes les bandes de cet
assemblée vraiment je vous demande de
retirer cette amendement
la vie du gouvernement
mais ma vie monsieur le Président je
voudrais en profiter pour
répondre aux interventions honnêtes et
solides comme toujours du rapporteur
général et du président de la commission
des finances pour clarifier peut-être un
ou deux points
d'abord monsieur le sénateur Husson sur
leur des choix je veux vraiment vous
dire avec beaucoup de force que lors des
choix n'est pas repoussé et que lors des
choix c'est maintenant
et que les choix que nous faisons de
ciblage des aides publiques pour faire
face à l'inflation ce sont des choix
pour maintenant ce sont des choix qui
nous engagent pour l'avenir et qui
doivent nous amener à ramener les prix
de l'électricité du gaz de l'énergie en
France vers les prix de marché tout
simplement parce que après avoir amorti
le choc il est normal il est juste que
ce soit les plus modestes les plus
fragiles qui soient protégés mais
qu'ensuite des prix de marché puissent
reprendre leurs droits pour que
l'économie puisse fonctionner
normalement
les choix que nous faisons dans ce PLF
2023 et sont clairs de ce point de vue
là nous soutenons vous l'avez rappelé
certaines politiques publiques en ont
besoin il est indispensable de continuer
à soutenir nos forces de l'ordre il est
indispensable de donner les moyens à
notre école de fonctionner correctement
et il est indispensable de soutenir
comme nous le faisons massivement
l'hôpital public que aujourd'hui
continue à rencontrer de très grandes
difficultés sur les aides pour faire
face à l'augmentation des prix je le
redis nous les ciblons avec l'objectif
progressivement d'un retour à la normale
enfin sur la trajectoire des finances
publiques je le redis nous sommes prêts
avec Gabriel Attal à ouvrir la
discussion avec l'ensemble des
sénatrices et des sénateurs pour voir
comment nous pouvons nous entendre sur
une trajectoire de loi de programmation
des finances publiques plus ambitieuses
avec pour les collectivités locales
comme pour l'État une réduction des
dépenses en volume de 0,5% sur la durée
du quinquennat
monsieur le Président
rénal d'abord je vous remercie d'avoir
salué les politiques que nous avons
menées face au covid de l'avoir qualifié
de réussite parce que je pense que c'est
une politique qui était adoptée
collectivement et c'est aussi ce qui a
fait sa force et je salue cette
honnêteté de jugement de votre part sur
la crise en Ukraine et l'inflation qui
en a résulté je voudrais rappeler que le
choix initial qui était fait en octobre
2021 c'est de protéger massivement
l'ensemble des Français avec la mise en
place de ce bouclier énergétique unique
en Europe plafonnement des prix du gaz
gel des prix du gaz et plafonnement des
prix de l'électricité vous avez raison
cette politique était coûteuse et vous
avez raison de souligner c'est bien pour
cela que nous la modifions au fur et à
mesure de son application qu'elle
protégeait tout le monde de manière
indifférencier et que désormais il est
temps qu'elle protège davantage les plus
modestes et que ceux qui en ont les
moyens puissent assumer une partie de ce
coup avec une augmentation de 15%. je
signale jusque l'avantage stratégique
qui a eu cette politique c'est de nous
permettre d'avoir le niveau d'inflation
le plus faible de tous les pays de la
zone euro il me semble que c'est un
avantage stratégique qui est important
je ne mes estime pas les revers que vous
avez indiqués mais j'estime que
l'avantage stratégique de contenir
l'inflation un niveau qui le plus faible
de tous les pays de la zone euro
l'emportait sur les inconvénients même
si je le redis les temps maintenant de
faire évoluer ces aides sur la
contribution inframarginale la taxation
des super profits appelé ça comme vous
voulez il n'y a qu'une seule chose qui
comptait pour nous
que nous puissions taxer les rentes des
énergéticiens je vois que le nouveau
ministre des Finances britanniques
s'engage en cette voie-là je vois que
tous les pays européens s'engagent dans
cette voie-là et je vois que ceux qui
avaient privilégié une taxation chez
Super profit de toutes les entreprises
s'aperçoivent de deux choses la première
c'est que ça rapporte moins qu'une
taxation sur les énergéticiens
uniquement et en deuxième lieu
qu'évidemment ça pénalise leurs grandes
entreprises industrielles dans des
secteurs qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
crise énergétique dans la compétition
mondiale donc je crois véritablement
qu'en mettant en place une taxation sur
les rente appeler sa super profit si
vous le voulez de tous les énergéticiens
que ce soit total que ce soit engie que
ce soit EDF c'était à la fois juste et
efficace et je ne veux pas que nos
compatriotes puissent croire un instant
que nous avons laissé des très grands
groupes énergétiques profitez de
l'explosion des prix de l'énergie tous
les profits qu'ils ont fait au dessus
certains niveaux nous avons récupéré ça
nous rapporte en 2023 26 milliards
d'euros aucun pays européen ne peut en
dire autant et je constate également que
cette intuition était tellement bonne
qu'elle était reprise par les autres
pays européens puisque le système de
taxation infrar marginale proposée par
la Commission européenne n'est que le
décalque de notre système de taxation
des énergéticiens que nous appliquons
depuis maintenant 2 ans donc moi je
préfère taxer ceux qui ont des rentes
que de pénaliser l'ensemble des grands
groupes industriels français au risque
de les fragiliser dans la compétition
mondiale on peut conjuguer justice
fiscale et efficacité fiscale il me
semble que c'est ce que nous avons fait
et croyez moi je ne compte pas en
arrêter là puisque nous sommes je le
rappelle le premier pays avoir mis en
place une taxation sur les genres du
numérique nous nous sommes battus pour
cela nous conjuguons justice et
efficacité cela rapporte 120 millions
d'euros et nous mettrons en place au
plus tard au début l'année 2023 une
taxation minimale à l'impôt chez société
pour éviter l'évasion et l'optimisation
fiscale
vous vous demandez ensuite si je cherche
la reconnaissance du Medef et vous le
faites avec un sourire qui fait plaisir
vous me connaissez suffisamment pour
savoir que nous ne cherchons tous ici
que la reconnaissance des Français et
que cette reconnaissance des Français
cette reconnaissance des Français ne
servons tous ici il me semble la même
ambition elle passe notamment en matière
de politique économique je sais que cela
vous tient très à coeur monsieur le
Président rénal par la reconquête
industrielle vous me demandez quel était
le fil rouge notre politique économique
notre fil rouge c'est le travail et
notre fil rouge c'est la reconquête
industrielle comme ministre d'économie
matin midi et soir je me bats pour cette
reconquête industrielle parce que
j'estime que ce qui nous redonnera de la
puissance économique ce qui nous
permettra de jouer notre rôle au 21ème
siècle du point de vue économique et ce
qui réellement redonnera du pouvoir
d'achat aux Français ce n'est pas la
redistribution c'est d'abord la création
d'emplois industriels qualifié formé
bien rémunéré donc l'enjeu est important
pour la France l'enjeu est important
pour notre indépendance technologique et
l'enjeu est important pour les salariés
et pour nos compatriotes par quoi est-ce
que cela passe cette reconquête
industrielle de la compétitivité d'où
cette baisse des impôts de production
qui va animer nos débats je pense qu'il
y a pas à tarder pour continuer à
baisser les impôts de production entre
pays je le dis à ceux qui me proposent
de reporter encore d'un an mais un an
c'est une éternité pour une entreprise
industrielle qui est confrontée à la
compétition mondiale je le dis personne
ne nous fera de cadeau et personne ne
nous attendra donc nous ne pouvons pas
attendre 12 mois supplémentaires pour
poursuivre la baisse des impôts de
production je propose que dès 2023 il y
a 4 milliards d'impôts de production en
moins qui seront concentrés sur les PME
industriels deuxième enjeu c'est la
formation et la qualification on le sait
tous la première richesse d'une
industrie c'est les salariés qui
travaillent et investir dans la
formation la qualification que ce soit
des ingénieurs des techniciens des
soudeurs des chaudronniers c'est le
meilleur investissement que la France
puisse faire enfin et c'est l'un des
défis qui nous attend pour les décennies
à venir
je le redis l'énergie sera la grande
question économique du 22e siècle et la
grande question économique de l'Europe
qu'aujourd'hui n'est pas indépendante et
doit devenir indépendante en matière de
production énergétique cela passe par
les combats que nous livrons avec le
président de la République d'abord pour
diversifier notre mix énergétique
réinvestir dans 6 réacteurs nucléaires
dont nous souhaitons la réalisation la
plus rapide possible nous nommerons dans
les tous prochains jours au Conseil des
ministres le nouveau président de DF la
première responsabilité du président
d'EDF la première mission qu'il sera
confiée c'est de produire plus
d'électricité le plus rapidement
possible pour servir nos industries et
nous permettre de passer l'hiver dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
au niveau européen au niveau européen
monsieur le Président rénal nous
continuerons à nous battre avec le
président de la République pour une
réforme en profondeur du marché européen
de l'énergie et pour un découplage
définitif des prix du gaz et des prix de
l'électricité enfin dernier sujet que
vous avez abordé à très juste titre
parce que c'est probablement le sujet
qui touche le plus nos compatriotes
aujourd'hui la rémunération du travail
la fraude n'est pas un sujet négligeant
mais il me semble qu'avant la fraude la
rémunération du travail est un sujet qui
touche le plus nos compatriotes
les salariés veulent vivre dignement de
leur travail et nous pouvons avoir une
fierté monsieur le Président rénal c'est
que l'un des seuls pays développés dans
lequel la rémunération du travail et la
rémunération du capital est restée
stable au cours des 20 dernières années
c'est la France
alors que tous les autres pays
développés ont vu exploser la
rémunération du capital par rapport à la
rémission du travail en France elle est
restée stable nous pourrons avoir le
débat nous pourrons avoir le débat elle
est restée stable en France je vous dis
pas qu'elle est parfaite et
satisfaisante nous cherche pas à
l'améliorer je dis juste que elle est
restée stable en deuxième lieu nous
sommes le seul pays avoir développé
aussi massivement les mécanismes
d'intéressement de participation de
prime défiscalisées d'actionnariat
salariés et tout ce qui a été fait par
la loi pacte nous avons débattu
longuement puisqu'ici il y a d'anciens
ministres qui sont depuis très longtemps
poste et d'ancien sénateurs qui sont là
depuis très longtemps en fonction aussi
nous avons eu ces débats sur la loi
pacte les résultats sont là vous avez
aujourd'hui 60% de salariés de PME en
plus qui ont un accord d'intéressement
grâce aux mesures de simplification et
d'allègement la fiscalité que vous avez
largement voté il y a maintenant plus de
4 ans ce dont je vous remercie
comment est-ce que l'on peut continuer à
avancer dans cette direction la
meilleure rémunération du travail
d'abord les salaires
oui d'abord les salaires
d'abord les salaires je crois avoir
toujours tenu ce discours là je le dis à
cette partie-là de l'hémicycle comme à
cette autre toutes les entreprises qui
le peuvent doivent augmenter les
salaires cela fait plus de 3 ans que je
le dis toutes les entreprises qui le
peuvent doivent augmenter les salaires
et d'ailleurs je constate je constate
qu'elles les ont augmenté en 2022 de
plus de 4%. donc ce ne sont pas des
paroles en l'air c'est des paroles qui
donnent des résultats et je tiens à
remercier les entrepreneurs qui ont
utilisé les marges de manœuvre dont il
disposé pour augmenter leur salaire je
sais que tous ceux qui le peuvent ne
souhaitent qu'une chose c'est pouvoir le
faire pour récompenser les salariés du
travail qu'ils ont accompli donc le
salaire c'est la première des réponses
ensuite il faut continuer à avancer vers
un meilleur partage de la valeur j'ai
redis que nous souhaitions avec Gabriel
Attal avec tous les membres de la
majorité que ce soit le grand débat du
début de l'année 2023 comment est-ce que
nous mettons en place un dividende
salarié comment est-ce que nous
garantissons de manière sur et certaines
qu'à chaque fois qu'une entreprise peut
se verser du dividende et bien le
salarié voit sa rémunération s'améliorer
le dividende salarié c'est le profit
pour tous et bien je propose que nous y
travaillons tous ensemble au début de
l'année prochaine
y a-t-il des demandes d'explication de
vote
se broyer
c'est le Président je remercie le
rapporteur général de sa réponse
argumentée et je conserve donc nos
interrogations sur la sincérité et la
volonté de du travail partagé avec le
Parlement mais notre groupe ne
souhaitant aucun cas qu'il n'y ait pas
de débat au contraire nous voulons que
ce débat existe qu'il soit sincères et
bien dans l'attente je retire donc au
nom de mon groupe cette motion d'y
recevabilité pour que ce débat ait lieu
au Sénat et nous verrons comment il sera
utilisé ou méprisé par le gouvernement
merci
je vais les retirer elle est retirée
nous allons passer à la discussion de la
motion préalable pendant
la motion tendance à opposer la question
préalable je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur à madame la Présidente
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'invocation à quatre prises de
l'article 49-3 de la Constitution a mis
un coup d'arrêt prématuré au débat
budgétaire sur les projets les projets
de loi de finance et de financement de
la sécurité sociale ce seul état de fait
justifie le dépôt d'une question
préalable et le rejet du texte puisque
celui-ci n'a pas fait l'objet à
l'Assemblée donc d'un débat approfondie
sur beaucoup trop de sujets un sénateur
ce matin parler à propos d'un texte
après le travail au CMP a dit que
justement ce travail en CMP incarnait un
bicarnéisme équilibré j'ai tendance à
dire cet après-midi que le bicamérisme
est plutôt déséquilibré
notre discussion s'ouvre dans un
contexte inédit la multiplication de
mise en jeu de la responsabilité de son
gouvernement par la première ministre
souligne d'une part la fragilité du
second mandat d'Emmanuel Macron mais
d'autre part et paradoxalement un
entêtement autoritaire une volonté
d'affirmer un exercice vertical du
pouvoir soit tenir compte de la volonté
exprimée lors du second tour de
l'élection présidentielle et lors des
élections législatives le Sénat peut-il
accepter ce véritable ou casse sans
réagir nous devons débattre au préalable
de cette situation inédite car
contrairement à des précédents recours
répétés au 49-3 celui-ci se déroule dans
un contexte politique en France en
Europe et à l'international un contexte
politique j'oserait dire des contextes
politiques très différents je le dis
d'emblée nous n'avons pas peur du débat
vous nous connaissez nous y sommes prêts
mais on est en droit de s'interroger à
quoi bon débattre d'un texte dont le
gouvernement finira en nouvelle lecture
par piocher les amendements auxquels il
daignent accorder ses préférences nous
dénonçons d'emblée ce jeu de dupes et
préférences nous les connaissons
satisfaire sa majorité relative 83% des
amendements retenus en émane nos
camarades de du groupe GDR à l'Assemblée
non eu l'honneur qu'à une seule
proposition conservée sur plus de 130
amendements signe du peu des gares que
le gouvernement témoigne aux
propositions alternatives les autres
groupes de la nups sont logés à la même
enseigne la situation est absolument
ubuesque la première ministre rejette
des amendements adoptés concerne des
amendements rejetés retient des
amendements dont discuté ce texte entre
guillemets sur mesure c'est construit au
détriment de la souveraineté
parlementaire la nouvelle méthode
prenait par le Président de la
République tout juste élu attendra
les dialogues de Bercy s'apparentaient
davantage au monologues de Bercy le 49.3
entérine un monologue budgétaire le
retour à cet article de la Constitution
et je cite le constitutionnalisme Pascal
Jean une arme lourde du Parlement du
parlementarisme rationalisé la
justification avancée par la première
ministre pour interrompre les débats et
je dois dire confondante je l'acte nous
ne tiendrons pas le délai pour cette
première partie du PLF ensuite et
surtout les oppositions ont toutes
réaffirmé leur volonté de rejeter le
texte avec elle défendu en toute
responsabilité à telle poursuivi nous
devons donner un budget à notre pays
alors mes chers collègues trois
arguments se dégagent le premier donné
un budget à notre pays nous le
souhaitons également
agiter la menace d'un Sean down à
l'américaine est une manipulation
coupable destinée à opposer le débat
démocratique et le bon fonctionnement de
l'administration publique en France le
rejet du projet loi de finances
n'entraîne nullement cessation partielle
d'activités nul problème pour la
rémunération des fonctionnaires nul
problème pour les dotations
collectivités territoriales des
mécanismes de réserve de report et
autres acompte permettent de pallier un
désaccord politique le chiffon rouge
d'un shutdown à la française et brandit
dans l'unique but de passer outre des
désaccords sur l'orientation budgétaire
de la nation le second argument est
d'ordre organisationnel le débat serait
long mes chers collègues je vais vous
faire une révélation c'est que la
démocratie prend du temps le débat
parlementaire de surcroît sur le texte
budgétaire prend du temps arguer que les
oppositions auraient déposé trop
d'amendements pour pouvoir les examiner
dans les délais impartis est une
manœuvre grossière le droit d'amendement
est le seul moyen d'expression des
parlementaires citez-moi une proposition
légitime une proposition d'obstruction
au débat vous n'en trouverez pas le rôle
de notre assemblée devrait être de
promouvoir une reprise de contrôle du
Parlement en matière budgétaire et non
pas se soumettre à un cadre de débat de
plus en plus restreint jusqu'à l'abusif
du 49-3 le troisième et dernière
argument invoqué par la première
ministre et peut-être le seul légitime
le gouvernement et sa majorité
insuffisante se sont fait mettre en
minorité par les députés de la nation le
constitutionnalisme dit Carcassonne
parlait du 49-3 comme d'un remède à
l'absence de majorité je crois au
contraire que c'est un poison pour le
pluralisme une majorité nette a affirmé
qu'elle ne voterait pas ce budget quand
vous quand vous quand vous y voyez vous
pardon un calcul politiqueien j'y vois
pour ma part un rejet politiquement
sincère pour des raisons extrêmement
différentes je vais vous faire part
ce texte consacre la poursuite d'une
politique libérale la prolongation d'un
nombre incalculable de niche fiscale
certaines sont utiles nous les voterions
d'autres sont inefficients leur coût
après de 100 milliards d'euros en 2023
ne sert souvent aucune politique
publique et Hérode les recettes
nécessaires pour mener à bien les grands
chantiers du pays pire certaines et
c'est le cas encore dans ce projet de
loi sont défavorables au climat la COP
27 est là pour nous le rappeler nous ne
contiendrons pas le réchauffement
climatique en deçà 1,5 degrés nous
croyons qu'il ne convient pas d'opposer
la cote d'alerte des finances publiques
qui obnubilent Monsieur le Maire à la
cote d'alerte climatique pour
paraphraser cette fois-ci le ministre
Gabriel Attal il y a dit-il des
économies qui coûtent et des dépenses
qui rapportent nous ne cesserons de vous
rappeler qu'un euro dans la transition
écologique investit aujourd'hui
100 euros que nous ne dépenserons pas
demain pour pallier ses conséquences
mieux chaque euro investit aujourd'hui
sont les économies d'aujourd'hui pour
nos concitoyens et nos concitoyens le
projet de budget pour 2023 poursuit une
logique de courtevue et une vision
comptable à la petite semaine un
bouclier par si un filet de sécurité par
là vous peinez à répondre à la crise
sociale provoquée par l'inflation la
population comme nos collectivités
connaissent une augmentation de leurs
factures énergétique que le bouclier
tarif et faire n'en raillera pas pour
les ménages et une partie des
collectivités la douloureuse et d'autant
plus sèche que depuis 10 années les
fractures les fractures d'électricité et
du gaz avaient déjà augmenté de 50%. le
gouvernement se borne à faire payer le
contribuable pour pallier les
difficultés du client les finances
publiques des notes de notre pays
méritent mieux que ça alors ce projet de
loi de finances pour 202 renforce aussi
l'injustice fiscale il diminue l'impôt
sur le revenu de tous et tous en
prétextant soulager les classes moyennes
que tous les contribuables de ce pays
m'entendent la classe moyenne notion
floue au demeurant ne gagne pas 160336 €
annuels pourquoi dès lors baisser les
impôts des plus riches c'est un choix
politique oui nous maintenant notre
volonté de rétablir une justice fiscale
en taxant les plus riches ce que
Monsieur Macron refuse obstinément
depuis 2017 ainsi vous le connaissez
l'ISF établi ces 3 milliards dans les
caisses de l'État exactement le coût de
l'amendement pour les transports voté à
la haine que vous avez enterré avec le
49-3 la suppression des entreprises est
également un marqueur du précédent
quinquennat vous persistez la
suppression de la cbae en réalité la
suppression de la relation entre
l'activité économique et les
collectivités la suppression entre la
richesse et l'endroit où elle je vois
dans cette décision à laquelle nous nous
opposons fermement une fracture fiscale
territoriale j'ajoute que cette
imposition constituée un rempart contre
l'évasion fiscale qui devrait ici toute
et tous nous rassembler cette décision
consacre la politique de l'offre mais
fait peser sur les ménages la baisse des
impôts des entreprises la compensation
d'une part de défait de TVA servira à
financer un énième cadeau fiscal
injustifié au patronat il
s'additionneront aux autres aides
fiscales directes ou indirects aux
subventions d'État qui culmine à 371
milliards d'euros ces deux exemples sont
graves et je vous le redis il n'y a
qu'un pas entre la continuité et
l'obstination ces visions politiques
n'ont pas été débattues à l'Assemblée
nationale et pour cause elles ont ces
débats ont été interrompus après
seulement quatre articles et la seconde
après seulement 7 mission j'entends sur
les banques de la majorité sénatoriale
qu'il convient de débattre pour faire
vivre le bicamérisme qui je le répète et
pourtant a mis à mal aujourd'hui voir la
démocratie tout court mais débattre pour
qui le gouvernement reprendra du Sénat
les seules propositions qui estiment au
mépris de notre institution il piochera
comme il l'a fait à l'Assemblée
nationale dans les propositions qui lui
sont faites qu'il pioche d'ores et déjà
dans nos amendements ils sont déposés et
sont à votre disposition je vous
remercie
merci madame la Présidente y a-t-il une
expression contre la motion je n'en vois
pas quelle est la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
madame la présente mes chers collègues
je vais confirmer ce que j'ai déjà dit
tout à l'heure je redis que notre
démocratie a de mon point de vue un
grand besoin d'écoute de dialogue de
respect et que ça doit
être pratiqué sur l'ensemble des bancs
de notre assemblée mais aussi de la part
du gouvernement dont on a pu dans le
quinquennat précédent regretté trop
souvent peut-être par le fait
majoritaire à l'époque à l'Assemblée
nationale une position ou des choix trop
unilatéraux je crois
c'est le choix du gouvernement en tous
les cas de du Parlement et du Sénat mais
je crois que pour bien dialoguer et
travailler il faut être deux et que le
gouvernement par rapport à notre
attitude
d'engager le débat ici au Sénat à une
responsabilité particulière je crois
qu'il doit lui aussi faire vivre la
démocratie et je dirais presque entre
guillemets pour de vrai parce que je ne
crois pas que nous devions soutenir ni
l'immobilisme ni laisser prospérer des
visions qui sont par trop des raccourcis
le gouvernement doit montrer con qu'il
croit à ce que j'appelle l'intelligence
partagée plutôt que de laisser prospérer
ce qu'on a payé à les fractures
territoriales sociales écologique qui si
on les laisse prospérer deviennent de la
fragmentation pour pas dire de
l'émettement et je ne suis pas favorable
à une France en miette parce que on sait
que dans ce cas là le risque c'est que
l'opinion prospère sur le terreau des
populismes de tout poil de tous ordres
et que cette absolument pas ce dont on a
besoin raison pour laquelle notre
assemblée doit impérativement débattre
avec un gouvernement qui doit écouter et
prendre en compte les différentes idées
qui seront ici débattues pour bien sûr
ne pas balayer d'Arvert de main mais
c'est sa responsabilité elle est
éminente mais c'est la responsabilité
monsieur le ministre du gouvernement
auquel vous appartenez merci Monsieur le
Ministre la vie du gouvernement
oui je voudrais confirmer après des
propos du
rapporteur général Jean-François Huchon
que nous avons ici dans un esprit de
dialogue de compromis nous l'a montré
sur le pdfr et j'espère que nous
pourrons trouver des accords sur des
propositions de quelques banques qu'ils
puissent venir
un mot simplement sur ce qui a été dit
sur la question de la fiscalité le
mérite de notre ligne politique c'est
qu'elle est claire nous sommes opposés à
toute augmentation de taxes ou d'impôts
pour une raison qui est très simple
c'est que nous avons le niveau
d'imposition le plus élevé de tous les
pays développés
et que lorsque vous êtes dans cette
situation là je ne pense pas que ce soit
la meilleure solution que d'augmenter
toujours plus un niveau d'imposition qui
est déjà le plus élevé tous les pays
développés alors on dirait il est pas
suffisamment bien réparti oui mais je
constate que aujourd'hui
70% de l'impôt sur le revenu est payé
par 10 % des contribuables on me dit le
prélèvement forfaitaire unique il faut
absolument l'augmenter mais l'imposition
du capital en France comparé à
l'Allemagne comparé à d'autres grands
pays est au-dessus de l'imposition du
capital dans la moyenne de la zone euro
on me dit faut pas baisser les impôts de
production il faut pas supprimer la c.a
mais je constate que malgré tous les
efforts que nous avons déjà engagés nous
avons le niveau de fiscalité sur la
production qui est 5 à 6 fois plus élevé
encore que celui de l'Allemagne donc on
peut pas pleurer sur la
désindustrialisation de la France qui
est la pire des décisions économiques et
politiques étaient prises depuis 30 ans
dans ce dont on paye encore les
conséquences économiques dont on paye
encore les conséquences politiques dans
nos territoires dans les élections et
dans le rapport de force avec les
grandes nations développées et dans le
même temps dire on va garder un niveau
d'imposition 5 à 6 fois plus élevé que
celui de l'Allemagne il faut de la
cohérence il faut de la fermeté dans ses
choix de politique économique les nôtres
sont claires nous voulons alléger la
fiscalité qui pèse sur les entreprises
industrielles nous voulons garantir la
reconquête industrielle et avant de
penser à répartir des richesses nous
réfléchissons d'abord en créer de
nouvelles
merci pour explication de votre monsieur
Bocquet
quelques mots avant de passer au vote de
cette motion nous prenons acte
évidemment des arguments de notre
rapporteur général qui qui vend tout
comme nous les vertus du Bic à mérisme
c'est pas seulement de chambre c'est le
Parlement le Parlement dans son unité
c'est ainsi qu'il faut le concevoir et
les deux chambres doivent se défendre
quand l'une de l'autre est piétiné c'est
ce qui s'est passé c'est l'unité
institutionnelle qui en dépend donc vous
devez clarifier votre position selon
nous soutenez-vous le passage en force
au titre de l'article 49.3 sur le texte
budgétaires première question ensuite
quelle garantie avez-vous obtenu sur la
considération de l'exécutif vis-à-vis
des propositions adoptées au Sénat
l'excellent Charles Dickens n'arrêt de
la sorte le mépris de l'exécutif au
regard du travail législatif par ses
lignes désolé de faire quelque chose qui
risque d'interrompre des activités aussi
sympathiques comme disait le roi au
moment de dissoudre le Parlement fin de
citation le Sénat sonore Ré à ne pas
cautionner le mépris avec lequel il a
été décidé des sujets sur lesquels
l'Assemblée nationale pouvait débattre
les collectivités territoriales se sera
non en première partie le débat sur la
mission des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales et repoussée
puis le 49.3 Annie il s'est débats ils
ne sont pas tenus le rapporteur général
portant la voix de la majorité nous
explique qu'il faut que l'on est ce
débat le débat sur le budget pour 2023
s'est fait dans la presse pour ainsi
dire quasiment pas dans l'hémicycle en
acceptant ce débat tronqué par un
gouvernement qui poursuit ses annonces
sans transmettre son texte qui continue
d'en faire la promotion sans
contradicteur le Sénat se fourvoie la
teinte mes chers collègues est grave
elle se reproduira certainement l'année
prochaine les suivantes tout au long se
quinquennat que décidera à la majorité
sénatoriale que les débats doit se tenir
pour sol de tout compte à la démocratie
voilà qui selon nous est un peu léger le
Parlement doit faire corps doit faire
front unis pour refuser les entraves aux
conditions sereine du débat démocratique
la question préalable que nous vous
opposons vous le savez n'est pas une
dérobase ce n'est pas le genre de la
maison nous sommes prêts nous aussi à
affronter le gouvernement et la majorité
sénatoriale nous sommes prêts à faire
valoir notre projet de justice fiscale
de justice sociale et du renforcement de
l'indispensable d'intervention publique
pour enrayer les dérives du marché c'est
un message d'alerte c'est une opposition
franche à la méthode et au contenu du
projet de loi nous vous appelons à la
même clarté merci beaucoup chers
collègues
je vais donc consulter le Sénat sur la
motion pendant à opposer la question
préalable je rappelle que l'adoption de
cette notion entraînerait le rejet du
texte en discussion en application
d'articles 59 du règlement le scrutin
public ordinaire et de droit le scuteur
sera ouvert dans quelques instants je
vous rappelle un avis défavorable de la
commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement le scrutin est ouvert
scrutin et clos
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 57
sur la motion numéro 1287 contenu de
l'ensemble de délégation de vote
accordée par les sénateurs au groupe
politique et notifié à la présidence
nombre de votants 344 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 279 pour l'adoption
27 contre 252 le Sénat n'a pas adopté la
motion nous pouvons poursuivre notre
programme dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Monsieur Daniel
broyier groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoires pour 9 minutes chers
collègues
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur général monsieur
le Président de la Commission chers
collègue nous ouvrons donc ce débat du
PLF 2023 quelques jours avant la clôture
de la Coop 2027 et quelques mois après
un été marqué par les canicules les
sécheresses les incendies de forêts et
les épisodes météo horlogiques
gravissime un Français sur deux vit dans
une ville exposée au surcharneurs
urbaine et bientôt deux tiers du pays
sera exposée à des sécheresses durables
générant d'immenses problèmes de gestion
de la ressource en eau nous ouvrons ce
débat alors que la biodiversité les
écosystèmes sont malmenés
32% des oiseaux nicheurs sont menacés de
disparition du territoire comme 19% des
poissons d'eau douce ces chiffres vous
les connaissez puisqu'ils sont issus du
site écologique.gouv
nous l'ouvrons dans un contexte marqué
également par la guerre menée par la
Russie en Ukraine trajet du humaine à
quelques milliers de kilomètres dont
certains hélas profitent envolés des
cours des énergies inflation voire
risque de récession des conséquences
sont brutales pour notre pays nos
concitoyens pour les territoires et pour
notre économie le pouvoir d'achat des
Français mis à mal et les effets peuvent
être redoutables notamment pour les
personnes âgées des étudiants les foyers
modestes à la limite du seuil de
pauvreté car 5% d'inflation n'a pas le
même impact lorsqu'on gagne 1500 euros
ou lorsqu'on en touche 500 5000 ou plus
voilà trois ans alors que la pandémie
s'étendait au monde entier le président
déclarait nous sommes en guerre il
invitait le gouvernement et chaque
composante de la société à se mobiliser
nous n'avions aucune anticipation
stratégique possible pour faire face à
cette épidémie dans l'ampleur était
inédite aujourd'hui votre incapacité à
anticiper concrètement les effets des
dérèglements climatiques est affligeante
alors que la COP 2027 souligne l'urgence
absolue le projet de loi de finance que
vous mettez en débat relève au-delà de
quelques mesures bienvenue de la
sacro-sainte orthodoxie libérale baisse
des impôts retour à un moindre déficit
et désarmement financiers de l'État
cette trajectoire marque une absence de
conviction et de volonté de s'attaquer
réellement à la crise climatique de
l'anticiper si possible et de nous y
adapter au fond ces crises conforte
hélas les analyses que porte les
écologistes sur notre société depuis
tant d'années j'aurais préféré qu'il en
fut autrement mais la crise est là les
incertitudes s'amplifient elles exigent
une boussole et un cap
Edgar Morin rappelle que vivre c'est
naviguer dans une merde d'incertitude à
travers des îlots et des archipels de
certitudes sur lesquelles on se
ravitaille des îlots et des chars et des
archipels vers la transition écologique
nous en identifions en voici un qui fut
voté à l'assemblée il consiste à
s'engager efficacement et immédiatement
dans l'isolation thermique des bâtiments
vous mettez 47 milliards dans des
boucliers énergétiques et 2 milliards et
demi pour la rénovation du bâti cette
proportion dit tout c'est une erreur
c'est même une faute le bouclier doit
être plus ciblé j'ai entendu d'ailleurs
que vous le reconnaissiez et la
rénovation doit être plus large un
investissement massif dans l'isolation
thermique permettrait à des millions de
familles de ne plus vivre dans la
précarité énergétique diminuerait notre
dépendance aux fossiles nos émissions de
CO2 dont un quart proviennent du
chauffage c'est aussi rendre ses
logements habitables et c'est essentiel
aujourd'hui on peut aussi ravitailler
financièrement le bateau France en
créant un ISF climatique au-delà des 10
milliards de recettes potentielles vous
permettriez ainsi au plus aisés qui sont
aussi ceux qui polluent le plus de
contribuer bien plus activement à cette
bifurcation écologique et je suis sûr
qu'ils nous en serait grasse le
patrimoine cumulé des 500 plus grandes
fortunes françaises dépassant les mille
milliards d'euros cette participation
serait un effort modeste et acceptable
en rapport à la soutenabilité de leur
mode de vie pour que notre planète reste
véritable
en instaurant un système de bonus malus
bonus et moins de fiscalité pour tout ce
qui répare ce qui recycle ce qui
soutient la sobriété et malus pour tout
ce qui augmente les émissions les
consommations excessives en soutenant
aussi vigoureusement la recherche la
création culturelle la vie associative
l'éducation et tout ce qui fait de notre
société une démocratie humaniste et
éclairée
l'école l'hôpital la justice l'accueil
du grand âge de la petite enfance
l'accès au logement pas un secteur où
les besoins d'intervention de l'État ne
soient cruyant c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous voulons une redistribution
des richesses par un impôt plus
progressif la taxation des dividendes et
celle des profits excessifs et je répète
le mot des super profits même les
intérêts de la dette qui passent à 50
milliards 14 de plus que l'année passée
mériterait que vous ne désarmiez pas la
capacité financière de l'État et
pourtant vous supprimez 8 milliards de
CVAE en deux ans comme si nous pouvions
à ce point nous passer de recettes
fiscales si nécessaire à améliorer nos
services publics qui sont en souffrance
quant aux outils de l'État en faveur de
la transition écologique l'Office
National des Forêts Météo France
l'Office français de la biodiversité le
cerema touche ont besoin de moyens
humains et financiers les quelques
unités supplémentaires que vous leur
accordez ne compensent pas les coupes
sombres des dernières dernières années
pire vous diminuez dans ce budget de
4295 et TP les services de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires nous voulons aussi messieurs
les ministres une société plus inclusive
et plus juste 57 milliards de dividendes
versés dans passé notre pays pulvérise
ainsi le record d'Europe des dividendes
versées en athlétisme on aurait exigé un
contrôle antidopage face à une
performance si incroyable
mais cette performance ne se traduit pas
par une hausse des rémunérations des
salariés des écarts de revenus sont
toujours plus insupportables ils exigent
des réponses nouvelles et en premier
lieu de mieux rémunérer le travail nous
devrions aussi garantir à tous nos
concitoyens un accès un coût très bas au
premier mètre cube d'eau au premier
mégawattheure de gaz ou d'électricité
pour que chacun se voit garantir ce qui
lui est essentiel pour vivre quant au
superflu ou aux non-essentiels que
chacun paye voilà une mesure simple de
justice sociale le gouvernement doit
réorienter ses financements publics vers
tout ce qui rend notre société plus
durable et résiliente une agriculture
paysanne une équité d'accès aux services
publics sur tout le territoire une
alimentation bio et locale abordable via
le chèque alimentaire promis encore
attendu
la lutte contre les îlots de chaleur la
liste pourrait être longue et nous
déposerons des amendements ce sens
surtout ces sujets que nous défendrons
avec ferveur quant aux fonds verts de 2
milliards il a l'avantage d'être d'abord
un fond vert de recyclage mais il ne
suffira pas à couvrir tous ses besoins
enfin nous voulons messieurs des
ministres une république des territoires
une véritable acceptation de votre part
de la décentralisation laissez les
collectivités confrontées à la crise du
logement à l'impossibilité de loger les
étudiants et les jeunes ménages en
raison de la multiplication des
résidences secondaires et des Airbnb
libre de fixer leurs taxe d'habitation
sur les résidences secondaires celles
sur les hôtels de luxe ou les logements
vacants laissez au collectivités en
charge des transports collectifs la
possibilité de moduler le versement
mobilité des transports protéger les en
élargissant le bouclier énergétique ou
même en indexant la DGF à l'inflation
comme ce fut longtemps le cas et surtout
renoncer à votre volonté de contrôler
leur choix
cet article 23 maquillé en 44 heures sur
le sujet sur lequel vous ne répondez pas
les marges d'amélioration de ce projet
de loi de finance sont nombreuses notre
groupe fera des propositions
il me semble toutefois indispensable de
poser deux postulats la fraternité et
l'égalité de notre devise républicaine
nécessite de réduire les injustices et
de mieux distribuer la richesse produite
dans notre pays la dette climatique est
au moins aussi dangereuse que la dette
financière c'est vrai pour aujourd'hui
comme pour demain
merci infiniment chers collègues la
parole est à présent à Monsieur tevaro
Fritsch pour le groupe rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes indépendants
vous avez six minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général cher collègue bonjour
ce projet de loi de finance le premier
de ce nouveau quinquennat s'inscrit dans
la continuité de l'action de la majorité
présidentielle tout en s'attachant à
faire face au défi stratégique actuel et
répondre aux attentes des Français face
aux crises
ce PLF poursuit en effet la politique de
l'offre menée depuis 2017 en soutient à
la compétitivité de nos entreprises et
au pouvoir d'achat des ménages alors que
le premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
avait déjà mis en oeuvre plusieurs
allègements fiscaux de la réforme de
l'ISF à la réduction massive dans
l'impôt sur le revenu en passant par la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation sur
les résidences principales portant la
baisse totale à plus de 50 milliards
d'euros au profit des Français cela a
été rappelé ce PLF pour 2023 prévoit de
nouveaux allègrements nous proposons
ainsi de supprimer en deux temps pour
moitié dès le mois de janvier prochain
un peu une suppression définitive en
2024 la cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée
des entreprises nous entendons quelques
réticents sur ce sujet mais nous notons
aussi que bon nombre de ceux qui veulent
aujourd'hui s'opposer à cette baisse ont
pu la proposer durant la campagne
présidentielle
cette réforme bénéficiera à tout notre
tissu industriel je tiens à souligner
d'emblée cette suppression en deux temps
sera intégralement compensée il n'est
pas question d'assécher les cons des
collectivités locales comme nous avons
pu l'entendre et si nous avons des
désaccords sur les modalités de
compensation ce qui est bien normal dans
notre assemblée nous devrions en
discuter travailler amender négocier
plutôt que de renoncer purement et
simplement une réforme qui est attendue
depuis longtemps par les acteurs
économiques du pays pourquoi pas
soulignons également que les réformes
fiscales et les dispositifs de soutien
engagés au cours des dernières années
ont porté leurs fruits et se traduisent
en dynamisme des recettes fiscales dans
nos collectivités profiteront également
chers collègues le choix que nous avons
fait de compenser la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation par une pâte TVA
conduit une compensation plus dynamique
que l'on que non jamais été celle des
réformes fiscales précédentes le pouvoir
d'achat des Français a cru de 1% par an
depuis 2017 ce qui représente un gars
annuel moyen de 300 euros ce qui est une
performance appréciable et jusque là
inégalée et c'est d'autant plus notable
que nous avons connu deux années de
crise sans précédent deux années durant
lesquelles le revenu des ménages n'a
pourtant pas diminuer l'épargne à
atteint des niveaux record notre
politique économique porte ses fruits il
faut bien le reconnaître et l'apprécier
collectivement
ce PLF pour 2023 est cohérent avec notre
cap parce qu'il vise le plein emploi en
prolongeant des dispositifs efficaces et
reconnus comme tel après la crise de
2008 le chômage atteignait les 9 et demi
pour cent sous le quinquennat suivant
est dépassé même les dix et demi à
l'époque le seul horizon était
l'inversion de la cour du chômage de la
courbe du chômage comme si la bataille
de l'emploi était déjà perdue
aujourd'hui la baisse est continue et le
chômage s'apprête à passer au-dessous
des 7%, le plein emploi est à notre
portée ce PLF poursuit les efforts nous
renfonçons renforçant pardon le
financement de l'apprenti de
l'apprentissage près de 900 000 jeunes
en ont bénéficié en 2021 nous visons
désormais le cap du million de
bénéficiaires d'ici à 2027 et pour cela
3,5 milliards d'euros ils seront
consacrés parmi les 31 milliards te dit
crédités au ministère du Travail le taux
d'emploi des 15 24 ans a progressé de
5,3 points entre fin 2015 et fin 2021
c'est un point fondamental car l'emploi
des jeunes et la clé d'une société
prospère et c'est résultat Hollande des
conséquences positives sur toute une
génération qui sera moteur à notre
économie du financement de notre modèle
social pour les années qui viennent
d'autres dispositifs sont également
poursuivis avec un effort de 300
millions d'euros pour le fnoformation
visant à soutenir les entreprises et
salariés en difficulté 84 millions
d'euros pour le plan de réduction des
tensions de recrutement pour assouplir
les frictions sur le marché du travail
enfin 50 millions en faveur du
dispositif transition collective le
gouvernement soutient pleine emploi et
nous voulons l'atteindre ici 2027 alors
que nous sommes en pleine semaine
européenne pour l'emploi des personnes
handicapées nous pouvons tous nous
féliciter la traînette baisse du taux de
chômage des personnes en situation de
handicap cette baisse est de 5 points
depuis 2017 la cohérence de ce budget
c'est enfin un soutien sans précédent en
fonction régaliennes pour la troisième
année consécutive ce sont des
trajectoires inédites de progression des
crédits cela a été rappelé 8% de hausse
du budget de la justice pour la
troisième fois l'an prochain 3000 postes
seront ouverts au ministère intérieur
2300 à la justice 1500 à la défense
nous avons des pas du débattu de la
trajectoire pluriannuelle de nombreux
collègues ont exprimer des critiques sur
ces points précis mais ce sont pourtant
bien ses efforts là qui sont financés
tout en proposant de revenir sous le
seuil des 3% en 2027 c'est aussi dans
cette épure et avec le souci de
l'équilibre nos finances publiques que
notre groupe portera des amendements
pour soutenir les collectivités locales
face à l'inflation
pour renforcer notre tissu productif et
pour soutenir les territoires qui en ont
le plus besoin c'est en ce sens que je
vous proposerai aussi un amendement pour
soutenir les investissements dans nos
collectivités d'outre-mer et en
particulier celle du Pacifique mais si
vous souhaitez malgré tout une
trajectoire budgétaire plus exigeante
encore chers collègues dites-nous ceux à
quoi nous devrions renoncer comme
affronter dès lors les défis qui se
présentent ils ont été rappelés soutenir
les collectivités locales réarmer les
fonctions régaliennes rénover notre
système éducatif éducatif financer la
transition écologique tout en diminuant
la pression fiscale qui pèse sur nos
entreprises et sur les ménages
au fond de vous vous en conviendrez ce
projet de loi de finance trace pour
notre pays une trajectoire cohérente et
pertinente et vise à répondre
efficacement aux attentes légitimes des
Français de métropole comme des
Outre-mer c'est la loi de l'action celle
vers le plein emploi celle qui exprime
de manière ciblée les solidarités
attendus des Français de nos entreprises
et de nos collectivités c'est cette
action qui nous est proposée et nous
vous appelons à la soutenir le groupe
RDPI soutiendra ce projet de loi de
finance merci merci chers collègues la
parole est à présent Monsieur Thierry
Cozic sénateur du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le sénateur vous avez 6 minutes
bonsoir
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
c'est sous emprise que nous abordons
aujourd'hui le projet de loi de finances
pour l'année 2023 nous sommes mes chers
collègues sous l'emprise de l'article
49-3 qui est certes constitutionnel mais
qui musait les organes de la démocratie
représentative
nous avons donc à nous prononcer sur un
budget animé par des logiques quasi
schizophréniques dans votre souci de
maintenir afflo l'économie par divers
aides se heurtent à votre volonté de
commencer à instaurer une austérité qui
ne veut pas dire son nom
car ne nous y trompons pas il faut bien
considérer cette loi de finances pour ce
qu'elle est le deuxième budget le plus
austéritaire des 20 dernières années
une fois neutralisé l'impact de la fin
des mesures exceptionnelles liées au
covid-19 les 65 milliards d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires prévues
suffisent tout juste à couvrir le coût
de l'inflation
ces 20 dernières années une seule fois
le budget des services publics aura
connu restriction plus importante par
rapport à l'année précédente en 2018
quelques mois avant la crise des gilets
jaunes
comprendre qui voudra
je le dis ce budget aura un impact sur
des tensions sociales déjà
substantielles tout comme il aura un
impact à court terme sur l'état de nos
services publics et donc sur la réforme
aux besoins de la population
derrière ces arbitrages budgétaires si
notre capacité à préparer collectivement
l'avenir qui est en jeu
un avenir dans nos élus dans les
territoires pénatrassés des contours
radieux
leur donner des marges de manœuvre et
vitales car il ne demande pas l'aumône
mais simplement la capacité à penser le
futur sereinement
voter l'amendement que je porterai au
nom du groupe socialiste sur
l'indexation de la DGF sur l'inflation
participe de cette sérénité si
nécessaire
les crises sanitaires énergétiques et
sociales malmaines nos collectivités qui
sont en première ligne et qui pour
certaines ne savent pas comment boucler
leur budget
la hausse des dépenses d'énergie ça
n'est pas moins de 11 milliards d'euros
ce n'est pas un hasard monsieur le
ministre silord des débats à l'Assemblée
nationale le 49-3 était déclenché avant
que les articles relatifs aux
collectivités locales souhaitent étudier
vous êtes même allé jusqu'à intervertir
ce chapitre avec celui de la justice
repoussant la discussion sur les
collectivités au vendredi suivant pour
finalement ne jamais l'aborder
ici au Sénat vous ne pourrez pas vous
dérober d'ailleurs vos chinoiseries
parlementaires ne témoignent
que trop bien du malaise qui vous habite
sur la question
les collectivités paient votre volonté
de rigueur d'ailleurs votre cadrage
budgétaire est symptomatique de cela car
vous souhaitez de toute force atteindre
les 5% de déficit en 2023 tout en
baissant les impôts des entreprises
mais qui peut croire à l'instant que ces
mesures portant si antinomiques
permettrait de financer les services
publics ou dégager les marges de
manœuvre nécessaire pour financer la
transition écologique
car si je devais résumer votre ambition
budgétaire en matière environnementale
je la résumerai en une phrase un peu
plus de verres et beaucoup plus de gris
qu'on se le tienne pour dire je peine à
voir ce qu'il y a de vert à poursuivre
les baisses d'impôts sans contrepartie
environnementale tout en subventionnant
massivement la consommation d'énergie
fossile
votre politique de l'offre a permis
depuis 5 ans la disparition de 50
milliards d'impôts de production en
faveur des entreprises afin et je vous
cite de favoriser la croissance et
l'emploi mais tout ceci a été fait sans
jamais demander de contrepartie sociale
et environnementale
la chambre haute n'a pas ignoré les uns
5 milliards d'euros destinés à
accompagner les efforts dans la
transition écologique des collectivités
territoriales par le biais du fond vert
nous serons attentifs à ce que comme si
engagé le gouvernement ce montant soit
intégralement engagé en 2023 et nous
serons tout aussi vigilants à vérifier
jusqu'où la mesure vient s'ajouter et
non se substituer aux dépenses
préexistantes
je note que d'ores et déjà la dotation
annoncée de 150 millions d'euros pour la
stratégie nationale pour la biodiversité
en 2023 sera portée par le fond vert en
toute état de cause se font est très
insuffisant pour permettre aux
collectivités de réaliser les
investissements qui sont de leurs
compétences afin d'atteindre les
objectifs nationaux de neutralité
carbone
selon l'institut pour l'économie du
climat elle devrait investir chaque
année de l'ordre 10 milliards d'euros
par an soit près du triple de l'effort
actuellement réalisé nos collectivités
territoriales ne sont absolument pas
réticentes à engager le virage
écologique l'époque nous intime
urgemment d'amorcés néanmoins elles ont
besoin qu'on les soutiennent en
accélérant les décaissement du fond vert
pour le climat pour la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments
nos collectivités ont surtout besoin de
retrouver des marges de manœuvre
fiscales nous vous proposons de leur
permettre si elles le souhaitent
d'augmenter la taxe d'habitation pour
les résidences secondaires
les grands changements sociétaux et
écologiques de l'époque nous oblige et
nous oblige à regarder l'avenir non pas
avec les lunettes du passé mais celle de
demain
nous porterons plusieurs amendements
soucieux de défendent une vision du
monde plus altruiste mais tout aussi
exigeante vous nous aviez venté durant
des semaines votre sens du compromis et
de la co-construction par votre soutien
aux amendements nous pourrons vérifier
que tout ceci n'était qu'un quant à toi
Winston Churchill disait
mieux vaut prendre le changement par la
main avant qu'il ne nous prenne par la
gorge je crains monsieur le ministre
qu'avec ce budget vous ayez seulement dû
l'avenir et qu'à la fin nous soyons tous
pris à la gorge je vous remercie cher
collègue je passe la parole à présent à
Monsieur Eric Bocquet sénateur du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste vous avez 10 minutes chers
collègues
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues voici donc venus le
temps d'examiner
au Sénat le PLF pour 2023 un budget
disiez vous lors de sa présentation fin
septembre destiné à protéger les
Français il nous faut donc examiner le
texte à l'aune de cette belle ambition
de communication
rappelons d'abord le cadre général dans
lequel il s'inscrit ni la crise dite des
gilets jaunes ni la pandémie de covid ni
enfin la guerre en Ukraine et ses
conséquences concrètes dans notre vie
quotidienne n'auront eu raison de votre
dogme absolu de réduction coûte que
coûte de la dépense publique votre
gouvernement a transmis mi-août son
programme de stabilité à la Commission
européenne ce document décrit la
stratégie pour les comptes publics pour
la période 2022-2027 Sophie directeur
est de contenir la hausse de l'ensemble
des dépenses publiques à 06 % Bercy
promet donc de réduire les dépenses de
l'État et les collectivités locales sur
le quinquennat
indépendamment des crises que notre pays
traverse cela nous rappelle le retour à
l'orthodoxie budgétaire tel que le
décrivent les traités de Maastricht et
de Lisbonne vous n'aimez pas ces mots
monsieur le ministre mais votre
politique c'est bien une austérité qui
ne dit pas son nom
l'effort en dépense exigé des
administrations en 2023 prix pour les
années suivantes est assumé par le
gouvernement vos documents budgétaires
indiquent sur la période 2022 2027 une
croissance moyenne de la dépense unique
de 0,6%, cette maîtrise de la dépense
sera ponctuée sera portée pardon par
l'ensemble des administrations publiques
la politique fiscale menée pendant le
précédent quinquennat surtout favorisé
les entreprises et les ménages les plus
aisés sont ainsi 54 milliards ou moindre
recettes sur cinq ans pour moitié à
destination des entreprises le
gouvernement prévoit une diminution des
recettes publiques liées au prélèvement
de 45,2% du PIB en 2022 à 44,7 en 2023
vos choix continuent à menuiser de
manière pérenne des recettes publiques
vous choisissez de faire supporter
l'intégralité de l'effort sur des
services publics déjà exangs vous
persistez dans le refus d'activer le
levier fiscal qui pourrait permettre de
répartir l'effort budgétaire de manière
redistributive
ce débat sur l'imposition des dividendes
c'était imposé au cœur de l'été lors du
débat sur le premier PLF Monsieur le
Maire à l'époque disait ne pas savoir ce
qui était les super profits j'imagine
que ces derniers mois ont éclairé sa
long terme car en effet le débat n'est
pas clou il traverse même toute l'Europe
l'ONG observatoire des multinationales a
calculé que les dividendes versées par
les entreprises du CAC 40 avaient été
l'an dernier cela a été rappelé par
certains collègues un montant record de
57,5 milliards d'euros et l'année 2022
s'annonce encore plus prolifique aux
dividendes en haut de 32% par rapport à
2020 il faut ajouter les rachats
d'actions visant à soutenir
artificiellement les cours en Bourse
soit pour les actionnaires une
gratification de 23 milliards en 2021
dans ce commentaire à l'ONG indique la
contribution fiscale des groupes du CAC
40 semble croître bien moins rapidement
que leur profit et leur dividendes
quelques 14% de l'ensemble des filiales
du CAC 40 sont localisés d'ailleurs dans
des paradis fiscaux rappelons-le la
rémunération moyenne d'un dirigeant de
ces grands groupes a progressé de 26,4%
entre 2019 et 2021
votre position est d'autant plus
inacceptable que ces mêmes groupes
bénéficient sous des formes les plus
diverses de subventions publiques une
étude récente montrait ainsi qu'en avril
2019 ce sont près de 160 milliards
d'euros qu'ils auront été versés ce
montant représente le premier poste de
dépenses de l'État en 1980 son montant
en atteignait pas des milliards et il
faut noter que ces aides ne sont
aucunement conditionnées à l'évidence il
faudrait réfléchir à au moins imposer
des contreparties encadrement dans le
versement des dividendes afin de
soutenir plutôt les salaires et les
investissements écologiques de long
terme sans compter que plus de 30% des
bénéfices des multinationales sont
transférés allègrement dans les paradis
fiscaux en refusant l'utiliser la
taxation vous privilégiez le recours à
la dette en effet nous emprunterons l'an
prochain 270 milliards d'euros alors que
nos recettes fiscales prévues
s'établissent à 345 milliards
la contrainte budgétaire extrêmement
forte qui pèse sur les différents
administrations conduira directement à
de nouvelles dégradations plusieurs
conséquences concrètes de cette
austérité peuvent d'ores et déjà être
identifiés à titre d'illustration le PLF
affiche ainsi une baisse de 1% pour
l'hébergement parcours vers le logement
et insertion des personnes vulnérables
avec le fermeture de plus de 20 000
places de même en observe une baisse de
23,8% des crédits alloués à la stratégie
interministérielle de prévention et de
lutte contre la pauvreté des jeunes
monsieur le ministre nous sommes à
quelques jours de l'ouverture à Paris du
104e congrès des maires de France qui va
rassembler pas moins de 10 000 et le
locaux depuis la communication des
éléments du budget 2023 les réactions de
toutes les associations des luttes n'ont
pas manqué la mesure la plus critiquée
et l'annonce de la suppression de la
contribution sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises la fameuse CVE ce sont ainsi
plus de 8 milliards d'euros qui vont
disparaître des caisses et collectivités
après la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle il y a 12 ans celle de
la taxe d'habitation aujourd'hui de la
celle de la CVAE tout cela sans
concertation nous rêvons tous une
République où l'on demanderait la vie
des maires et des élus locaux avant
toute décision de suppression d'un impôt
revenant légitimement aux collectivités
locales vous lui expliquez pour
justifier ce choix que les collectivités
doivent elles aussi contribuer à
l'effort de redressement des comptes
publics c'est d'abord injuste car les
collectivités n'ont aucune
responsabilité dans le déséquilibre des
contes de la nation elles sont tenues de
par la loi de voter un budget équilibre
l'état emprunte pour financer son
fonctionnement les collectivités pour
investir la part de la dette des
collectivités dans la dette globale du
pays représentent environ 8% du total et
ce chiffre n'a pas varié depuis trois
décennies
d'ailleurs l'effort demandé aux
collectivités a déjà été effectuées
elles ont déjà participé pour 46
milliards au redressement des comptes
publics ces dernières années vous
laissez entendre que les collectivités
seraient assis sur un matelas de pièces
d'or or la réalité c'est que les
recettes et les dépenses s'équilibrent
il n'y a donc pas de gras les comptes
2021 ne sont bons que par rapport à 2020
ou les collectivités on le sait on subit
la crise sanitaire si l'on compare ces
chiffres à ceux de 2019 les dépenses
d'équipements des communes sont en recul
de 12,5%. et sur les fonds de roulement
il y a des excédents d'un an et demi car
en 2020 les communes intercommunalités
départements et régions n'ont pas pu
engager l'ensemble des investissements
votés avant la crise une stabilité des
dotations générera au plan
macroéconomique un effet réceptionniste
rappelons que les collectivités sont un
levier économique essentiel pour les
territoires sachant qu'elle réalise
encore plus de 70% de l'investissement
public 70% de l'investissement public 8%
de la dette publique 0% du déficit
public quel bilan magnifique qui dit
mieux monsieur le ministre après la
crise sanitaire qui a coûté près de 7
milliards aux collectivités celle-ci
font désormais face à l'explosion du
prix des matières premières des denrées
alimentaires et de l'énergie certaines
d'entre elles voient leurs dépenses
énergie bondir de façon parfois
vertigineuse jusqu'à 600% dans certains
cas les mers s'inquiètent de savoir si
il ou elles pourront faire face à ses
factures et quand les factures seront
acquittées quel sera le niveau de leur
excédent constaté l'an prochain pour
engager les investissements nécessaires
au développement de leur commune au
service de leur population il
conviendrait tout d'abord de permettre
collectivités d'absorber le choc
énergétique les quelques annonces de ces
dernières semaines il suffiront pas à
l'évidence ne seront pas de nature à
rassurer les élus locaux seule une
indexation des DGF sur l'inflation et le
retour au tarif réglementé devant de
l'énergie à l'ensemble des collectivités
seraient des signaux forts et rassurant
les services publics de proximité
doivent être confortés le service public
c'est le patrimoine de ceux qui n'en ont
pas les affaiblir aura comme conséquence
d'aggraver les fractures géographiques
et sociales et donc en fin de compte
pour être amplifier la crise civique
voire politique que nous traversons
enfin pour conclure je voudrais évoquer
votre méthode nous contestons au fond
les choix régressifs de ce PLF 2023 et
nous en contestons tout autant la forme
dans une interview à la gazette.fr
monsieur le ministre en date du 26
décembre dernier pardon
vous évoquiez les contrats de confiance
que vous souhaitez mettre en place avec
les collectivités et en évoquant la
maîtrise de leurs dépenses je vais vous
citer vous avez eu ces mots
si jamais les collectivités et des
strates ne font pas l'effort de
maîtriser la hausse de leurs dépenses de
fonctionnement il pourra y avoir une
incitation jusque-là tout va bien la
première année ce sera l'absence d'accès
à toutes dotation de l'État vieillessel
DETR fond vert pour les collectivités
n'ayant pas respecté l'objectif au sein
d'une catégorie qui ne l'a pas atteint
non plus ensuite qui manifestement il
n'y a vraiment pas de volonté de
s'inscrire dans cette trajectoire alors
que les autres collectivités le font ils
pourraient y avoir des reprises fin de
citations n'est-ce pas là une atteinte à
l'article 72 de la Constitution
consacrant le principe de libre
administration des collectivités vous
prenez monsieur le ministre en risque
économique et politique considérable à
corps se fait ainsi les administrations
publiques et les collectivités elles
sont les unes et les autres une réponse
concrète quotidienne à la fracture
sociale qui s'aggravent sans cesse dans
notre pays votre budget ne prend pas en
compte l'état réel de notre société nous
ne pourrons dès lors que le rejeter
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent à Madame Sylvie vermeiller
sénatrice du groupe de l'Union centriste
vous avez 6 minutes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général
le groupe Union centriste d'abord de ce
projet de loi de finances pour 2023 avec
le même esprit que lors des précédents
textes financiers rigueur budgétaire et
recherche du plus faible déficit
possible
avec Monsieur le Ministre le maire nous
sommes à l'Europe avec vous monsieur le
ministre Attal nous voulons éviter le
dérapage budgétaire pour cela nous
proposons une trajectoire différente de
la vôtre en recette et en dépense mes
collègues compléteront mon intervention
je vais pour ma part aborder les
recettes il manque des recettes dans ce
PLF 2023 il manque une contribution
exceptionnelle générale sur les
bénéfices il manque la CVAE monsieur le
ministre pas plus que vous nous n'avons
envie de prélever des impôts pas plus
que vous nous n'imaginons freiner
l'allant de nos fleurons du CAC 40 mais
bien entendu nous anticipons les
milliards de dépenses exceptionnelles
auxquelles l'État devra consentir pour
protéger nos concitoyens et nos
entreprises des crises à venir
aussi nous devons saisir toutes les
marges de manoeuvre afin de nous
prémunir de déficit irréversibles
monsieur le ministre le maire explique
très bien pourquoi nous devons éviter la
spirale inflationniste et il se dit
inquiet de la situation britannique mais
il se trouve que dès 2023 la France va
devoir emprunter 270 milliards pour
financer sa dette soit des milliards de
plus que l'an passé le taux auquel elle
empruntra ne sera plus négatif mais bon
dira à deux et demi voire 3% pour
l'isoaté à 10 ans ce qui nous entraîne
dans un début de spirale impossible à
contrer dans quelques années
à ce jour la maturité de notre dette
d'environ huit années elle est taux
d'emprunt sans cesse décroissant des
décennies antérieures ont rendu le coût
de nos emprunts dérisoires mais c'est
terminé et nous voyons dès 2023 et des
remboursements d'emprunts qui augmentent
et des taux d'intérêts alarmants voilà
qui nous ordonne de réduire le déficit
public nous partageons l'analyse de
Philipp Plein chef économiste de la
Banque centrale européenne qui craint
l'accumulation des déficits de plus en
plus difficiles à financer ainsi que son
effet inflationniste il est donc
favorable à notre taxation et oui
augmenter le déficit alimente davantage
l'inflation que de prélever l'impôt pour
le redistribuer c'est la première raison
pour laquelle nous proposons une
contribution exceptionnelle sur les
bénéfices élargit à tous les secteurs
d'activité
nous avons révisé notre amendement
d'août dernier en relevant le seuil
d'imposition aux entreprises et allant
réalisant plus de 10 millions de
bénéfices net et nous l'avons calé sur
la taxation européenne nous appliquons
le même taux de 33% au bénéfice 2022
supérieur de 20% à la moyenne des 3
meilleurs résultats nets entre 2018 et
la différence c'est que nous souhaitons
une participation de toutes les
entreprises ayant réalisé des profits
exceptionnels pas seulement les
entreprises énergétiques que vous
ponctionnez sans limite à la faveur du
reversement intégral de leurs bénéfices
via le bouclier tarifaire 29 milliards
et c'est parfait mais pourquoi les
autres secteurs y échappent pourquoi pas
le transport le luxe les laboratoires
les assurances et les banques celles qui
remontent leur taux d'intérêt monsieur
le ministre le maire en août dernier
lors du premier plaire s'opposé à cette
contribution exceptionnelle préférant
que les entreprises fassent elles-mêmes
des efforts en direction du pouvoir
d'achat des Français en ont elle fait
pour la plupart aucun et pour quelques
autres de Timmy geste sans comme une
mesure avec les dividendes qu'elles ont
distribuées non elles n'ont pas écouté
Monsieur le Maire alors nous allons
faire ce qui est juste prélevez une
contribution exceptionnelle sur des
profits exceptionnels pour financer des
dépenses exceptionnelles car l'État ne
peut pas toujours dépenser tout seul
pour tout le monde quand ça va bien en
supprimant les impôts et quand ça va mal
en versant des aides il est normal qu'il
récupère un peu quand certains
s'enrichissent beaucoup exactement comme
le dit Monsieur le Maire nous allons
chercher l'argent là où il est pas
seulement chez les gens du numérique ou
de l'énergie partout car c'est juste
comme les baisses d'impôts précédentes
ont su servir tous les secteurs et nous
nous engageons bien à ce que cette
mesure ne soit pas pérenne mais reste
exceptionnelle second point le report de
la suppression de la CVAE jeudi report
mes nombres de mes collègues veulent
suppression et oui le Sénat et les
collectivités tiennent à cet impôts
tiennent à cela ce lien tangible entre
le PCI et l'entreprise entre le nid et
l'oiseau au PLF 2021 lors de la
suppression de 10 milliards de cette
CVAE j'avais proposé un amendement
préférant la suppression de la C3S un
pot taxant bêtement le chiffre
d'affaires même en cas de bénéfice et il
semble qu'il y a matière à y réfléchir
de nouveau pour l'heure nous estimons ne
pas pouvoir nous permettre de creuser
notre déficit de 4 milliards pour
compenser la suppression de cette année
et d'autant l'an prochain l'État a
besoin d'entreprises fortes et agile
mais il a tout autant besoin de
collectivités fortes et agiles c'est
pourquoi nous souhaitons remettre à plus
tard voir à jamais la suppression de la
CVAE voici donc deux propositions
quelques milliards de recettes
supplémentaires qui ne peuvent que
tenter le ministre des comptes publics
mais peut-être pour nous assez riche je
sais en tout cas que le Sénat le sera
dans ses débats merci merci Père
collègue la parole est à présent à
Madame Esther ben bassin
sénatrice non inscrite pour 5 minutes
chers collègues
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur général monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues dans ce
contexte économique et social
extrêmement tendue nous abordons
aujourd'hui le budget pour l'année à
venir il est certain que ce projet de
loi de finance ne remplit pas sa part du
contrat lorsqu'il repose sur des
projections financières irréalistes
c'est à se confondre et se perd dans un
flot d'estimation de chiffres de
pourcentage que vous seul semblait
comprendre d'autant plus que la
Commission européenne annonce une
récession pour la fin de l'année un
hiver et en hiver particulièrement
difficile pour la zone euro la dette
publique française actuelle dépense les
2900 milliards d'euros
75% du PIB et même si le déficit public
s'est stabiliserait à 5% pour pour 2023
cela n'éviterait pas une augmentation de
la dette publique dans ce semble paysage
économique vous dites vouloir préserver
les ménages de l'inflation tout en
contenant maximum et le déficit public
cette équation s'avère impossible à
réaliser si votre intention est louable
vos actions manquent pourtant de
crédibilité pour la simple et bonne
raison
qu'après une loi visant à protéger le
pouvoir d'achat un PLF de crise un
bouclier tarifaire sur l'énergie les
Français restent fortement lésés par la
hausse des prix à tous les niveaux
tout ce qui n'ont jamais mis les pieds
dans un hypermarché ne connaissent pas
la réalité sociale de la France
d'aujourd'hui ces mots appartiennent à
Annie Ernaux prix Nobel de littérature
monsieur le ministre je vous pose alors
la question avez-vous fait les courses
récemment parce que quand on a une
inflation alimentaire autour de 12%, il
est légitime d'interroger vos habitudes
selon un récent sondage et Lab 85% des
Français estiment ce privé dans leurs
achats bon nombre d'entre eux se
demandent si oui ou non ils pourront se
permettre de prendre des fruits ou de la
viande alors qu'il y a les factures
d'électricité de gaz à payer à la fin du
mois il privilégieront forcément les
produits de première nécessité tout
extra dans le panier de course et
proscrit c'est un calcul de tous les
instants qui finit par hanter quotidien
de nos concitoyens comment se déplacer
en moindre coût comment réussir à
économiser est-ce envisageable de partir
en vacances cet été mettre ou ne pas
mettre le chauffage quitte à avoir froid
pourtant les Français ont répondu
positivement et jouer le jeu de la
sobriété énergétique en modifiant
lentement et progressivement leur
comportement non pas grâce à vos petites
sorties sur l'école roulait ou le wifi
mais grâce à une prise de conscience
collective de leur consommation ne leur
demandez pas plus d'efforts qu'ils ne
peuvent en fournir les choses ne vont
pas aller en s'arrangeant comme vous le
prétendez l'épuisement des énergies
fossiles ainsi que la transition
écologique vont continuer à mettre les
prix de l'énergie sous pression il
faudra alors prendre ses responsabilités
parce que la dette publique comme la
dette éc se creuse d'année en année
nous l'aidons ce fardeau insupportable
aux générations futures la dette
publique ne doit plus être un prétexte
empêchant une réelle transition
écologique dans nos finances si nous
échouons à les solutionner conjointement
les dégâts économiques et humains seront
inévitables malheureusement au regard de
ce que vous nous proposez et de votre
volonté de passer en force PLR qui
manque cruellement de justice sociale et
fiscale vous ne semblez pas mesurer
toute la gravité de la situation
économique des Français et vous actez
pour le moins une véritable rupture de
confiance entre l'exécutive et les
parlementaires je voterai évidemment
contre ce budget je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent au président Jean-Claude Roquier
président du groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez 10 minutes pour ce faire chers
président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la caution des finances
monsieur le rapporteur
on dit parfois que l'assemblée
court pas les bonbons tu fais l'absence
de majorité absolue et du recours quasi
inévitable à la procédure du 49-3 il
semblerait que le véritable chemin de ce
projet doit finance commence aujourd'hui
au Sénat dans notre hémicycle en toute
en tout cas si on a un jugement déposer
qui va record chaque année et dont
beaucoup seront certainement adoptés par
votre santé
que restera-t-il de ces modifications de
la loi
plus que jamais il est difficile de le
prévoir tant que la configuration
actuelle est inédite malgré une majorité
relative le gouvernement dispose
toujours des marges manœuvres
importantes que les confères la
Constitution le 49-3 bien sûr mais aussi
un pouvoir d'amendement élargi le
monopole de la capacité aniariser les
pensées et nous en prive pas au-delà du
cas d'institutionnel il y a surtout à
disproportion des moyens humains et
techniques de l'exécutif bien supérieur
à ceux du Parlement malgré une volonté
et une détermination sans faille de
l'autre côté
ces budget 2023 est aussi le premier que
nous examinons sous la nouvelle
configuration établie par la loi
organique du 28 décembre 2021 donc nous
avons eu une première expérience le mois
dernier avec le nouveau débat annuel sur
les finances locales alors ici il était
même question d'un projet de loi
spécifique au finance des collectivités
locales à l'extérieur c'est pour la sécu
peut-être un jour la durée des débats
correspondra-t-elle ainsi plus
fidèlement au grand volume budgétaire le
budget de la Sécurité sociale devant
celui de l'État et le budget de
l'enseignement scolaire devant le
Sénégalais après des années très
marquées par les conséquences de
l'épidémie du covid-19 et on rattrapage
économique important depuis un an et
demi l'inflation est repartie nettement
à la hausse avec une accélération depuis
cette année liée notamment au conflits
Russo ukrainien mais pas seulement
dans ce contexte les perspectives de
croissance en 2023 apparaissent quelque
peu incertaine alors que les pays
voisins sont d'ores et déjà rentrés à
récession
l'article limitaire du PLF 2023 présente
comme chaque année les prévisions de
sols structurelles et le solde effective
de l'ensemble de la migration publique
en 2023 les prévisions d'exécution de
les 22 et l'exécution en 2021 depuis la
modération de la Golf sont aussi
détaillés le niveau d'endettement public
une figurer jusqu'ici que dans les
annexes le taux de prélèvement
obligatoire ou encore les prévisions
parties que la nitration publique
le PLF 2023 post 49.3 prévoit toujours
un déficit public 5% du PIB et également
échangé par rapport au programme de
stabilité et la loi de finance
rectificative pourtant les sources de
révision étaient importantes depuis lors
la croissance réelle serait toujours 1%
contre respectivement de 7% en 2022 au
fond ces hypothèses sont toujours
incertaines le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques lui-même dans son dernier avis
en date
la position qui avait tenu cet été au
moment du premier président de finance
rectificative j'avais maintenant
aux principales mesures du PLF
la réforme phare de la première partie
et bien sûr la suppression sur deux ans
de la contribution à ajouter des
entreprises la CPL la majorité c'est la
toriale en ligne passion longtemps
soutenu une réforme similaire celle
d'attaque professionnelle en partie
remplacée alors par la CVAE et la CS
la tranquillité économique de notre pays
et l'accentue aussi une évolution
durable de nos finances publiques vers
l'usage de plus en plus diversifié des
recettes de la TVA d'abord pour le
financement des régions bientôt
poursuivi département et de façon au
cours du massive de la sécurité sociale
si la question de Sonic son équité est
souvent posée sur l'efficacité
économique on a fait ses preuves en
permettant de rentrer fiscales massives
et encore plus en période de fortes
inflation des prix sans entraîner de
disccorpion économique reste à savoir si
les comptes publics doivent dépendre
aussi fortement de faire ce ressources
ou rester suffisamment diversifiée et
indépendants des aléas de la conjoncture
j'aurais pas été complet ça rappelait
l'impact spécifique sur les budgets des
collectivités locales
le dernier rapport de la Cour des
comptes sur la situation des finances
locales est éclairage en particulier
dans les comparaisons internationales
les finances locales ne représentants en
France que 20% environ de l'espace
public loin derrière lui dépasse de la
sécurité sociale et celle de l'État
c'est ailleurs envoyer européenne vous
n'avez pas des collectivités locales
représentent en moyenne 40% de la
dépense publique il est vrai que la
France n'est pas un État fédéral comme
l'Allemagne ou très décentralisé comme
l'Espagne justement cette répartition
originale
nous ramène la question lancinante des
priorités et des missions depuis neuf
mois après avec le conflit
russo-ocrinien nous avons voté plusieurs
rallonges au budget de la défense dans
la dernière en date au PLF à plus de 1
milliard d'euros
globalement ces dernières années les
budgets régaliens ont connu un certain
retour en grâce cela dit en 2023 tous
les budgets ou presque vont augmenter
en effet d'une part à cause de la nation
d'autre part aussi de la volonté du
gouvernement d'assurer un certain nombre
de missions essentielles même si les
services de la dette a fait son grand
retour depuis cette année avec la
remontée des taux d'emprunt et alors que
notre niveau d'endettement public a
battu des records depuis la crise
sanitaire
il faut dire que l'exécutive n'a pas
mélanger ses efforts avec la politique
je crois qu'il en coûte l'Ottawa qui
n'est pas si facile d'en sortir
maintenant la maîtrise dans l'espace
public et notre responsabilité commune
quoi que ce soit le bord politique ça
qui ça n'est dotations de l'état
politique du président quinquennat
marqué par une grande stabilité la DGF
reste autour de 26-27 milliards d'euros
je salue en particulier la
revalorisation de la dessert à hauteur
de 110 millions d'euros ce qui
contribuera à rattraper le retard
accumulé par rapport à la DSU rien de
suite les piliers sujets de la taxation
de s'y faire profit il faut noter que le
gouvernement en partie répondu la
question avec la manoir retenue en
première partie du PLF sous le
plafonnement des rentes dites infras
marginales
terme comptable pour désigner
effectivement des revenus exceptionnels
liés à un contexte de crise et pour
lesquels l'accord a été prélement congru
en septembre au niveau européen la
fiscalité reste un domaine politique il
n'a pas lieu de le nez après tout les
grandes touristes ont souvent pris leur
source dans des disputes aussi de
l'impôt et de sacristes répartition
pensez à la révolution en particulier et
mon groupe proposera ce titre comme
chaque année l'avant-damment classique
visa élargir l'assiette de l'impôt sur
le revenu dit amendement Joseph caillot
se rappeler historique nous empêche nous
empêche pas d'être emprise avec les
réalités plus contemporaines qu'il
s'agit de l'aménagement du territoire
avec notre expérience d'élus souvent
issue de territoire ruraux ou la
tradition écologique aussi sont bien les
enjeux sans cesse aider en quelconque
dogmatisme
quand cet été le pouvoir d'achat ou pour
le dire de notre façon le niveau de vie
ne concitoyen reste le fil rouge de son
profil droit de finance alors que les
prix des énergies atteignent encore de
nouveau historiquement élevés c'est
encore plus prévoir aisément une
trajectoire d'évolution à cours au moyen
terme nous font un certain nombre de
propositions pour des femmes les
intérêts de la population et de nos
territoires dans ce contexte difficile
imprévisible en conclusion notre groupe
sera d'accord sera d'abord attentif au
détail des débats qui promet de cette
année d'être riche caractérisé par une
grande liberté de vote nous serons
sensibles sort qui sera donné à nos
différents amendements dans leur dans le
respect des positions des uns et des
autres
merci président la parole est à présent
à Madame Christine Lavarde
du groupe les républicains
et chers collègues vous êtes parti pour
18 minutes
[Rires]
mais avec brio nous le savon
merci madame la Présidente alors
Monsieur le Ministre les années se
suivent et se ressemblent je suis obligé
de le dire alors on dit souvent qu'il
existe une permanence de l'État vous
l'illustrez parfaitement le ministre de
l'économie reste le ministre des comptes
publics change mais les orientations et
les critiques qu'on peut faire sur ce
budget demeure et j'aurais même je
reprend même d'ailleurs le plan de mon
intervention de l'année dernière alors
l'année dernière je vous disais un
quinquennat pour rien pour ce qui
concerne la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques j'ai même envie de poser la
question un nouveau quinquennat pour
rien pour la maîtrise des comptes
publics alors en effet ce budget c'est
le premier du second quinquennat alors
il a été présenté comme un budget visant
à protéger les Français face à
l'inflation provoquée par la crise
énergétique et le conflit en Ukraine
d'ailleurs le rapport économique social
est financier au PLF peut se résumer en
une phrase c'est celle que vous avez
utilisé dans la conférence de presse un
pouvoir d'achat préservé grâce aux
mesures du gouvernement alors dans le
détail quand presque toutes les missions
voient leur enveloppe budgétaire
progressé par rapport à la LFI 2022 on a
du mal à dégager à une prior c'est sauf
à dire que tout est pouvoir d'achat
alors pour le gouvernement ce budget il
est responsable à l'Europe ça c'était
peut-être le 26 septembre selon le
ministre Bruno Le Maire très soucieux du
redressement des comptes publics alors
je constate juste quelques chiffres
hausses de la dépense sous le
gouvernement de Nicolas Sarkozy plus
32,7 milliards d'euros avec je vous le
rappelle une crise importante en 2008
sous François Hollande 27 milliards
d'euros sous le premier quinquennat sans
crise sous le premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron plus 118 milliards
d'euros et en 2023 pour cette première
année de Macron 2 et ben nous en sommes
à plus 62 milliards pour les dépenses
courantes hors crise et dans la version
du 26 septembre j'ai pas refait le
calcul depuis avec tous les ajouts qui
continuent alors aucune économie
structurelle n'est réalisée les dépenses
ordinaires continuent de le croître le
déficit va augmenter en 2023 alors même
que nous persistons à penser que votre
prévision de croissance est trop
optimiste ce qui aura une conséquence
négatives sur le déficit alors l'état
protège l'état paie l'état déverse des
milliards financés par le déficit la
dette publique représente quand même
aujourd'hui près de 42000 euros par
français mais ce que le consommateur
gagne aujourd'hui sur son pouvoir
d'achat je veux quand même le dire 52
occurrences de ce terme dans le rapport
social le contribuable devra l'honorer
demain avec la hausse rapide de la
charge de la dette et ce terme-là ce
n'est plus que 9 mentions dans le
rapport social vous voyez un peu le
déséquilibre pourtant cet enjeu ne peut
être passé sous silence de PLF en PLF le
groupe LR n'a cessé d'alerter les
gouvernements successifs sur le risque
de ne pas s'attaquer au mur de la dette
encadre montée des taux nous sommes
désormais je suis dans le regret de le
dire face à ce mur
de négatif en décembre 2021 le taux des
OAT a dépassé les 3% le 21 octobre
dernier de manière inquiétante le PLF
est construit sur une hypothèse de taux
de 2,6% pour 2023 pour mémoire un taux
un point de taux d'intérêt en plus c'est
au bout de 10 ans un coup supplémentaire
de 40 milliards selon les données de la
Banque de France soit en ordre de
grandeur le budget de la défense en 2027
la charge de la dette à elle seule sera
supérieure au premier budget de l'État
l'enseignement scolaire la charge de la
dette est une dépense obligatoire sa
croissance vient donc diminuer d'autant
la capacité de l'État à investir dans
des dépenses d'avenir la recherche
l'éducation la décarbonation il existe
un seul bouclier c'est un terme à la
mode pour protéger de cette hausse la
maîtrise de la dépense publique c'est ce
que nous vous avons proposé dans une
version amendée de la loi programmation
des finances publiques dans votre copie
initiale le lent redressement des
comptes publics repose principalement
sur la sur les collectivités locales
alors je vais bien noter l'avancée du
ministre le maire qui nous a annoncé que
l'été l'État était prêt à prendre sa
part en acceptant lui aussi une baisse
de diminution de sa dépense de 0,5 % il
reste encore à définir la sienne cette
trajectoire notre trajectoire la
trajectoire du Sénat que vous jugez
irresponsable trop contraignante sur les
économies en dépense à réaliser nous
allons vous montrer au cours de la
discussion de ce PLF qu'elle est
atteignable je constate de toute façon
que l'amendement 1662 du gouvernement
portant sur l'article luminaire remet
déjà en cause votre proposition initiale
les taux de prélèvement obligatoire
augmente le ministre le maire il y a
quelques instants ici à rappeler que
notre pays était quand même le pays le
plus prélevé fiscalisé des pays
développés la dépense publique augmente
de 8 milliards elle ne va baissera que
de 1,2% contre 2,6% annoncé dans la loi
de programmation finance publique
l'année dernière je vous fais je vous
faisais remarquer que les discussions à
l'Assemblée nationale c'était fait au
mépris du Parlement en effet le
gouvernement avait déposé 125
amendements au cours de la lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale et ses amendements
ce n'était pas des simples corrections
aux articles liminaires du PLF mais
c'était des ajouts très importants au
dernier moment sans études d'impact je
vous le rappelle 11,8 milliards de
dépenses supplémentaires mais je suis au
regret de vous dire que vous continuez
cette année taxation de la rente infra
marginale bouclier électricité gaz
amortisseur filet de sécurité pour les
collectivités mais des sujets très
sensibles qui nécessitent un travail
important d'expertise
pas le temps pas de données pas de
réponse à nos questions mais j'ai même
envie de penser que le gouvernement lui
aussi légifère un peu à l'aveugle je
reviendrai d'ailleurs sur ces points
pour vous montrer les limites à certains
de vos dispositifs mais mépris aussi dit
Parlement des collectivités à qui vous
faites des fausses annonces tout le
monde ici se gargarise enfin les
ministres du fameux programme 380 ou le
fond vert on fait croire aux
collectivités qu'elles vont d'exposer de
2 milliards d'argent frais pour venir
financer leur dispense de transition
écologique c'est faux mais regardez
simplement il s'agit uniquement d'un
recyclage de crédit qui était porté
antérieurement par le programme 362 il
viendra ses crédits viendront en fait
compléter des politiques déjà portées
par les programmes 113 et 181
mais surtout le retour des contrats de
confiance est une véritable provocation
ma dernière question gouvernement n'a
obtenu aucune réponse sur mes deux
interrogations comment osez-vous et
surtout vous engagez vous à respecter le
vote des deux chambres qui part deux
fois ont rejeté le dispositif pour le
ministre Béchu qui m'a répondu je le
cite cette manière de faire est une
façon de reprovoquer le dialogue enfin
franchement moi je pense que c'est
plutôt une façon de reprovoquer tout
court pour le groupe LR la suppression
définitive des contrats de confiance est
une ligne rouge les collectivités ont su
montrer par le passé qu'elles sont
responsables elles ne représente
aujourd'hui que 9% de la dette publique
sur la période 2018-2021 les économies
qu'elles ont réalisées sont de 11
milliards par rapport au taux
d'anciennes de la loi de programmation
pour 2018-2021
elles le font parce qu'elles doivent
présenter des budgets en équilibre à la
différence de l'État toute hausse non
financée de leur fonctionnement se
traduit immédiatement par une
augmentation de la pression fiscale
mesure un populaire pour des élus
apporter de baffes une corde de rappel
très efficace le Sénat a également
conscience que les collectivités doivent
participer à l'effort collectif de
redressement des comptes publics nous ne
sommes pas revenus sur l'évolution des
concours de l'État aux collectivités
prévues à l'article 13 de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques qui
en ne reconstant vont diminuer au cours
du quinquennat cette mesure à elle seule
représente déjà près des trois quarts de
l'effort sur les dépenses de
fonctionnement exigées par l'odele par
rapport à la trajectoire zéro volume
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle le
groupe les républicains ne soutient pas
une mesure d'indexation de la DGF sur
l'inflation ce serait irresponsable
enfin et comme l'année dernière ce
budget apporte des réponses imparfaites
à des défis importants en premier lieu
je vais parler de la hausse de l'énergie
pour les entreprises la trembler des
prix de l'énergie et son impact pour la
compétitivité sont au cœur de leur
préoccupations le 16 octobre le
président du Medef lançait un signal
d'alarme sur la question et demander au
gouvernement des ajustements sur son
volet date de 10 milliards mais on peut
comprendre les craintes des entreprises
sur les sur les trois milliards inscrits
en 2022 seul 500 millions ont été
consommés à ce jour le mécanisme de
bouclier électricité est flou dans son
application le code de l'énergie parle
de moins de 10 personnes employées
comment doit-on comprendre ce terme
est-ce la nomenclature-état à savoir 10
équivalents temps plein ce qui
laisserait à penser qu'on peut avoir 12
personnes employées ou est-ce au stand
strict 12 personnes dans les effectifs
cette question est vrai pour les
entreprises elle est vraie aussi pour
les collectivités les modalités
d'appliques pratiques d'aplatissons de
l'amortisseur sont renvoyés à des
décrets d'application comment peut-on se
préparer comment peut-on envisager
et puis par ailleurs j'ai l'impression
que le même le gouvernement s'y perd
lui-même parce que je n'ai pas bien
compris pourquoi dans votre amendement
toujours le même le 1600 et des
brouettes vous parlez de l'extension du
bouclier alors que le bouclier quand on
parle de tarifs réglementé je vois pas
comment on peut du jour au lendemain et
je pense que c'est plutôt l'amortisseur
que vous voulez tendre enfin c'est une
parenthèse mais par ailleurs ces
dispositifs qui sont très flous que
personne ne comprend les entreprises
elles font face dans la réalité dans la
vie réelle dans l'économie réelle un
phénomène de déstabilisation de leur
compétitivité relative par rapport à
leur concurrent allemand et américains
administre le maire a lui-même reconnu
tout à l'heure pourquoi le gouvernement
25 milliards d'aide pour ces entreprises
et peut-être plus demain si la
commission valide le bouclier de 200
milliards dans l'attente au mois de
décembre la facture des petites
entreprises sera payée directement par
le gouvernement pourquoi nous n'avons
pas les moyens de faire autant parce que
nous sommes entrés avec des finances
fragilisées dans la crise de la covid
les entreprises les Américaines elle a
le bénéficient d'un prix de
l'électricité 10 fois plus faible que le
prix observé en France elles sont par
ailleurs soutenues par un plan de 370
milliards de dollars de subventions et
de crédit d'impôts et nous le président
de la République a annoncé il y a une
dizaine de jours 10 milliards pour
soutenir la décarbonation mais en fait
c'est 10 milliards c'est uniquement 5
milliards et peut-être demain 5 de plus
si jamais les entreprises respectent
l'objectif qu'il aura été fixé et ses
crédits et figuraient déjà d'ailleurs
dans France 2030 je vous rappelle
l'amendement à 34 milliards de l'année
dernière le plus cher de la Cinquième
République alors face à ce constat à ce
besoin d'une aide directe pour les
entreprises nous rejoignons le
gouvernement sur le besoin de renforcer
leur compétitivité et là écoutez bien
mais c'est le ministre
le groupe les républicains va porter un
amendement sur la CVAE mais très
différent celui du gouvernement parce
que nous rejoignons toutes les critiques
qui ont été exposées par le rapporteur
général et toutes les raisons pour
lequel la commission des finances a
refusé la disposition que vous portez à
l'article 5 à savoir une suppression de
la CVAE avec un compensant une
compensation de TVA parce qu'aujourd'hui
tout est flou sur les sur la manière
dont les collectivités seront compensées
tout est flou sur le maintien d'un lien
réel entre le dynamisme économique des
territoires et la compensation qui
traversait par l'État et ça nous le
refusons et je le redis ici pour que ce
soit bien clair non nous nous allons
porter un amendement pour demander
effectivement un dégrèvement de CVAE en
2023 à hauteur de 50% de manière à ce
que les entreprises soient certaines de
bénéficier d'une aide de 4 milliards
qui sera beaucoup plus efficace en tout
cas elle sera sûre par rapport à tous
les dispositifs d'énergie sur lequel on
s'interroge voilà ce que fait cet
amendement et surtout je tiens à le
redire il ne change rien pour les
collectivités en 2023 elles auront une
CVAE équivalente est-ce qu'elles
auraient perçu en l'absence de réformes
telles que proposée par leur apporteur
général enfin tel que proposer par votre
gourmand et tel que le fait notre
amendement elles auront également des
recettes de CVAE
identiques en 2024 ce n'est qu'à partir
de 2025 quand nous aurons eu le temps de
préparer tous ensemble une réforme de
suppression de la CVAE en associant
vraiment les collectivités qu'à ce
moment-là il se passera quelque chose
sur l'énergie toujours et cette fois-ci
en faisant un lien direct avec les
collectivités je vais vous citer
quelques exemples pour vous montrer
comment vous dispositifs sont faibles la
commune de Digoin en Saône-et-Loire qui
est administrée jusqu'à peu par notre
collecte Fabien jeûner 8000 habitants
elle bénéficie d'un groupement de
commande
sa facture d'énergie va progresser de
441000 euros en 2021 850 000 euros en
2022 puis en 2023 une multiplication par
3 sans amortisseur par 2,7 avec un
amortisseur soit une facture totale
autour de 1,2 millions d'euros et dans
le même département une commune de la
même taille Gueugnon qui elle ne
bénéficie pas d'un groupement de
commandes dans le cadre de son
approvisionnement en gaz verrait sa
facture d'énergie passer de 880000 euros
en 2021 à 2,6 millions d'euros en 2023
un autre exemple une autre commune une
commune de Montagne la commune des
échelles en Savoie qu'administré Cédric
Vial ah les 1300 habitants pour la
commune la hausse des dépenses ça va
être 40,2% 42% et par ailleurs un
certain nombre de ces services sont
gérés par des syndicats qui répercutent
en fait sur la commune via le chapitre
65 les subventions il va bien falloir
prendre en compte ce cas-là
il n'y a rien fait pour cette commune 90
% de sa capacité d'autofinancement va
disparaître dès 2024 un dernier exemple
que je ne peux pas passer sous silence
l'exemple de Boulogne-Billancourt 120
000 habitants le milieu urbain
ah bah vous l'attendiez mais c'est
intéressant aussi les dépenses de cette
commune vont passer de 4,3 millions
d'euros en 2021 à 8,3 millions d'euros
en 2023 et pourtant et pourtant cette
commune elle a déjà fait 17% de baisse
de sa consommation de gaz entre 2018 et
2022 18% de sa consommation
d'électricité sur la même période par
des investissements significatifs et
cette commune aujourd'hui elle n'est
aidée par rien alors trois exemples
parmi les 35000 autres que j'aurais pu
citer qui reflètent d'une part la
diversité de notre organisation
territoriale et la diversité des
manières d'acheter de l'électricité
d'acheter du gaz pour vous dire que
votre dispositif il ne marche pas
l'épargne brute elle s'optimise
l'épargne brut elle est aussi
indispensable pour couvrir les dotations
aux amortissements donc pour avoir de
l'épargne mais c'est vous en êtes
contraint par la nomenclature comptable
l'épargne brute elle peut aussi être
décolorée de la richesse d'une
collectivité le potentiel financier
fiscal il peut être décorrélé des
capacités d'une commune je pense ici à
Aubergenville commune de notre collègue
Sophie prima par ailleurs la date de
référence 2022 vous voyez bien qu'en
fait le choc énergétique il existe
depuis 2021 alors c'est pour ça que nous
nous soutiendrons massivement le
dispositif qui a été proposé par la
Commission des finances qui est beaucoup
plus simple qui permet à toutes les
communes d'être potentiellement
éligibles au filet de sécurité mais
surtout nous vous demandons qu'il y a
une véritable clause de revoyure pour
savoir ce qui va se passer combien de
communes vont être compensées alors nous
vous remercions parce que pour la
première fois nous sommes informés déjà
de ce qui se passe sur le bouclier de
2022 mais il faut faire encore beaucoup
plus et enfin troisième sujet que je
voudrais aborder c'est celui de notre
reconquête de souveraineté il y a eu un
excellent rapport de la commission des
affaires économiques qui montrent que
les problèmes que nous rencontrons
aujourd'hui n'ont jamais été perçus dans
une importance aussi grande et en
parlant de deux exemples je voudrais
commencer par l'agriculture mon collègue
Vincent Segoin malheureusement n'est pas
là cet après-midi mais je suis certaine
qu'il aurait voulu vous dire que nous
imposons aujourd'hui à nos agriculteurs
des lois de surtransposition d'énormes
nouvelles produits photos sanitaires
bien-être amiable qui crée des
contraintes et des charges non
productives par rapport à nos
concurrents nous nous alignons sur le
cours mondial pour préserver le pouvoir
d'achat bilan nous approvision sont les
agriculteurs qui peinent à trouver des
remplaçants et d'année en année nous
imposons des contrôles de plus en plus
importants et contraignant sur les
productions françaises sans rien imposer
d'équivalent aux produits importés juste
pour information 2300 fonctionnaires
effectuent des contrôles dans les
exploitations agricoles quand seulement
300 contrôlent les importations à Rungis
je vous renvoie au rapport de notre
collègue Laurent Duplomb et de son
exemple du sésame nous interdisons les
molécules comme le dit
métaux hâte pour la culture des cerises
et pourtant nos importants des cerises
cultivés avec cette même molécule nous
ne produisons plus des escalopes de
poulet consommer chaque jour dans la
restauration collective parce qu'elles
ne sont pas compétitives si elles ne
sont pas produits dans des élevages
intensifs mais nous en importons de
d'autres pays et je pourrais vous lister
longuement des absurdités de ce même
type sur la tomate le blé et autres
aujourd'hui notre balance excédentaire
agricole ne l'est que grâce aux vins
d'ici 2024 elle ne le sera plus du tout
et je pourrais continuer en vous parlant
de notre industrie comment aujourd'hui
80% des véhicules électriques achetés en
France
peuvent-ils être importés au cours des 9
premiers mois de l'année 2022 les le
bonus attribué pour l'achat de véhicules
produits en France ne reproduisez que
140 millions d'euros soit moins d'un
cinquième du total aujourd'hui nos
impôts servent à financer l'industrie
chinoise pour ne pas la citer comment
peut-on accepter cette perte de
souveraineté comment peut-on accepter de
mettre dans la main dans nos concurrents
géopolitiques une industrie
indispensable pour notre transition
écologique et je pourrais vous dire
encore beaucoup d'autres choses
et oui c'est malheureusement c'est fini
encore des choses à vous dire donc je
reviendrai une prochaine fois il va
falloir vous parler merci
[Rires]
la parole est à présent
à notre collègue Monsieur Emmanuel Capus
sénateur du groupe Les Indépendants
Républiques et territoires pour 5
minutes vous avez moins de temps chers
collègues
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
chaque année au moment d'examiner le
budget nous vérifions les mots de Pierre
Dac
les prévisions sont difficiles surtout
lorsqu'elles concernent l'avenir
depuis deux ans nos prévisions
tournaient autour de la même incertitude
qui se résumait en un mot pandémie il
fallait d'abord protéger le pays contre
le virus puis anticiper une résurgence
du virus enfin relancer l'économie
malgré le virus
aujourd'hui nos prévisions
ignorent le virus il nous aura fallu le
quoiqu’il en coûte mais la victoire est
acquise désormais nos prévisions doivent
composer avec d'autres incertitudes
elles sont plus nombreuses plus
complexes et surtout plus menaçante
ces incertitudes s'appellent l'énergie
l'inflation et la guerre elle surgissent
à l'est ou Poutine s'acharne en Ukraine
et aussi de gipping sans tête dans sa
politique du zéro covid mais les
incertitudes surgissent aussi sur notre
continent l'Union européenne doit de
nouveau prouver que les crises
renforcent la solidarité entre les pays
membres plutôt qu'elles ne la fissure et
les états au premier rang desquels la
France et l'Allemagne doivent montrer
qu'ils respectent les règles communes
pour protéger leurs citoyens et leurs
entreprises
c'est ce que propose le budget que nous
allons examiner le premier axe de
protection concerne donc les citoyens en
prolongeant le bouclier le bouclier
tarifaire en revalorisant le barème de
l'impôt sur le revenu l'état protège
leur pouvoir d'achat le coût pour nos
finances publiques est objectivement
élevé personne ne peut le nier mais le
bénéfice est précieux nous maintenons
ainsi l'ordre des choses en 2023 le
travail continuera de payer et ce malgré
l'inflation ce n'est pas rien
le second axe de protection concerne nos
entreprises
beaucoup pour craint la faillite à cause
du coût de l'énergie
ce budget le rapporte enfin des
dispositifs concrets pour faire face aux
difficultés à court et à moyen terme
outre le bouclier tarifaire pour les
plus petites entreprises les mécanismes
complémentaires protégeront également
les PME et les et je salue cette mesure
monsieur le ministre elle était
nécessaire face aux dangers que
représente la hausse des coûts pour la
réindustrialisation du pays et plus
largement pour la survie de nos
entreprises
certes les entreprises à la différence
des particuliers peuvent en partir et
répercuter la hausse de leur coûts sur
leur prix
mais cela entretient la spirale
inflationniste et ce n'est pas toujours
possible c'est pourquoi il est efficace
d'agir à la racine de l'inflation c'est
à dire sur l'énergie
le dernier axe de protection concerne
les collectivités la revalorisation de
la DGF à hauteur de 320 millions d'euros
la place en hausse net par rapport aux
années précédentes c'est une première
depuis 13 ans et c'est une bonne
nouvelle il faut le dire je crois que ça
n'a pas été dit le texte prévoit
également un filet de sécurité pour les
collectivités concernant les coûts de
l'énergie pour un montant de 1,5
milliards d'euros je tiens à saluer cet
effort supplémentaire qui est le
bienvenu en effet les élus locaux
craignent que le PLF entame les finances
locales leur préoccupations tiennent
surtout d'ailleurs à la suppression
progressive de la CVAE notre groupe a
toujours défendu la baisse des impôts de
production dont la CVAE
c'est un pot pénalise nos entreprises et
donc nos territoires notre préoccupation
majoritaire tient avant tout au
dynamisme de la compensation et à sa
territorialisation plus qu'au calendrier
mes chers vous la récré vous l'aurez
compris notre groupe estime que ce
budget répond à l'urgence de la
situation bien sûr nous proposerons de
l'améliorer ma collègue Vanina
paoligajin
présentera tout à l'heure nos pistes
d'action
pour conclure je veux rappeler que ce
budget reflète nos engagements européens
d'abord parce qu'il nous place sur une
trajectoire de rétablissement des
finances publiques
ensuite parce que les mesures de
protection supplémentaire sont rendus
possibles par une action concertée
le Royaume-Uni nous l'a rappelé à ses
dépens l'union fait la force
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent à notre collègue Monsieur
Georges patient pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez 5
minutes président
E
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues
dans un contexte marqué par l'inflation
et la flambée des prix de l'énergie le
bouclier est tarifaire est maintenu par
le gouvernement pour un coût estimer à
45 milliards d'euros en 2023
au total en 3 ans
100 milliards d'euros auront été
dépensés pour protéger nos compatriotes
de lockswagen et des Outre-mer contre la
flambée des prix et contre le retour de
l'inflation
un effort essentiel pour maintenir notre
économie pour soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat des ménage et pour préserver les
finances des collectivités
j'entends pourtant certains dire que ce
budget est un budget d'austérité
d'autres au contraire dire qu'il faut
veiller plus encore à l'équilibre de nos
finances publiques
dans ce PLF est assumé la première étape
de la trajectoire de retour
sur les trois pourcents de déficit en
mais ce sérieux budgétaire ne fait pas
oublier les priorités qu'il faut
financer
pardon le fond vert permettra de
financer l'adaptation de nos territoires
aux aléas climatiques et viendra
soutenir les travaux de rénovation ou de
modernisation menées par nos
collectivités locales
le dispositif m'a prime rénove sera
prolongée pour un total de 3 milliards
d'euros
c'est un des leviers de notre
indépendance énergétique par le soutien
aux travaux d'isolation et d'audit
énergétique des particuliers
plus d'un million de personnes ont pu en
bénéficier depuis son lancement en 2020
dans deux tiers sont des foyers modestes
et également prioriser l'effort à
l'endroit des collectivités
territoriales
le gouvernement a fait le choix de
relever la dotation globale de
fonctionnement pour la première fois
depuis 13 ans à hauteur de 320 millions
d'euros les dotations de fonctionnement
sont elles stabilisées et les recettes
fiscales dynamiques avec l'amortisseur
annoncé par la première ministre et le
filet de sécurité nous veillerons à ce
que les finances des collectivités
locales soient préservées
j'en viens maintenant aux outre-mer
il est d'autant plus aisé d'en parler
qu'il existe spécifiquement pour les
outre-mer un document singulier le
document de politique transversale qui
reflète l'ensemble des politiques
publiques financées par l'État au plus
près des territoires ultramarins
les autres territoires hexagonaux ne
font pas l'objet d'un tel document
n'est-ce pas la preuve monsieur le
rapporteur général que les outre-mer
peuvent connaître des exceptions des
dérogations des adaptations pour
utiliser le terme constitutionnel
ceci dit les dépenses de l'État en
faveur des Outre-mer
seront d'environ 27 milliards d'euros en
CP
et à 28 milliards d'euros en a eu
depuis 2018 cet effort total a augmenté
de 15,4 % on a eu et de 23,1% CP soit
respectivement 3,6 milliards d'euros en
a eux et 5,4 milliards d'euros en CP
un engagement renforcé indéniable de
l'État au profit des Outre-mer mais
l'exécution demeure contrastée notamment
pour les dépenses d'investissement
un engagement financier qui peine à se
concrétiser sur le terrain pour
reprendre les termes de la Cour des
comptes dans son dernier rapport rédigé
à la demande de la commission des
finances du Sénat la cour demande que
les engagements financiers de l'État
soient mieux suivis tant au niveau
central qu'au niveau local par le
développement d'un appui à l'ingénierie
locale permettant de garantir la bonne
exécution des crédits à louer en effet
malgré les investissements réalisés par
l'État dans les territoires ultramarins
des vides inégalités persistent en
matière de transport d'infrastructures
d'assainissement d'électricité de
télécommunication d'accès à l'eau
ou au logement social les écarts de
niveau de vie structurels entre
loutremer et l'Hexagone persiste
concernant les dépenses fiscales
tout comme pour les crédits budgétaires
on enregistre une hausse notable entre
2018 et 2022 malgré des tentatives de
rationalisation
de ce fait en raison de leur difficile
évaluation elle demeure très contestée
notamment par la Cour des comptes elles
sont cependant un outil complémentaire
indispensable qui ne peut être si
aisément remplacé en raison des risques
être insectes à la objatisation
en résumé concernant les outre-mer des
crédits en hausse constante mais une
soucoupe une sous-consommation à
combattre je conclurai monsieur le pénis
en vous disant que l'adoption de ce
budget nous permettra de limiter la
hausse de la facture des électricité et
de gaz des Français de 120 à seulement
15 % que l'indexation du barème de
l'impôt sur le revenu représente
également pour les ménage une économie
de 6,2 milliards d'euros et que pour les
collectivités locales les forces contrat
également en milliard d'euros et
permettra de passer le pic
inflationniste pour toutes ces raisons
le groupe RDPI soutiendra ce budget en
soudant que la discussion nous permet
d'améliorer et de renforcer sa
dispositif si chers collègues la parole
est à présent à madame Isabelle briquet
sénatrice du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain pour 6 minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général monsieur
ministre mes chers collègues la pauvreté
exclut et la richesse isole
ces mots placés dans la bouche d'un des
personnages de l'écrivain Laurence Durel
résonne aujourd'hui avec une acuité
particulière
le rôle de l'État et de garantir et
d'entretenir le lien social entre chaque
individu de lutter à la fois contre
l'exclusion et contre l'isolement
tout cela est possible grâce à une
fiscalité équilibrée et juste adaptée au
défi de notre société
cette question des recettes fiscales
sera centrale dans les débats des
prochains jours car elle pose les
fondements d'une véritable politique
sociale et solidaire
manifestement nous n'avons pas la même
approche
issus de la loi de programmation des
finances publiques pour 2023 2027 ce
premier budget illustre parfaitement le
positionnement idéologique libéral du
gouvernement dans le droit fil du
quinquennat précédent vous poursuivez
méthodiquement le désarmement fiscal de
notre pays
ces cinq dernières années vous avez déjà
renoncé à 54 milliards de prélèvements
obligatoires 54 milliards qui auraient
pu utilement contribuer à réduire le
déficit public sans avoir à rogner sur
les dépenses publiques vous nous
proposez de poursuivre dans la même voie
entre l'annonce de la suppression de la
tvae et celle de la contribution à
l'audiovisuelle publique ce seront un
minima 54 milliards d'euros auxquels
vous renoncerez
alors que le poids de la dette
s'alourdit est-il raisonnable de se
priver de ainsi de recettes alors que
nous traversons une crise économique
profonde qui va affecter durablement nos
concitoyens
est-il bien raisonnable de renoncer à
certaines politiques publiques votre
choix est clair le redressement des
comptes publics ne pourra passer que par
des réformes structurelles assurant
chômage retraite encadrement des
dépenses de l'État et des collectivités
les inégalités se creusent de plus en
plus
le rapport du Secours Catholique sur un
état de la pauvreté en France sorti
aujourd'hui en un test
alors que les revenus du travail
augmentent peu les revenus du capital
liés aux actifs boursiers immobiliers
explosent
que faites-vous face à ce constat
alarmant qui fragmente de plus en plus
notre société pas grand chose hélas
symbole de l'injustice grandissante qui
frappe nos concitoyens les profits
exceptionnels engrangé par les
entreprises du CAC 40
174 milliards d'euros de bénéfices en
2021 une progression qui n'est pas due
au gain de production ni au dynamisme
économique de 2020 première année de la
crise sanitaire voilà une définition
claire et chiffrée de ce con de ce que
sont les super profits au regard de ces
requins de ces records historiques ces
entreprises supporteraient aisément une
taxation spécifique en ces temps ou
nombre de ménages sont étranglés par
l'inflation
il ne peut y avoir d'un côté ceux à qui
l'on distribué des dividendes et ce à
qui on distribuent des colis
alimentaires
notre société se fracture elle a besoin
de vrais politiques avec des services
publics forts et présents au point du
territoire au plus près des habitants
les collectivités jouent un rôle majeur
en termes de cohésion sociale le moins
que l'on puisse dire et qu'elles ne sont
pas épargnées par ce texte
oubliez la crise des gilets jaunes
oubliez la phase aiguë de la crise
sanitaire aujourd'hui les collectivités
locales sont la variable d'ajustement
des comptes publics
malgré son rejet par l'Assemblée
nationale malgré son rejet par notre
assemblée lors de la discussion du
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques le gouvernement a
réintroduit dans le projet loi de
finances l'encadrement des dépenses de
fonctionnement des collectivités
succédant au pacte de Cahors les pactes
de confiance font à nouveau peser sur
ces dernières la baisse de la dépense
publique qu'en est-il dans ces
conditions de leur libre administration
et surtout de leur autonomie financière
ces pacte vont venir limiter grandement
leur capacité d'investissement or vous
le savez parfaitement celle-ci reste le
premier investisseur public dans notre
pays avec plus des deux tiers de
l'investissement public
fragiliser les collectivités
territoriales c'est fragiliser le tissu
économique et l'emploi local et je ne
suis pas certaine que les PME en proie
elles aussi aux difficultés liées à
l'inflation puis supporter une baisse de
la commande locale
quelle société voulons-nous pour demain
que se passera-t-il si les collectivités
territoriales ne jouent plus le rôle
d'amortisseur social une fois de plus
ce sont les administrés les usagers
notamment les plus modestes qui seront
les premières victimes de vos choix
politiques
je pourrais également parler de la
suppression de la CVAE et de ses
multiples conséquences l'insuffisance
des crédits consacrés aux filets de
sécurité mise en place à l'initiative
des parlementaires à l'été dernier ainsi
que de beaucoup d'autres sujets
largement évoqués par mes collègues
concernant le pouvoir d'achat si les
dispositifs tels que le bouclier
tarifaire sont indispensable pour bon
nombre de Français le gouvernement
privilégie toujours les aides
ponctuelles au détriment de vrais
réformes il est grand temps de
s'attaquer réellement à la lutte contre
la pauvreté contre la précarité contre
l'exclusion en privilégiant le dialogue
et l'écoute avec les partenaires sociaux
le monde associatif sans oublier bien
sûr les députés et les sénateurs
appréhender la maîtrise des comptes
publics sous le seul prisme de la
dépense publique en refusant d'envisager
de nouvelles recettes et pire en
continuant à faire des cadeaux fiscaux
au plus riches n'est pas une bonne
manière de faire à nos yeux je le redis
ce projet de loi de finance s'inscrit
dans la continuité des cinq précédents
il continue d'aggraver les inégalités
sociales de désarmer la puissance
publique et de malmener les
collectivités locales notre vote
s'inscrira donc dans la continuité de
nos précédents votes
chers collègues la parole est à présent
à Monsieur Bernard delcro sénateur du
groupe de l'Union centriste
vous avez six minutes chers collègues
bien et Madame madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
faire des prévisions budgétaires pour
2023 dans un contexte européen et
mondial aussi fragile et incertain
relève évidemment d'un exercice
extrêmement difficile auquel nous devons
malgré tout nous livrer en
responsabilité pour notre groupe ce
premier budget du quinquennat doit
marquer une étape vers deux objectifs
le redressement de nos finances
publiques et je pense que nous
partageons tous cet objectif réduire nos
déficits et contenir notre endettement
mais aussi mais aussi deuxième objectif
consacrer les moyens qui sont
nécessaires pour répondre aux besoins du
pays dans des domaines aussi cruciaux
que la santé l'éducation la justice la
sécurité notre défense ou encore la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
alors ces objectifs sont-ils
conciliables nous pensons que oui que
c'est possible mais pour y parvenir nous
considérons que si nous devons bien
évidemment mieux maîtriser nos dépenses
est une nécessité une coupe drastique et
globale dans les budgets n'est pas la
solution à l'heure ou des besoins
croissants se font jour et concernant
les emplois publics un sujet qui revient
régulièrement
des allègements sont bien sûr possible
dans certains secteurs la démonstration
a d'ailleurs été faite avec la
réorganisation des services de Bercy
notamment grâce aux opportunités
ouvertes par la dématérialisation et le
prélèvement à la source mais ces
allègements doivent avant tout permettre
des glissements vers des secteurs dans
lesquels des moyennes supplémentaires
sont indispensables et je ne suis
personnellement pas favorable à des
coupes à l'aveugle dans nos emplois
publics dans une seule approche
comptable c'est pourquoi pour réduire
notre déficit et contenir notre dette
notre groupe considère que nous devons
aussi agir sur un autre levier
l'accroissement des rentrées fiscales
dans les caisses de l'État un levier à
travers lequel l'État doit d'ailleurs
jouer pleinement son rôle de régulateur
nous ferons donc des propositions
concrètes pour accroître les recettes de
l'État comme les a détaillés Sylvie
vermeiller avec la contribution
exceptionnelle de solidarité sur les
profits le report de la suppression de
la CVAE la suppression de plusieurs
niches fiscales que proposera notre
collègue Michel canvé ou encore une
lutte renforcée contre la fraude fiscale
chère à Nathalie Goulet concernant les
collectivités locales permettez-moi tout
d'abord de rappeler une nouvelle fois le
rôle essentiel qu'elle joue dans tous
les territoires de France pour soutenir
le tissu économique et l'emploi pour
assurer les services au plus proche des
habitants pour garantir la cohésion
sociale pour réussir aussi le pari de la
transition écologique cette réalité doit
guider nos choix et éclairer nos
décisions sur la DGF nous approuvons
l'orientation prise par le gouvernement
d'augmenter les moyens qui lui sont
consacrés en ciblant les les plus
fragiles
mais nous savons bien que derrière les
moyennes souvent mises en avant se
cachent des disparités très fortes aussi
pour mieux tenir compte de cette réalité
nous proposerons de porter la hausse de
la DGF de 320 millions à 500 millions
d'euros
concernant la dotation aux communes pour
la protection de la biodiversité qui
reconnaît enfin le rôle essentiel des
territoires ruraux dans la protection de
l'environnement je veux saluer les
avancées obtenues nous proposerons une
amélioration complémentaire peu coûteuse
mais qui effacerait une inégalité de
traitement
en matière d'investissement le maintien
de l'enveloppe DETR à son niveau actuel
la reconduction de la décile et le
nouveau fond vert doté de 2 milliards
d'euros viennent donc compléter
utilement le soutien aux investissements
des collectivités locales nous proposons
également de réintégrer les dépenses
d'aménagement de terrain dans les
ligibilité au FCTVA de laisser au
territoire le choix de répartir
librement la taxe d'aménagement comme
nous l'avons voté hier en loi de finance
rectificative et de décorer les taux de
certaines taxes locales trois mesures
très attendues par les cellules locaux
et nous regrettons monsieur le
rapporteur général que hier nous ayons
fait le choix de priver les
collectivités de la récupération du
FCTVA pour les aménagements de terrain
je veux enfin évoquer les mesures que
vous proposez afin de protéger les
collectivités les ménages et les
entreprises face à l'explosion du coup
de l'énergie le plafonnement à 15% de la
hausse des tarifs réglementés en faveur
des ménages et des petites collectivités
et l'amortisseur électricité en faveur
des collectivités et des entreprises
nous semblent de dispositifs bien ciblés
et bien calibré nous les soutenons
il en va différemment pour le troisième
outil que vous proposez le fil est
sécuritaire en faveur des collectivités
si l'objectif de se filer de sécurité le
bon ces modalités de mise en oeuvre nous
paraissent trop complexes et par
conséquent son effectivité incertaine
nous vous proposerons donc les redéfinir
à partir de critères simplifiés et
clarifier monsieur le ministre nouvelle
fois notre groupe aborde l'examen de ce
projet de budget de manière positive
avec la volonté de trouver avec le
gouvernement les meilleures solutions
pour notre pays et pour nos territoires
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues à la demande du
ministre nous suspendons quelques
minutes et nous reprenons dans quelques
minutes merci chers collègues
chers collègues la séance et reprise la
parole est à présent monsieur Stéphane
sotarel sénateur du groupe les
républicains et vous avez 10 minutes
chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général du budget mes chers
collègues je vais avoir le sentiment
d'intervenir en premier après cette
interruption donc de pas me répéter
nous voilà donc face à cette adresse ce
budget impossible et pourtant nécessaire
un budget qui doit encore faire face à
l'urgence et qui devrait aussi répondre
à sa fonction première celle de préparer
l'avenir de proposer un CAP en ce sens
il doit s'inscrire dans une trajectoire
celle de la programmation plurielle de
nos finances publiques dont j'espère
notre pays disposera avec le cadre que
le Sénat a retravaillé en responsabilité
dans le contexte particulier du rejet à
l'Assemblée nationale de ce texte nous
avons décidé d'adopter un projet réécrit
qui semble hélas déjà dépasser avec
enfin un effort des administrations
centrales calcu sur celui demandée aux
collectivités territoriales inflation
moins 0,5 pour aboutir à une trajectoire
plus ambitieuse
que vous nous avez dit vouloir désormais
partager et retrouver en 2025 des
niveaux de déficit et de dettes plus
acceptable bien qu'encore élevé si nous
pouvons partager la volonté de mieux
coordonner politique monétaire et
politique budgétaire veillez à un
meilleur partage de la valeur en faveur
du travail renforcer notre indépendance
énergétique protégée de manière ciblée
nos concitoyens nos entreprises à nos
collectivités nous ne pouvons ni
souscrire à des hypothèses
macroéconomiques trop optimistes ni à
l'absence de réformes structurelles qui
limite la crédibilité de l'exercice
comme la rappeler ma collègue Christine
Labarde nous vous proposerons donc
plusieurs voies pour y remédier sans
renoncer à une ambition pour notre pays
en vous proposant 4 milliards
d'économies et sortir enfin du quoi
qu'il en coûte
l'examen des principaux éléments de
l'équilibre ou plutôt du déséquilibre du
PLF 2023 que vous nous présentez mais
monsieur le ministre ne manque un effet
pas d'inquiéter à cet égard un scénario
macroéconomique
incontestablement trop optimiste je l'ai
dit une inflation durable estimée à 5,4
% pour 2023 et peut-être sous-estimé un
niveau de déficit exceptionnellement
élevé 158 milliards en 2023 alors qu'il
n'était que de 67 en 2017 et une
explosion de la dette et de son cou 57
milliards en 2023 la dette son poids son
évolution ses flux comme son stock c'est
fondements qui ne prennent racines que
dans nos dépenses de fonctionnement et
la source majeure des inquiétudes et du
manque de lisibilité qui frappe notre
pays comme la rappeler notre apporteur
général Jean-François Husson
son niveau fixé à 111,2 % du PIB dans le
PLF 2023 et sans doute plus haut encore
va nous contraindre d'emprunter le
montant record de 270 milliards d'euros
sur les marchés financiers 2023 est donc
bien ce rendez-vous le rendez-vous que
nous avions annoncé avec le mur de la
dette sur lequel nous avions déjà alerté
face à ce mur une structure de nos
finances publiques déjà dégradée qui les
rendent confiscatoire et trop souvent
inefficace deux chiffres déjà dégradés
d'ailleurs par rapport au plpfp
44,9% de taux de prélèvement obligatoire
56,9% de taux de dépenses publiques des
mesures plus radicales des choix
tranchés illisibles sont donc
nécessaires vous le savez nous
partageons avec vous la nécessité de
réduire les prélèvements obligatoires
déjà trop élevés dans notre pays au
regard du contexte nous vous proposerons
sans la remettre en cause des
aménagements quant à la suppression de
la CVAE pour garder un lien au
territoire et assurer une dynamique de
la ressource pour les collectivités via
un dégrèvement dans un premier temps
alors que la réindustrialisation de
notre pays est lourdement remise en
cause par la hausse de l'énergie en
Europe la baisse de nos impôts de
production et le pari de baisser les
taux pour voir le rendement s'améliorer
comme on l'a constaté pour l'IS et bien
nécessaire mais cela ne suffira pas pour
ma part je proposerai des amendements
pour engager un réel effort sur la
dépense fiscale et sociale qui pèse près
de 130 milliards d'euros dans notre pays
pour d'une part rendre toute niche
fiscale bornée dans le temps et d'autre
part engager une trajectoire de baisse
de 10% par an de la dépense fiscale de
même je porte l'idée qu'il faut
s'interdire toute baisse de TVA dans les
faits sur les prix et le pouvoir d'achat
est plus aléatoire alors qu'elle prive
l'État est désormais les collectivités
de ressources quant au poste de dépenses
je ne peux m'attarder que sur deux
d'entre eux se liés à la mobilité et
surtout les soutiens accordés aux
collectivités territoriales qui
d'ailleurs ne sont pas une dépense mais
bien d'autres nécessiterait aussi un
développement
en qualité de rapporteur spécial au
transport j'aurai l'occasion de
m'exprimer plus largement lors de
l'examen de cette mission si la
trajectoire de la Lomme est respectée
grâce au plan de relance nous savons ici
et nous l'avons dénoncé avec mon
collègue Hervé Moret dans notre rapport
sur le système ferroviaire français que
nous ne répondons pas aux enjeux qui
sont les nôtres nos infrastructures ont
besoin de 100 milliards d'euros
d'investissement notre matériel roulant
attend encore des moyens de
modernisation et nous vivons dans une
contraction de l'offre qui risque de
s'amplifier alors que nous devrions
susciter la demande pour améliorer notre
trajectoire carbone tout en répondant à
des enjeux de pouvoir d'achat pour tous
je sais nous savons tous que les
réponses ne sont pas simples mais
désormais elles rêvait même une
dimension démocratique avec
l'instauration des ZFE par exemple ou
les usages en territoire périphériques
qui risquent d'exclure nombre de
Français de notre société nous risquons
d'accroître les factures les fractures
pendant et de renforcer la cohorte et
les factures aussi d'ailleurs la cohorte
des dépossédés de tous ceux qui se
sentent exclus du monde qui advient
alors qu'il travaille et constitue une
majorité exclue d'un modèle qu'une élite
bien passante bien pensante veut lui
imposer alors oui aux autres
osons innover pour enfin investir pour
enfin moderniser nos voies ferrées car
bientôt toutes seront concernés mais
aussi certaines routes encore comment
quand on prend je crains que nous n'en
n'ayons plus les moyens grands projets
européens je crains que nos faiblesses
nous le permettent pas vraiment société
de projet pourquoi pas la SNCF nous
promet des retours sur investissement à
trois ans et demi sur certains
investissements majeurs la début de
l'utilisation la sortie de leur nualité
les perspectives offertes à 10 ou 20 ans
avec la mobilisation de fond vert et de
partenariats publics privés doivent
pouvoir nous le permettre alors essayons
essayons vraiment
ce budget confirme aussi que le seul
facteur de déséquilibre est constitué
par le budget de l'État alors que les
collectivités sont à l'équilibre et que
la sécurité sociale s'en rapproche même
si ces perspectives inquiètent d'où mon
dernier point sur les territoires et les
collectivités commençons par rétablir la
confiance nous avons supprimé l'article
23 du projet de loi de programmation
plus rien annuel qui prévoyait un
encadrement des dépenses des
collectivités territoriales alors que
celle-ci n'agrave pas le déficit
l'attachement aux libertés locales n'est
pas compatible avec un encadrement de
leurs dépenses mais appelle plutôt à une
lisibilité autour d'un pacte de
confiance plurielle le système de
contrôle et de sanctions proposées n'est
pas acceptable comment pouvez-vous le
réintroduire dans ce PLF au détour du
49.3 à l'Assemblée avec son avatar de
l'article 40 quater
la première urgence est donc de revenir
sur cette disposition si vous voulez
confirmer que l'exécutif est ouvert aux
propositions du Sénat comme le
gouvernement le déclare et faire
confiance aux collectivités qui ont
montré qu'elles années tes dignes
s'agissant des dépenses des
collectivités et sans entrer dans les
chiffres établissant quelques vérités
les collectivités territoriales ne sont
pas un problème pour les comptes de la
Nation les dotations ne sont pas des
subventions de l'État elles ne sont pas
un don mais un du car elles sont la
contrepartie à l'Europe près constant
soit de la nationalisation d'une
fiscalité jusqu'à lors locale soit d'un
transfert de charge relevant de l'État
vers les collectivités c'est même notre
principe constitutionnel au fil des
années plus l’état a prélevé dans les
finances locales sur ces pour ses
besoins plus son propre déficit s'est
accentué depuis 2014 46 milliards
d'euros ont ainsi été piochés dans les
budgets des collectivités par un État
dont le déficit est reparti à la hausse
depuis 2018 soit avant le covid ce qui
est d'autant plus que les excédents de
fonctionnement des collectivités
territoriales améliorent la présentation
à Bruxelles des comptes publics de
l'État mais au-delà des difficultés des
difficultés rencontrées à l'échelle
micro par chaque commune la
désindexation des dotations générales au
plan macroéconomique un effet
réceptionniste l'hypothèse de croissance
en 2023 retenue par le gouvernement et
de 1%, ce chiffre faible est déjà
optimiste sera revu à la baisse si les
collectivités territoriales qui ne
représentent en France que 19% du total
de la dépense publique mais assure 70%
de l'investissement public se voit privé
de leur capacité d'autofinancement à
raison de l'effet ciseaux de la
dynamique de la dynamique pardon des
charges qu'elles subissent car c'est
bien là le véritable sujet celui de
l'autofinancement des collectivités ne
pas garantir un neuroconstant les
recettes supposées appartenir aux
collectivités via le produit du résidu
de fiscalité locale et surtout des
dotations qui s'y sont substituées
remettra en cause leurs vertus
contracycliques de soutien à l'activité
en période de difficulté et donc général
un effet réceptionniste nous avions
défendu lors des dialogues de Bercy le
maintien de la dynamique des bases
fiscales sur la fiscalité locale c'est
une mesure importante de stabilité des
règles et de respect de l'autonomie je
me réjouis qu'à ce stade nous soyons
entendus côté dépense les collectivités
devraient pouvoir bénéficier de
dispositifs de soutien renforcé face au
prix de l'énergie comme nous le
demandons depuis des semaines dans
l'attente d'une révision de l'échelle
européenne du prix de référence de
l'électricité j'insiste sur ce point qui
me semble crucial car il nous
exonérerait de bien des efforts
budgétaires et je vous interroge pour
savoir si le gouvernement pense enfin
pouvoir obtenir de la part de l'Europe
le régime
ibérique Bruno Le Maire nous a dit tout
à l'heure que l'Europe doit faire bloc
il semble pourtant hélas que ne soit pas
aujourd'hui tout à fait le cas la
discussion qui va s'engager de manière
constructive et responsable dans cette
hémicycle notre groupe y participera
activement nous allons pouvoir vérifier
dans les jours qui viennent si vous
voulez donner lisibilité et efficacité à
notre dépense publique pour renouer avec
la confiance et l'espérance je vous
remercie
collègue
ils ont à Madame
va cher collègue vous avez 5 minutes
pour vous exprimer
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
l'ère du quoi qu'il en coûte ses refermé
avec la remontée des taux la hausse des
coups de l'énergie l'inflation qui
s'installe dans l'économie mondialisée
nous ne pouvons plus dépenser sans
compter mais nous devons compter ce que
nous dépensons
c'est ce que vous avez appelé monsieur
le ministre des comptes publics le
combien ça coûte je salue ce changement
de braquet qui tire les conséquences
d'une situation nouvelle il faut prendre
les choses comme elles sont car on ne
fait pas de politique autrement que sur
des réalités général de Gaulle nous y
voilà
je ne reviendrai pas sur le contexte
global de ce budget mon excellent
collègue Emmanuel Capu a déjà expliqué
pourquoi notre groupe soutien le texte
du Gouvernement je me contenterai de
présenter quelques pistes d'action
complémentaires pour embrayer après le
combien ça coûte je propose de passer à
la vitesse de croisière du mieux qu'il
en coûte désormais un budget constant
nous devons impérativement améliorer
l'efficacité des dépenses publiques nos
propositions répondent à cette logique
je vous en cite trois qui illustrent
l'esprit de ce projet de loi de finance
stimuler l'innovation la
réindustrialisation des territoires et
le produire en France
accélérer la transition écologique et
protéger la biodiversité
renforcer notre souveraineté culturelle
la réindustriels de la
réindustrialisation pardon du pays
passera à la fois par les territoires et
par l'innovation si nous voulons éviter
notre déclassement en pays de
sous-traitance il faut ne pas oublier
Lisbonne et mourir nous devons investir
massivement dans la recherche et dans
l'innovation pour que nos chercheurs et
entrepreneurs trouvent et développent
les solutions adressant les défis du
siècle c'est aussi vital monsieur le
ministre pour notre balance commerciale
c'est tout le sens de la mission
d'information que notre groupe avait
lancé il y a un an et que j'ai eu
l'honneur de rapporter l'objectif de
cette mission n'était pas d'orner les
rayonnages de vos bibliothèques
messieurs les ministres d'un rapport
supplémentaire s'agissait de trouver des
solutions efficaces opérationnelles pour
contribuer à changer la donne l'ensemble
de nos propositions se divise en trois
tiers un tiers pour le gouvernement un
tiers pour le secteur privé un tiers
pour le Parlement avec les membres de la
mission dont sont président sarrasin
nous prenons notre part et proposons des
mesures concrètes
la plus importante en termes de signal
positif concerne le crédit d'impôt
recherche nous proposons un enveloppe
budgétaire constante de reventiler une
part réduite de l'enveloppe et ce au
bénéfice des PME et ETI en supprimant le
taux de 5 % au-dessus du seuil de 100
millions d'euros de dépenses de R&D je
vous rappelle qu'un euro de crédit
d'impôt recherche anti entraîne un euro
40 de dépenses de recherche privée dans
une PME versus 40 centimes dans un grand
groupe dans un cas c'est une dépense
utile créatrice de richesse
supplémentaire dans l'autre elle manque
un peu vous en conviendrez d'efficacité
télé monsieur le ministre notre
conception du mieux qu'il en coûte je
sais que le gouvernement ne souhaite pas
toucher à ce dispositif qui contribue à
l'attractivité du pays et j'en conviens
mais alors que nos concitoyens davantage
de justice fiscale l'argent public ne
doit pas servir à faire venir pour de
mauvaises raisons des entreprises
étrangères nous préférons qu'il finance
directement l'innovation des PME PMI et
de nos territoires
pour accélérer dans un second temps la
transition écologique nous voulons
ouvrir le bénéfice du mécénat aux
particuliers et entreprises qui
concentre des dons aux communes
forestières pour aménager des accès
replanter des essences résilientes etc
après les mégafeux qui ont ravagé nos
forêts cet été nous souhaitons permettre
aux Français d'agir de façon locale et
concrète pour préserver nos forêts ce
dispositif a je vous le rappelle a été
adopté par notre commission des finances
grâce au travail conduit par mon
collègue Vincent Segoin j'espère que
nous pourrons l'intégrer au budget afin
de rendre opérationnel dès le 1er
janvier 2023 ce dispositif est préparé
l'avenir enfin pour renforcer notre
souveraineté culturelle nous proposons
également de mobiliser davantage de
capitaux privés c'est essentiel car le
monde de la culture a été fortement
frappé par la pandémie dans le même
temps l'enco globale sur les livrets des
pannes réglementées dont le livret A le
ldds à dépassé les 500 milliards d'euros
ces 5 fois le montant total du plan de
relance monsieur le ministre c'est
considérable c'est pourquoi nous
proposons de créer un nouveau livret
d'épargne réglementé dénommé le livret C
c'est comme culture
pour mobiliser des capitaux privés pour
le financement des lieux culturels
notamment patrimoniaux et la création
d'autres propositions dont celle de mon
excellente collègue Colette Milo en
faveur de l'art numérique iront dans le
même sens j'espère que ces propositions
pourront enrichir le texte du
Gouvernement en l'orientant monsieur le
ministre sur la voie du mieux qu'il en
coûte je vous remercie merci beaucoup
chers collègues la parole est à présent
Monsieur Patrice Joly c'est netteur du
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain vous avez 6 minutes chers
collègues
monsieur le madame pardon la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur président
de la commission divinente bien sûr
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
c'est obligé de 1000 23 se tient dans
des conditions particulières qui ont été
rappelés avant moi crise énergétique
inflation perte de pouvoir d'achat on
observe une augmentation de l'énergie
importante de même que celle des
produits alimentaires et qui pèsent plus
particulièrement sur les ménages compte
tenu de leur structure de dépenses c'est
pourquoi ce budget nous oblige encore
plus fortement cette année à être à
l'écoute de nos concitoyens de nos
collectivités de nos entreprises et de
tous les acteurs économiques dont les
voix se font de plus en plus criante
pour demander
que l'État redevienne davantage
opérateurs en fournissant des services
publics en intervenant directement dans
la vie économique française et la
production de biens et de services que
l'État redevienne davantage régulateur
en
garantissant pardon le fonctionnement du
système complexe que notre société que
l'État redevienne davantage régalien
pour protéger et garantir l'ordre public
mais aussi de manière plus générale pour
assurer la sécurité dans ces différents
domaines que l'État redevienne plus fort
pour lutter contre les inégalités
sociales et rétablir la justice fiscale
en définitive que l'État redevienne
pleinement en phase avec les besoins de
nos concitoyens
mais comment rassurer nos concitoyens
alors même que nous venons tout juste
d'achever les débats autour d'une loi de
programmation des finances publiques peu
ambitieuses le gouvernement a renoncé à
faire payer celles et ceux qui
bénéficient aujourd'hui de la crise il a
renoncé à donner à l'état les lents
nécessaires pour venir en aide au
territoire et aux populations les plus
fragiles dont le nombre est grandissant
comme le rapporte l'état de la pauvreté
en France établit par le Secours
Catholique comment ne pas être inquiet
pour nous concitoyens en examinant ce
budget 2023 vous continuez à vouloir
ramener le déficit public à moins de 3%
d'ici 2027 au nom de la maîtrise de la
dépense publique si vous n'y aviez pas
fait si vous n'aviez pas fait ce choix
de réduire de 54 milliards les
prélèvements obligatoires notre déficit
aurait pu être maîtrisé sans renier sur
les dépenses publiques visiblement il ne
suffit pas de se taux proclamer bon
gestionnaire pour
au nom de la maîtrise de la dépense
publique monsieur le ministre sont des
cataclysmes qui se profilent toujours
moins de services publics alors que les
besoins s'en font plus que jamais sentir
toujours moins de justice sociale et
fiscale alors que notre société croule
sous les inégalités toujours moins de
réponses à la crise écologique alors que
l'humanité est menacée toujours plus de
misère plus de crises dans les hôpitaux
et les écoles plus de file d'attente à
la pompe et à l'aide alimentaire
monsieur du ministre de nombreux points
nous interroge tout d'abord quelle
protection apportez-vous à nos habitants
une étude récente de FC Que Choisir à
montrer l'ampleur de la crise sanitaire
dans les territoires et plus
particulièrement dans les territoires
ruraux il est devenu particulièrement
difficile voir impossible de consulter
un généraliste ou des spécialistes de
son côté l'hôpital s'effondre sous les
coups de l'austérité budgétaire les
démissions se multiplient reflétant les
inspirations des personnels soignants
à titre d'exemple dans mon département
la Nièvre les élus et les habitants
assistes contre leur gré et malgré leur
nombreuses protestations aux fermetures
des services dans différents
établissements puis on met toujours des
services de médecine fermeture des lits
de long séjour fermeture des maternités
des centres périnato faute de sage-femme
alors il faut investir fortement pour
améliorer les conditions de travail
augmenter les salaires du secteur de la
santé permettre le recrutement de
personnel pour que plus jamais un être
humain habitant ce pays ne puisse mourir
dans un couloir sur un brancard faute de
soin ou dans l'attente d'être transporté
à l'hôpital ensuite quel service public
souhaitez-vous encore maintenir sur nos
territoires aux yeux du gouvernement
c'est toujours l'objectif obsessionnel
de maîtrise des budgétaires qui est
prioritaires vous considérez que le
service public comme une dépense
uniquement sans jamais vous interroger
sur ce que coûte leur absence ni sur ce
qu'ils peuvent apporter en termes de
cohésion sociale d'accès aux droits
d'emploi de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique mais également
de développement économique et de
création de valeur ajoutée enfin quel
secours donnez-vous à nos collectivités
ces dernières ne peuvent se satisfaire
de leur dotation actuelle d'autant
qu'elle subissent depuis plusieurs mois
une présentation sans précédent de leur
charge de fonctionnement du fait de la
crise inflationniste expliquez-nous
monsieur le ministre malgré les mesures
que vous proposez comment peuvent-elles
aujourd'hui entretenir les écoles les
collèges les lycées les Plessis les
piscines municipales et j'en passe tout
en s'adaptant bouleversement
irréversible du dérèglement climatique
alors que leurs dépenses devront évoluer
un rythme de 0,5 points au taux de
l'inflation
votre budget promet une cure d'austérité
que vous souhaitez voir supporter par
les collectivités locales qui deviennent
les grandes perdants de ce projet les
associations d'élus sont toutes unanimes
les mesures retenues par le gouvernement
direction des collectivités locales ne
sont pas à la hauteur des défis auxquels
doit faire face mes chers collègues j'ai
envie de faire mienne la parole de
Victor Hugo je ne suis pas de ceux qui
croient qu'on peut supprimer la
souffrance en ce monde mais je suis de
ceux qui affirment qu'on peut détruire
la misère face à un tel niveau d'urgence
il est temps de renverser votre logique
et de repenser le budget de la France en
partant des besoins de la population et
de la planète pour aller ensuite
chercher les moyens essentiels ce qui
suppose au préalable d'imposer un
partage des richesses une plus grande
participation du capital et une Rupe
distribution des revenus au sens large
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
et enfin la parole est à Monsieur le
Kester monsieur Vincent capot canelas au
nom du groupe Union centriste vous avez
5 minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
l'année dernière nous avions sans doute
trop rapidement écourté l'examen du PLF
à l'issue de la première partie c'était
en tout cas un regret les années passent
mais elle ne se ressemblent pas
forcément car cette année c'est autour
de l'Assemblée nationale de voir les
débats interrompus pour autant les
sénateurs centrist salut
venant de différents groupes
d'opposition d'ailleurs le maintien d'un
certain nombre de dispositifs de bon
sens je pense tout particulièrement à la
hausse du plafond défiscalisé des
tickets restaurants à la prolongation du
taux réduit de TVA à 5 et demi pour les
produits Léo covid ou encore à la mise
en place d'un bouclier protégeant les
collectivités de l'envolée des prix
d'énergie encore le dispositif en
question reste-t-il à améliorer
c'est pourquoi notre groupe proposera un
bouclier énergétique plus performant en
faveur des collectivités définis à
partir de critères simples et claires
notre rapporteur général a livré une
proposition
utile qui mérite débat et évidemment
enrichissement
bien que s'appuyant sur les hypothèses
optimistes le gouvernement prévoit
dois-je dire après avoir entendu
monsieur le misé l'Économie des Finances
prévoyez pour 2023 une simple stabilité
du déficit effectif une amélioration au
mieux limité du sol de structurel et une
quasi stabilité du ratio de la dette or
le redressement des finances publiques
s'annonce un silent et très incertain
nous dit le Conseil le gouvernement
a-t-il bien saisi l'urgence de retrouver
la maîtrise de nos finances publiques
quand j'entends tout à l'heure le
ministre économie des finances je suis
porté à le croire
mais nous voudrons des preuves dans la
discussion des amendements et le groupe
UC a toujours porté l'exigence de
redressement des finances publiques
encore faut-il pour qu'il y ait un corps
au sein de la majorité c'est latoriale
que le compromis soit clair et partagé
car la soutabilité de notre budget nous
appelle à une plus grande vigilance les
deux dernières années ont démontré
l'exigence de retour à des niveaux de
dettes raisonnable garantissant à la
France de disposer de marge de manœuvre
suffisantes c'est nécessaire pour
affronter de nouveaux chocs
macroéconomiques ou financiers et faire
face à des besoins importants
d'investissement public cet effort
collectif repose sur la maîtrise de la
dépense coupée à la recherche d'une plus
grande efficacité de celle-ci les
crédits des ministères augmentent de 24
milliards la charge de la dette du toit
les 60 milliards et les dépenses
d'assurance maladie de London hors des
points s'il y a la crise sanitaire sont
en augmentation et toujours supérieure à
celle d'avant crise
en effet une fois la bête est dépenses
exceptionnelles neutralisées la dépense
publique est prévue en hausse en volume
de
0,7%. ces chiffres seront nécessairement
au centre de nos discussions
les dépenses courantes sont encore
augmenter de 60 de milliards d'euros et
11000 fonctionnaires vont être recrutés
au moment même où les taux d'intérêt
remontent voire dépasse les deux et demi
pour cent la France va emprunter 270
milliards d'euros sur les marchés un
record dont nous serions sans doute
collectivement passé
prenons ces responsabilités pour
apporter des solutions concrètes assez
hautes automates le groupe UC s'est
accordé pour déposer plusieurs
amendements lors de ce PLF 2023
concurrent au redressement de nos
finances publiques dès lors et avec la
conscience bien sûr ça a été rapide tout
à l'heure par Monsieur le Ministre quand
cette période d'incertitude et de risque
nous devons éviter d'ajouter une absence
de discussion budgétaire à la situation
actuelle nous serons force de
proposition
nous aurons un sujet de discussion
l'instauration d'une contribution
exceptionnelle de solidarité sur les
super profits
étendu à l'ensemble des secteurs
d'activités et ciblant les plus grands
entreprises la solidarité et l'affaire
de tous la cohésion passe aussi par des
symboles
opposés à des baisse d'impôts non
financés ne proposeront par ailleurs le
report de la suppression de la CVAE
mesure perçu de Suroit comme un nième
coup porté à l'autonomie financière des
collectivités la position de la
Commission des finances sur ce point
peut être un point d'atterrissage
revenir dessus serait en soi plus
problématique
le financement des collectivités est
devenue incompréhensible pour une grande
majorité ces dernières le calcul de la
DGF en ami exemple nous saluons
l'augmentation de celle-ci de 320
millions d'euros et la création d'un
fond vert destiné aux collectivités
locales à l'heure où cette hémicycle va
connaître de longs débat le groupe UC
souhaite des échanges équilibrés
intelligibles et respectueux à l'image
du travail fourni au Sénat et qui va
mettre un dialogue entre les différents
groupes nous espérons que les
propositions faites par le Sénat et
notamment les sénateurs centrist seront
suscités la décision du plus grand
nombre et nous permettre d'adopter un
budget tel que modifié par le Sénat
merci
merci Monsieur le Kuster la parole est à
présent au ministre délégué chargé des
comptes publics monsieur Gabriel Attal
merci madame la Présidente je vous
remercie l'ensemble des oratrices des
orateurs qui se sont exprimés nous
allons avoir des débats nombreux riches
nourris dansent dans les jours et les
semaines qui viennent et donc je ne
serai pas trop long dans ma réponse à
cette discussion générale puisque nous
aurons l'occasion de revenir sur
beaucoup des sujets qui ont été évoqués
peut-être reprendre les interventions
les unes après les autres en espérant
que je n'oublierai personne monsieur
broyer vous avez abordé un certain
nombre de sujets qui me tiennent
évidemment aussi à coeur vous avez parlé
notamment des questions culturelles de
notre politique culturelle et on
pourrait parler longuement de ce que
nous faisons avec le Pass Culture ou
pour la rénovation du patrimoine dans
notre pays je pense que je m'arrêterai
dans votre propos sur la question de
l'éducation qui est évidemment centrale
fondamental et moi je veux redire
revendiquer à nouveau le caractère
inédit dans son ampleur de la hausse du
le budget du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale l'an prochain je me souviens
que quand François Hollande a été élu en
2012 il a lancé un grand plan de
recrutement de réarmement c'était
affirmé à l'époque pour l'éducation
nationale ce plan s'est traduit pour le
PLF 2013 à l'époque par un rehaussement
du budget du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale d'un milliard 700 millions
d'euros le budget du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale l'an prochain
augmente de 3 milliards 700 millions
d'euros pour des actions très concrètes
évidemment au service de des méthodes
pédagogiques de nos enseignants pour la
revalorisation nos enseignants que j'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure une
revalorisation de 10% pour aussi faire
en sorte que c'est notre engagement
qu'aucun d'enseignant ne démarre sa
carrière en dessous de 2000 euros nets
par mois mais aussi pour poursuivre le
regroupement le recrutement
d'accompagnants pour les élèves en
situation de handicap les aesh nous en
recruterons 4000 l'an prochain et à la
suite d'un amendement porté dans le PLF
à l'Assemblée nationale par la majorité
présidentielle les aesh bénéficieront
également de la revalorisation salariale
de 10% c'est un amendement que nous
avons retenu dans le texte réputé adopté
à l'Assemblée nationale monsieur
rofrisch de vous remercier pour votre
intervention et notamment pour avoir
souligné là aussi la hausse importante
dont bénéficie le ministère des
Outre-mer avec près de 3 milliards
d'euros de budget les outre-mer
connaissent une hausse à nouveau
importante pour l'année prochaine
c'était déjà le cas dans le texte
initial du PLF c'est par ailleurs
enrichi par des amendements qui ont été
retenus dans la discussion à l'Assemblée
nationale on peut penser à l'amendement
qui abonde de 30 millions d'euros les
corums les villes qui sont signataires
d'un contrat Corum ou l'aide de 10
millions d'euros de crédit budgétaire
pour des entreprises industrielles ou de
services dans les dromes évidemment les
discussions au Sénat sur le budget
outre-mer seront aussi très importants
monsieur Cozic
dans les critiques que vous formulez les
différentes critiques que vous formulez
sur ce PLF je retiendrai une qui est la
critique que vous nous faites de je cite
subventionné des énergies fossiles et
c'est vrai et je trouve qu'on
subventionne encore trop les énergies
fossiles et je souhaiterais qu'on
subventionne moins les énergies fossiles
évidemment mais subventionner les
énergies fossiles dans ce texte ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire le bouclier est
tarifaire qui permet de limiter la
hausse du prix du gaz qui est une
énergie fossile c'est vrai que c'est
très concret pour les Français de ne pas
avoir à payer 160 euros par mois en plus
sur leur facture de gaz l'an prochain et
d'avoir une hausse seulement de 15% au
lieu de 120%, ça implique effectivement
que les finances publiques
subventionnent d'une certaine manière en
tout cas viennent compenser la hausse du
prix du gaz pour les Français c'est ce
que j'imagine ce que vous appelez en
partie subventionnellement des énergies
fossiles évidemment qu'on souhaiterait
s'en passer mais je n'imagine pas que
nous ne prenions pas des mesures face à
cette explosion des prix de l'énergie
partout dans le monde qui a un impact
sur le pouvoir d'achat des Français de
la même manière
c'est sûr que ça ne faisait pas entre
guillemets plaisir au sens de l'ambition
que nous avons de la transition du
subventionnement plutôt à la transition
qu'aux énergies fossiles de faire la
restante carburant cette année qui nous
aura coûté 8 milliards d'euros mais
c'était nécessaire je crois d'avoir
cette investissement pour faire en sorte
de limiter au maximum la facture des
Français ça aura fait économiser 120
euros de essence à un automobilisme
moyen en France je pense que c'était
nécessaire dans le moment que nous avons
traversé nous allons passer à un
dispositif ciblé l'an prochain aussi
pour garder des marges de manoeuvre pour
continuer à renforcer nos dispositifs de
soutien à la conversion des véhicules
avec le bonus écologique et la prime à
la conversion je vais rappeler quand
même les engagements qui ont été pris
extrêmement forts sur le sujet on veut
être le premier grand pays à sortir des
énergies fossiles on s'en donne je crois
les moyens avec le réinvestissement dans
des sources d'énergie des carbonées je
pense à réinvestissement massif dans le
nucléaire je pense au développement
massif des énergies renouvelables je
pense aussi à des mesures fortes nous
avons prises à la suite de la conférence
de Glasgow qui se retrouve aussi dans
les textes budgétaires c'est la fin des
garanties à l'export pour les projets
fossiles et je rappelle que la France a
été le premier pays au monde en 2017 à
interdire la recherche et l'exploitation
d'énergie fossiles sur son sol ça me
semble être des engagement majeur et je
crois qu'ils sont très largement
partagés monsieur Bocquet vous avez
parlé dans les années à venir dans la
trajectoire du gouvernement je cite
d'une baisse des dépenses des
collectivités territoriales je veux sur
ce point vous rassurer il n'est
absolument pas prévu dans la trajectoire
budgétaire qui est la nôtre de faire
baisser les dépenses des collectivités
territoriales ce que nous souhaitons
c'est que globalement la dépense
publique soit maîtrisée dans les années
à venir mais quel progresse qu'elle
progresse de manière maîtrisée en
l'occurrence les collectivités
territoriales auront dépensé cette année
295 milliards d'euros dans la
trajectoire que nous avons proposé en
2027 c'est 326 milliards d'euros de
dépenses donc 31 milliards d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires dans de cinq
années qui viennent d'ici à 5 ans donc
on voit que les dépenses vont continuer
à progresser évidemment c'est légitime
face aux enjeux qu'on évoque
régulièrement dans cette hémicycle la
transition écologique la transition
démographique la transition numérique
évidemment qu'on a besoin que les
collectivités continuent à dépenser à la
fois en investissement et en
fonctionnement d'ailleurs je suis pas là
à dire que les dépenses ne
fonctionnement doivent baisser de
manière brutale on parle simplement
d'une maîtrise dans la progression pour
les collectivités comme pour l'État ce
qui me semble sain parce que si on n'est
pas capable de montrer si on n'est pas
capable de montrer que la croissance de
nos dépenses est maîtrisée le risque
auquel nous faisons face c'est une
explosion de nos taux d'intérêt qui aura
un impact sur la dette de l'État mais
qui aura aussi un impact sur les
collectivités territoriales parce que
pour mener à bien des projets
d'investissement elles ont besoin
d'emprunter et avec des taux d'intérêt
qui exploseraient elles ne pourraient
plus emprunter dans des mêmes conditions
pour réaliser des projets attendus par
tous les Français en matière de
transition écologique notamment je veux
rappeler que sur les contrats de
confiance
dans le projet qui a été soumis on parle
bien des 500 plus grandes collectivités
qui seraient concernées par les
incitations que vous avez rappelé c'est
un sans plus grande collectivités qui
ont un budget supérieur à 40 millions
d'euros je voulais le préciser puisque
je vais pas laisser penser que c'est un
dispositif qui s'adresse à l'ensemble
des collectivités territoriales mais
évidemment au plus grandes vous avez
posé la question de l'autonomie des
collectivités locales et du fait que ça
ne respecterait pas la Constitution moi
j'ai le souvenir que cette question
avait été posée au moment des contrats
de Cahors et que le Conseil
constitutionnel a jugé qu'ils étaient
conformes à la Constitution or là on est
très loin des contrats de Cahors dans
les contrats de confiance et d'ailleurs
un certain nombre de d'associations
d'élus l'on dit je cite intercommunalité
de France qui a dit texto le
gouvernement tourne la page des contrats
de Cahors avec ce dispositif je pense à
l'Assemblée des départements de France à
son président François Sauvadet qui
m'ont indiqué que ce dispositif leur
convenait dès lors qu'on sortait les is
et qu'on retraitait les is des dépenses
prises en compte ce à quoi j'ai donné un
avis favorable constant depuis le début
des discussions monsieur Bocquet
toujours je veux là aussi rassurer sur
le fait que nous ne baissons pas le
budget de l'hébergement d'urgence
heureusement et au contraire nous avons
augmenté le budget de l'hébergement
d'urgence comme aucun gouvernement et
aucune majorité ne l'ont augmenté le
budget l'hébergement d'urgence en 2017
c'est un milliard 700 millions d'euros
quand Emmanuel Macron a été élu en 2023
l'an prochain dans ce PLF c'est 2
milliards 800 millions d'euros c'est à
dire une augmentation d'un milliard 100
millions d'euros pour l'hébergement
d'urgence en 5 ans ça me semble pas être
une baisse une saignée une coupe le
nombre de places est passé de 110 000 à
200 000 et nous avons par ailleurs créé
000 places supplémentaires de pension de
famille d'intermédiation locative moi je
le dis nous avons beaucoup augmenté nos
places notamment pendant le covid parce
qu'il y avait un confinement et qu'il
fallait héberger des personnes sans
domicile il y a eu c'est vrai au départ
dans ce PLF je l'ai défendu en
interministérielle je l'assume une
volonté de réduire de commencer à
réduire la voilure sur l'hébergement
d'urgence
notamment aussi sur le coût des nuités
hôtelières qui est objectivement
beaucoup trop élevé et parfois avec des
intermédiaires qui font beaucoup de
profits sur ce sujet là de manière
objectivement induite l'arbitrage qui a
été rendu finalement par Matignon a été
de dire que nous ne serions pas ces
économies en 2023 dont acte mais moi je
redis que on peut aussi évidemment
chercher à trouver des marges
supplémentaires y compris sur ce sujet
là et notamment sur le tarif dénuitées
hôtelières madame Vermeillet vous avez
abordé la question des super profits et
moi je veux pas me paraphraser par
rapport à ce que j'ai dit en discussion
générale dans mon intervention liminaire
mais on a eu ce débat l'été dernier dans
le PLFR et à l'époque on a renvoyé à la
discussion européenne et on nous a dit
pour renvoyer la discussion européenne
pour enjamber le sujet on a eu un accord
européen il y a dans le texte que vous
examinez une captation des super profits
qui est prévue pour les secteurs de
l'énergie qui ont bénéficié de rente
indu liée à pas une explosion et pour
une part spéculative des prix de
l'énergie au niveau européen et au
niveau mondial nous on considère que les
super profits il faut aller les chercher
dans les secteurs qui bénéficient
indument d'une spéculation d'une
inflation sur les prix de l'énergie il y
a des entreprises qui ont vu leur
profits augmenter c'est vrai mais il y a
beaucoup d'entreprises qui ont vu leur
profit augmenter sans que ça n'est rien
à voir avec la crise que nous traversons
parce que l'entreprise a été redressée
parce qu'elle a fait des efforts parce
qu'elle a innové pourquoi alors elle est
capter ces profits ces gains qui sont
liés à une politique d'innovation une
politique d'investissement une politique
de redressement d'entreprise nous on
considère que ce qui n'est pas légitime
d'aller pénaliser entre guillemets ces
entreprises là et on pense au contraire
qu'il faut garder une forme de stabilité
qui a été l'anneau depuis 2017 pour
susciter l'investissement l'innovation
et l'attractivité économique de notre
pays mais nous aurons ce débat comme
nous l'avons eu cet été au moment de vos
amendements monsieur requier monsieur le
Président Roquier vous avez AB poser la
question de la prévision de croissance
la prévision est toujours difficile
c'est un art difficile comme l'on dit
beaucoup c'est d'autant plus difficile
quand on fait face aux aléas tels que
ceux que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
autour de la gare en Europe la crise
immobilière en Chine
l'inflation réduction Act aux États-Unis
qui fait peser un risque sur nos
industries en Europe les évolutions
politiques en Italie et le possible
impact sur leur trajectoire des finances
publiques et sur la zone euro les
risques d'approvisionnement en énergie
pour nos voisins allemands en matière de
gaz cet hiver tout ça c'est quand même
des nuages qui s'amoncellent au dessus
de nous et oui qui font peser un aléa
sur l'activité économique moi je veux
paraphraser pour le coup le Haut Conseil
des finances publiques qui a jugé nos
prévisions en matière de croissance en
matière d'inflation crédible et je vais
au bout puisque je suis évidemment
transparent qui a considéré que notre
prévision de croissance était peut-être
je cite un peu élevé bon moi je crois
profondément qu'avec les mesures qui
sont prévues dans ce PLF notamment pour
soutenir l'activité économique dans
notre pays grâce à l'amortisseur sur les
prix de l'énergie grâce oui à la baisse
des impôts de production grâce aux
mesures que nous prenons pour susciter
l'activité économique nous pourrons
avoir une croissance positive et
évidemment je l'espère atteindre la
prévision qui est la nôtre l'an prochain
madame Lavarde et Monsieur sotarel aussi
puisque vous êtes intervenu aussi sur ce
sujet et cette question des économies
moi je veux rappeler quand même quand on
parle de dépenses publiques
rythme des dépenses publiques dans les
trois précédents quinquennat
2007 2012 augmentation de 1,4% en volume
2012 2017 augmentation de 1% en volume
ça dépend publique a moins progressé
dans le quinquennat de François Hollande
que dans celui Nicolas Sarkozy
2017-2022
09% en volume premier quinquennat Macron
- encore que quelqu'un qui n'a précédent
et dans la trajectoire que nous vous
proposons c'est 06 % de progression en
volume dans le quinquennat qui vient
donc le rythme de la maîtrise de la
progression des dépenses publiques la
plus forte depuis au moins 15 ans dans
notre pays ça me semble pas être des
vannes totalement ouvertes et la dépense
publique qui s'envole ou qui
s'envolerait en France c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'on est régulièrement critiqué
ou certains nous accusent de faire de
l'austérité ce qui est pas du tout le
cas mais en tout cas on assume le
sérieux budgétaire et la maîtrise des
dépenses publiques
vous avez indiqué madame lavardte que
nous étions entrés dans le covid avec
des finances publiques dégradées dégradé
peut-être par plusieurs décennies de
laisser aller budgétaire moi je veux
quand même rappeler que le Président de
la République qui le déficit sous les
trois pourcents c'est quand même
Emmanuel Macron en 2018 nous avons
ramené le déficit sous les 3% avant la
crise covid et nous avons fait et nous
avons fait pour cela des efforts des
efforts qui ont été faits très
importants au début du précédent
quinquennat qui avait donné lieu à des
débats très importants je pense
notamment à la suppression des contrats
aidés ça a été très difficile ça fait
beaucoup de débats ça a été une économie
importante au début du précédent
quinquennat qui nous a permis d'assainir
nos finances publiques mais oui nous
avions ramené le déficit sous les 3%
avant la crise covid et nous avons donc
d'autant plus l'ambition de le faire
d'ici à la fin de ce quinquennat
s'agissant madame l'avare monsieur
sotarelle des réformes des économies oui
évidemment qu'il faut en faire on a
adopté à l'Assemblée nationale enfin
d'ailleurs est adopté définitivement je
crois la réforme de l'assurance chômage
qui est une réforme importante
nous proposerons dans les prochaines
semaines une réforme des retraites qui
doit permettre une économie budgétaire
de 9 milliards d'euros horizon 2027
ainsi que des recettes fiscales et
sociales de 12 milliards d'euros en plus
à horizon 2027 comme estimé par la DG
trésor grâce à l'amélioration du taux
d'emploi dans notre pays on a par
ailleurs des réformes qui sont prévues
dans les textes budgétaires que l'on
discute en ce moment qui sont jamais
faciles parce qu'il y a toujours
évidemment une forme de contestation
d'opposition quand on propose 250
millions d'euros d'économies sur le
secteur de la biologie médicale c'est
sûr que ça crée du débat c'est sûr que
c'est difficile moi j'assume de demander
à un secteur qui a bénéficié d'un
chiffre d'affaires de 7 milliards
d'euros du fait des tests covid et qui a
une marge brute qui est passée de 18% à
30% en moyenne de lui demander un effort
d'économie de 150 millions d'euros par
an dans les années à venir mais voilà on
voit qu'il y a une contestation il y a
une greffe pendant trois jours des
laboratoires d'analyses nous faisons cet
effort quand on propose dans ce PLF des
économies de 800 millions d'euros sur
les coûts dans les CFA pour
l'apprentissage c'est sûr que c'est
difficile on a une discussion qui est
difficile avec les CFA parce que ça
demande des efforts mais on assume de
leur demander et vous aurez à discuter
d'une économie supplémentaire de 800
millions d'euros que nous proposons sur
le compte personnel de formation le CPF
pour assainir la situation budgétaire de
France compétence je pourrais parler
encore longtemps de ces sujets je
voulais m'arrêter sur la question que
vous avez abordée qui nous tient tous à
cœur qui est celle des voitures
électriques c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
80% des véhicules électriques sont
importés et c'est vrai du coup que notre
soutien financier pour les Français qui
changent de véhicule avec la prime à la
conversion au bonus écologique va en
grande partie à des véhicules importés à
des véhicules chinois c'est pour ça que
nous devons continuer à agir pour une
vraie filière souveraine de véhicules
électriques en France on a quand même
réussi à faire émerger trois projets de
gigafactory de batterie électrique dans
notre pays notamment à Douvrin les
premières batteries électriques
françaises vont sortir dans les
prochains mois des usines c'est quand
même un point je pense qui dont on peut
se réjouir collectivement et on va
évidemment continuer à agir sur ce sujet
là c'est d'autant plus important vous
continuez à agir avec le plan France
2030 je rappelle 5 milliards d'euros
pour le secteur automobile dont un
milliard d'euros spécifique pour les
sous-traitants du secteur automobile
pour qu'il puisse se diversifier et
s'adapter et s'adapter à
l'électrification du parc mais c'est
évidemment essentiel de continuer à agir
et je fais le lien avec l'intervention
de Monsieur Capu qui ensuite a parlé de
la baisse des impôts de production oui
ça nécessite qu'on continue à agir aussi
pour l'attractivité de notre pays la
compétitivité de notre pays pour le
développement des filières industrielles
d'autant plus au moment où les
États-Unis se lancent avec l'inflation
réduction actes dans une forme il faut
l'assumer de dumping qui met en danger
qui fragilise notre industrie en France
et en Europe c'est pour ça qu'on veut
poursuivre évidemment notre baisse des
impôts de production et la suppression
de la CVAE je vous indiquer monsieur
Capu vous en avez parlé que la DG trésor
estime qu'avec la suppression de la CVE
nous devrions pouvoir bénéficier court
terme de 0,7 points de PIB
supplémentaire et que cette suppression
créerait 120 000 emplois supplémentaires
à terme dont 57000 des 2025 donc oui il
y aurait un impact sur notre industrie
sur notre économie pour favoriser la
création d'emploi et je le dis infinie
derrière les recettes de l'État puisque
plus il y a de Français qui travaillent
plus il y a de recettes pour l'État et
pour notre modèle social si on avait le
taux d'emploi de nos voisins allemands
j'aurais beaucoup moins de travail pour
trouver des économies et pour équilibrer
les comptes parce que la réalité c'est
que on aurait des finances publiques
beaucoup plus équilibrées grâce aux
recettes induites par un taux d'emploi
meilleur que celui que nous avons
aujourd'hui d'où l'enjeu de continuer à
investir pour la formation
l'apprentissage et de faire la réforme
des retraites je continue pour aller
plus rapidement monsieur patient vous
avez abordé les questions de pouvoir
d'achat et oui je rappelle que ce texte
ce PLF est aussi un PLF de pouvoir
d'achat grâce aux bouclier tarifaires
grâce à l'indexation du barème de
l'impôt sur le revenu sur l'inflation
c'est 6 milliards de 100 millions
d'euros rendus sur ce sujet Monsieur
Madame pardon briquet sur la question
des inégalités bon je vais pas refaire
toute la liste de ce qui a été porté
pour soutenir les foyers les ménages les
plus modestes pendant la crise covid ou
pendant la crise de l'inflation depuis
maintenant plus d'un an mais je n'ai pas
d'exemple comparable de pays comparables
en Europe qui est dépensé autant que
nous l'avons fait pour accompagner
financièrement les ménages les plus
modestes je n'ai pas d'exemple
sincèrement et j'espère que dans les
débats on aura l'occasion de poursuivre
cet échange et que vous aurez des
exemples à me donner de pays qui
auraient davantage soutenu qui aurait
davantage investi de l'argent pour
soutenir les ménages les plus modestes
dans leur pays sincèrement je serai
vraiment preneur d'avoir un exemple
monsieur delcrot vous allez abordé la
question notamment de l'emploi public et
vous avez appelé à ne pas faire de
coupes comptables dans l'emploi public
évidemment je vous rejoins sur ce point
là le mandat qui m'a été confié par la
première ministre c'est une
stabilisation de l'emploi public sur le
quinquennat qui arrive ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il n'y aura pas de suppression
de postes puisqu'on ne s'est engagé sur
des créations massives 8500 postes en
plus dans la justice 8500 postes en plus
dans la police et la gendarmerie
plusieurs milliers en plus dans les
armées ça veut dire qu'il faudra en
trouver autant de l'autre côté pour
avoir des marges de manoeuvre évidemment
mon ministère Bercy qui est le premier
pourvoyeur d'économie en emploi depuis
des années il sera encore mis à
contribution mais on en trouvera aussi
j'espère des marges ailleurs il faut que
ces marges on les trouve évidemment
qu'elle soit le fruit de réforme et de
modernisation c'est ce que nous avons su
faire à Bercy ces dernières années je
veux saluer l'engagement des agents
monsieur Joly vous aviez aussi abordé la
question des inégalités donc ça rejoint
la réponse que j'ai faite à Madame
briquet et enfin Monsieur capot canelas
je veux rejoindre votre vœu votre
souhait que nous arrivions à dans ce
débat trouver collectivement le plus
largement possible des solutions qui
nous permettent de répondre aux
préoccupations des Français et de tenir
l'équilibre de nos comptes et je crois
madame la Présidente que je n'ai pas
débordé d'une minute les 20 minutes qui
mettaient confiées
presque pas merci infiniment la
discussion générale est close nous
allons examiner l'article liminaire
présenté par le gouvernement monsieur le
ministre vous avez à nouveau la parole
merci madame la Présidente effectivement
c'est un amendement qui propose une
actualisation de l'article linéaire par
rapport au texte adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale et je vais vous dire comment
elle s'est actualisation se décompose il
y a d'abord une mise à jour des mesures
énergies nous allons nous réduisons les
recettes de CSPE attendu de CSPE donc
contribution pour l'électricité de 4,4
milliards d'euros dont 3,5 milliards
d'euros de réévaluation de l'effet de
sortie des contrats 0,9 milliards pour
les dispositifs oui 09 milliards pour le
dispositif de soutien à la cogénération
en gros on a des contrats CSPE avec des
énergéticiens qui prévoit que lorsque le
prix de marché est au-dessus du prix que
nous avons fixé avec eux dans les
contrats qui nous conduisaient à leur
verser des subventions